HEARING PUBLIC SAFETY BUT JUST
A FIVE. THANK YOU TO EVERYONE
IS JOINING US I HAVE BEEN ASKED
TO READ SOME DIRECTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING. HELP INSURE
THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE
TODAY. WHILEALLOWING PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. TODAY
ROOM FOR THIRTY SEVEN IT WE ARE
HAVING TO PHYSICALLY DISTANT
AND PERSON HEARING. WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTENT IN A STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA OF THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA.
THREE KEEPS SIXTY THE SPACING.
THERE ARE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IN PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. ARREST
DATE THIS WHEN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT AGAINST BUT IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THEIR
OWN WISHES SPEAK. THEY WILL
RAISE THEIR HANDS AND I LASSEN
TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. WE
WILL ALSO HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
VIA TELEPHONE. WE WILL HAVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER WE HAVE
HEARD. ALL ITEMS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. I WOULD AFTER THE
PUBLIC RESPECT SICKLE
DISTANCING AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU- YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT IS
DONE OR RETURN TO YOUR SEAT BUT
PLEASE OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IN APPALLING IN THE
CAPITAL. INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. THE PALACE ALLEY- AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RPA
REMOTELY TODAY. ASSET EVERYONE
SILENCE ELECTRONIC DEVICES AND
FEET MEET YOURSELF WHEN YOU'RE
NOT SPEAKING. THERE WILL BE NO
VOTE INTO THIS COMMITTEE.
TODAY'S HEARING WILL FOCUS ON
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND A CROSSOVER
ISSUE FROM THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. IN ADDITION TO
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL WILL BE
DISCUSSED IN A PROPOSAL FOR
MORE HEARINGS AND CIVIL MATTERS.
MORE HEARING CAN PROVIDE
EFFICIENCY AND CONVENIENCE OF
THE PRODUCERS AND THE COURTS.
BUT IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS ARE
CRITICAL TO TRULY UNDERSTAND
THE IMPACT. FINALLY WILL BE WE
WILL BE DISCUSSING THE NEW
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION AN OFFICE THAT WILL
OVERSEE THE ENTIRE JUVENILE
JUSTICE CONTINUE ON. WHEN THAT
CONTINUES TO BE OVER
REPRESENTED BY BLACK AND BROWN
YOUTH IN ORDER TO SUCCESSFULLY
CARRY OUT ITS MISSION. IN IS
THE APPROPRIATE INVESTMENT OUR
CHILDREN THE SERVICE. THANK YOU
TO ALL OUR PANELISTS JOINING US
TODAY I LOOK FORWARD TO TODAY'S
DISCUSSION AFTER EACH PANEL I
WILL OPEN IT UP. PERCEPT
COMMITTEE MEMBER QUESTIONS. OUR
FIRST ISSUE IS THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH A REVIEW MAINTENANCE
CONSTRUCTION PROPOSALS. WE'LL
BEGIN OUR FIRST PANEL ON ISSUE
ONE AND PANELISTS WILL SPEAK IN
THE ORDER LISTED IN THE AGENDA.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE
SUBCOMMITTEE LET'S BEGIN.
I CAN
HEAR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ARMS LUCK WITH YOUR SEARCH FROM
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL BUDGET
SERVICES NOW PROVIDE YOU A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH OF THE MISSION OF THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH TO RESOLVE
DISPUTES ARISING UNDER THE LAW
AND TO ENTER PLIVA LAW
CONSISTENTLY IMPARTIALLY AND
INDEPENDENTLY TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS AND LIBERTIES GUARANTEED
BY THE CONSTITUTION TO
CALIFORNIA IN THE UNITED STATES
AND IS BETTER ACCESSIBLE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT MANNER.
DIGITAL BRANCH CONSISTS OF THE
SUPREME COURT SIX COURTS OF
APPEAL DISTRICTS AS WELL AS
FIFTY A TRIAL COURTS THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL INCLUDING ALSO
PROBE AND HABEAS CORPUS
RESOURCE CENTER BY THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH RECEIVES MOST FUNDING
FROM THE GENERAL FUND
SPECIFICALLY THE BUDGET
INCLUDES TOTAL FUNDING OF FOUR
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS TWO
POINT THREE BILLION GENERAL
FUND AND TO. ANOTHER FUNDS FOR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FOR THE
BRANCH OF WHICH TWO POINT FOUR
BILLION IS PROVIDED TO SUPPORT
TRUCKLOAD OPERATIONS THE TRUCK
ARTICLE OF THE COMBINATION
GENERAL FUND. COUNTY
MAINTENANCE EVER. CAN YOU MAKE
THIS EFFORT. FROM ALL FINE
ITSELF AND OTHER REVENUES AS
FEDERAL FUNDS. THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL'S THE POLICY MAKE BODY
OF COURTS THE LARGEST COURTS IN
THE NAY. LEADERSHIP OF THE
CHIEF JUSTICE AND ACCORDS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION THE
COUNCIL IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENSURING A CONSISTENT AND
INDEPENDENT. IMPARTIAL AND
ACCESSIBLE ADMINISTRATION OF
JUSTICE JUDICIAL COUNCIL STAFF
HELPED IMPLEMENT THE COUNCIL'S
POLICIES. IN TERMS OF THE
BUDGET THE GOVERNOR'S AMENDED
BUDGET REFLECTS IMPORTANT
PROPOSALS THE BRANCH FUNDING
THAT WILL SYSTEM PROVIDING
ACCESS TO JUSTICE SOME OF THESE
PROPOSALS INCLUDE. RUSSIAN TOO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
BUDGET OPTIONS. FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THAT WAS INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
THIS FUNDING IS TO BE RESTORED
FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
SEVENTY TWO POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR TRUCK OPERATIONAL
COST INCREASES. NINETEEN POINT
ONE FOR SELF HELP SERVICES
EXPANSION OF OURBILLET ABILITY
TO PAY PROGRAM FOR TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS. TRAILER BILL IF
YOU WISH TO AUTHORIZE REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS AND CIVIL MATTERS.
TWO POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
OVER FIVE YEARS FOR ADDITIONAL
COURTHOUSE CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM
NUMBER EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO ADDRESS CRITICAL TRIAL AND
APPELLATE COURT FACILITY NEEDS.
AS ALWAYS WE'RE HERE TO ANSWER
ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE ABOUT BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS. LISTED IN THE
AGENDA. NOW WILL HAVE AN S.
EVERHART THE COURT EXECUTIVE
OFFERS FROM THE SAN BERNARDINO
SUPERIOR COURT TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE IMPACTS
OF THE PANDEMIC. ON TRIAL COURT
OPERATIONS ANOTHER CHOPPER TO
RESPOND TO THE PANDEMIC AFTER
DANCE PRESENTATION WILL ALSO
HAVE ROBERT A YOUNG. JUDICIAL
COUNCIL CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
TO PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
PANDEMIC RELATED DATA. ON FOR
YOUR INFORMATION. SO THAT WILL
HAVE IT WILL HAVE MISS
EVERHART. PRESENTS. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT CHAIR THE
IS NANCY HURTS SAN BERNADINE
STICKER COURT. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC ON THE
STATE COURTS FURTHER IMPACTED
BY SUDDEN AND SEVERE
REDUCTIONS. TO THE BRANCH
BUDGET AND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE CHALLENGES
FACED BY THE COURTS AND
PROVIDING ACCESS DURING THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY. I'VE BEEN
DIFFICULT BUT ALSO NOT PROVIDED
OPPORTUNITY FOR INNOVATION AT
THE SAME TIME. JUSTICE IS BY
NATURE SOCIAL UNDERTAKING THAT
REQUIRES GROUPS TO COME
TOGETHER TO DELIBERATE AND
RESOLVE ISSUES. SOCIAL
DISTANCING INADEQUATE
FACILITIES REDUCTIONS IN
STAFFING DUE TO QUARANTINE
BUDGETARY INDUCED VACANCIES
FURLOUGHS AND LAYOFFS EFFORT OR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
OUR COMMUNITIES. FILE COURTS
REALLOCATED OPERATIONS FUNDS
OUT THERE ARE COURTS IN
RESPONSE BY RECONFIGURING COURT
SPACE LEASING ADDITIONAL SPACE
IMPLEMENTING REMOTE HEARINGS
REMOTE SELF HELP REMOTE
STREAMING TO PROMOTE
ALTERNATIVE ACCESS. WE PROVIDED
TELECOMMUTING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STAFF AND ALTERNATIVES TO
BRINGING IN JURY PANELS. WE
REALLOCATED STAFF TO PROVIDE
CONTACT TRACING REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS MANAGEMENT
ADDITIONAL STAGGER CALENDARS TO
ADDRESS SOCIAL DISTANCING
ADDITIONAL JANITORIAL TRIAGE
AND SECURITY JUST TO NAME A FEW
THESE CHANGES HAVE GIVEN US
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITIES TO THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX ABOUT SERVICE
DELIVERY AND A PATH FORWARD
POST PANDEMIC. WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR AND SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
BUDGET SO WE CAN BEGIN TO
RESTORE SERVICES TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AS HEALTH ORDERS
ALLOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT PERCENT. HI MY
NAME IS ROBERT THE YOUNG I AM
THE CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER FOR
JUDICIAL COUNCIL I JUST WANTED
TO SHARE WITH YOU- A COUPLE OF
QUICK. DATAPOINTS REGARDING THE
EFFECT OF THE PANDEMIC ON THE
COURTS I'M OVER ALL. DURING BY
TWENTY TWENTY COMPARED TO
TWENTY NINETEEN. FILINGS WERE
DOWN BY ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
PERCENT. ARE AT THAT SAME
PERIOD OF TIME DISPOSITIONS
WERE DOWN BY 50% SO ALTHOUGH
THE NUMBER OF FILINGS WERE DOWN
BY TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT. COURTS
WERE ONLY ABLE TO PROCESS ABOUT
HALF AS MANY DISPOSITION. AND
TWENTY TWENTY COMPARED TO
TWENTY NINETEEN. DUE TO
PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS. AND STAFF
AVAILABILITY AND FINALLY THE
LAST PIECE OF DATA I WANT TO
SHARE WITH THAT FOOT TRAFFIC
INTO THE COURTHOUSES- WAS
REDUCED APPROXIMATELY BY
SEVENTY PERCENT- SO AGAIN WHILE
FILINGS WERE DOWN BY ABOUT
TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT. FOOT
TRAFFIC WITH DOWN BY 70% AND SO
THIS IMPLIES THAT- THE PUBLIC
HAS BEEN CONTINUING TO. CONFIRM
THAT THEIR BUSINESS WITH THE
COURTS. THROUGH ONLINE- AND
REMOTE MEANS THROUGH VIDEO- OR-
ELECTRONICALLY. AND THAT
CONCLUDES THE S. R. POINTS I
WANT TO MAKE THANK YOU. THANK
YOUR NECK CAR PURCHASE. YEAH
MADAM CHAIR WILL HAVE HELLO. A
PROVIDED. OF THE VARIOUS
MAINTENANCE AND SCRIPT
CONSTRUCTION BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL AS DESCRIBED IN THE
AGENDA. OKAY THANK YOU BARCO
MADAM CHAIR. THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL FACILITY PROGRAM
SUPPORTS CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT COURTS OF APPEAL IN TRIAL
COURTS HI PROVIDING BUILDINGS
PLANNING DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION FACILITIES
OPERATIONS AND REAL ESTATE
SERVICES. BUT PORTFOLIO
CONSISTS OF FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FACILITIES WITH OVER TWO
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
COURT ROOMS ACROSS THE STATE
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY NINE
MILLION SQUARE FEET. THERE IS
AN AVERAGE OF SIX THOUSAND
TICKET SERVICE ORDER. I REQUEST
PROCESS MONTHLY AND NEARLY A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FACILITY MODIFICATION
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS.
37% OF THE FACILITY THE
PORTFOLIO ARE OVER FIFTY YEARS
OLD AND NEARING THE END OF THE
SPOTLIGHT. REPORT BILLION
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG IS
OVER FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. THE
COURTHOUSE CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM
HAS COMPLETED THREE COURTS OF
APPEAL COURT HOUSES AND TWENTY
SIX TRIAL COURT PROJECTS WITH
THE TWO THOUSAND AND TWO TRIAL
COURT FACILITY FACT
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY FOR
COUNTY COURT FACILITIES TO THE
STATE. IN ADDITION TO THE
TWENTY SIX COMPLETED TRIAL
COURT PROJECTS TEN NEW TRIAL
COURT CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS ARE
ONGOING. PROJECTS WILL ACTIVATE
A HUNDRED FORTY COURT ROOMS AND
VACATE TWENTY TWO SUB STANDARD
FACILITIES YES MADE OF PROGRAM
COSTS IT'S. ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. OF THE CURRENT
CAR. TO OUR NEIGHBOR FINAL.
REVIEW MEETING ANSWER ARE UNDER.
QUALITY THING IF KEEPS RECAP
WILL BE THIS SPRING. THREE MORE
PROJECTS WILL COMPLETE IN
FISCAL TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND THE RECENTLY STARTED
EIGHTEEN STORY FIFTY THREE
COURTROOM SACRAMENTO COURTHOUSE
SCHEDULED FOR COMPLETION IN
FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET REQUIRE THE BEAUTIFUL
COUNCIL TO CONDUCT A RECESSED
BUTTON ALL TRIAL COURT CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS THAT HAD NOT
BEEN FULLY FUNDED PROJECT THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET BACK.
THE REASSESSMENT GENERATED
EIGHT POINT LEAD AT EIGHTY
TROUT FOR CAPITAL PROJECTS FOR
FORTY ONE FOR THE FIFTY EIGHT
COURT. WITH GREAT PRIDE WITH IT
THE BASIS FOR THE BRANCHES.
FIVE YEAR INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN.
THE PROJECTS FOR TIED ON MEET
THE COST BASED WITH BUILT
FORTY. RATING CRITERIA INCLUDED
J. BUSINESS CONDITION OF THE
BUILDING. AND EVALUATION OF
RISK ASSOCIATED WITH I THINK
AFTER THE FIRE LIFE SAFETY
CONDITION ADDITIONAL CRITERIA
INCLUDED ADEQUATELY. COURT
SECURITY FEATURES THE PUBLIC
ACCESS TO COURT SERVICES
SPECIAL OVERCROWDING THE
PROJECT COST THE COST REPORT
USER. BUT THE EIGHTY PROPOSED
TRIAL COURT PROJECT FIFTY SIX A
FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION TWENTY
FOUR OUR RENOVATION PROJECT.
THE TOTAL COST OF THE EIGHTY
PROJECT SIX IF THAT'S THE MADE
IT AT THIRTEEN POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS. THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL FIVE YEAR
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN INCLUDES
FOURTEEN PROJECTS WELL THE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT INTO OUR
STUDY. THAT PRIORITY ORDER
FOLLOWS THE RANKINGS DETERMINED
BY THE TWENTY NINETEEN IF THAT.
TO PROJECT INTO STUDIES BY
SUPER FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUT THREE ADDITIONAL
PROJECTS PARK EACH SUBSEQUENT
YEAR. JULY THE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT OR PROGRAM WITH
CONTEMPORARY INDUSTRY MATHIS
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS SEEKING
AUTHORITY VIA TRAILER BILL. TO
TRANSITION THE PROJECT DELIVERY
METHOD FOR MOST NEW
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS TO DESIGN
BUILD IN A DESIGN BUILD PROJECT
DESIGN CONSTRUCTION SERVICES
ARE CONTRACTED WITH A SINGLE
ENTITY KNOWN AS THE DESIGN
BUILDER. THE ADVANTAGES INCLUDE
REDUCTION IN ORDER LIABILITIES
AT THE DESIGN BUILDERS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR OWN
TERRORIST KIND OF PENSIONS
CONSTRUCTION STARTS EARLIER AND
COST CERTAINTY IS THE TRUTH.
CHEAP THEATER WITH SEVEN
MAINTENANCE CONSTRUCTION BUDGET
PROPOSALS RECORDED SUPPORT THE
FACILITY PROGRAMS MULTIPRONGED
STRATEGY TO ENSURE RELIABLE
SAFE AND FUNCTIONAL COURT WILL
BE FOR CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK WITH. JEFF
A REMINDER PARTMINER FINE AS
MENTIONED BY THE G. POWER THE
IMMEDIATE PACKAGE INCLUDES AN
AGREEMENT TO RESTORE THE TWO
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS ONGOING
REDUCTION FOR THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH THAT WAS INCLUDED IN A
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
SPECIFICALLY HUNDRED SEVENTY
SIX POINT NINE WILLIAM B. WILL
BE RESTORED TO THE TRIAL COURT
AND TWENTY THREE POINT ONE
MILLION WILL BE RESTORED FOR
THE STATE LOCAL JUDICIARY.
BEGINNING IN 212-120-2120 TWO
IN ONGOING THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
SHOULD USE THESE FUNDS TO MEET
THEIR CHANGING OPERATIONAL AND
PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS RESULTING
FROM THE PANDEMIC. IN ADDITION
THE BUDGET CONSOLIDATES THE
STATE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FUND IN THE
IMMEDIATE CRITICAL NEEDS
ACCOUNT WHICH ARE PRIMARY
FUNDING SOURCES FOR THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH FACILITIES
PROGRAM THIS FUND CONSOLIDATION
ALLOWS FOR THE STATE COURT
FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION WENT TO
REMAIN SOLVENT IN THE BUDGET
YEAR IN AVOID PRODUCING SERVICE
LEVELS FOR THE FACILITIES
PROGRAM. WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
CONSOLIDATED FUND WILL HAVE
SOLVENCY ISSUES IN FUTURE YEARS
AND WE APPRECIATE THE- L. A. AS
RECOMMENDED APPROACH SHIFTING
THESE FUNDS TO THE GENERAL FUND
THAT'S ONE POSSIBLE STRATEGY
FOR ADDRESSING THE ONGOING
PROBLEM. HOWEVER WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER OTHER
POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS INCLUDING
OPTIONS THAT DO NOT REQUIRE
SUCH A SIGNIFICANT IMMEDIATE
GENERAL FUND COMMITMENT. IN OR
WE AND WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO DO SO. AT
THE END THE IMMINENT SOLVENCY
OF THESE FUNDS IS ONE
MANIFESTATION OF A BROADER
PROBLEM RELATED TO DECLINING
FINING FEE REVENUES IN RECENT
YEARS. WHICH IS NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED A VARIETY OF RECIP
RECIPIENT FUNDS. ONE OF WHICH
WOULD BE THE TRIAL COURT TRUST
FUND. THEREFORE ANY SOLUTION.
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED IN THE
BROADER CONTEXT OF ADDRESSING
IT FOR THE OTHER SPECIAL FUNDS.
FOR NOW- FUND CONSOLIDATION
ALLOWS FOR THE FUND TO REMAIN
SOLVENT WITHOUT REDUCING
SERVICE LEVELS IN REQUIRING A
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION IN
THE BUDGET YEAR WHILE WE
DEVELOP A PERMANENT SOLUTION TO
ADDRESS THE INSOLVENCY. IN
THESE FUNDS AND OTHERS. THANK
YOU LET ME KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU AND ARE
BIGGER FOR THE PANEL. WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
SO FOR THE CONSTRUCTION
PROPOSALS THAT YOU HAVE BEFORE
YOU WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE AT MINIMUM
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
CONSOLIDATION BECAUSE IT DOES
DELAY THE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
INSOLVENCY AND THE BUDGET HERE
AND THERE REALLY IS NO
RATIONALE FOR MAINTAINING TWO
SEPARATE ACCOUNTS ONE BOTH OF
THEM ARE GOING TO BECOME
INSOLVENT. ANYWAYS I'M HOWEVER
AS A REFERENCE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THERE
ISN'T REALLY A PLAN TO ADDRESS
THAT'S INSOLVENCY PERMANENTLY
SO BECAUSE OF THAT WE ACTUALLY
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE GO
FURTHER BY ELIMINATING THE
ACCOUNTS AND SHIFTING FULL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR TRIAL COURT
CONSTRUCTION OVER TO THE
GENERAL FUND- AND THIS IS
BECAUSE ABSENT ANY CHANGES.
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES ARE GOING TO BE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT EXISTING
OBLIGATIONS WHICH IS MOST
NOTABLY THAT SERVICE FOR
COURTHOUSES THAT WE'VE ALREADY
COMPLETED CONSTRUCTION FOR AND
SO WE ESTIMATE THAT AROUND A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION COULD BE NEEDED
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND THAT'S
WHAT DECLINE OVER TIME AS
PROJECTS WERE PAID OFF BUT WE
LIKELY NEED GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES FOR THE NEXT SIXTEEN
YEARS AND SO OUR RECOMMENDATION
TO SHIFT THESE OBLIGATIONS OVER
WOULD PERMANENTLY ADDRESS THE
INSOLVENCY AND ENSURE THAT ANY
GENERAL FUND CONSTRUCTED
CONSTRUCTION RELATED
OBLIGATIONS ARE FULLY ACCOUNTED
FOR WHEN THE LEGISLATURE IS
CONSIDERING THE STATE'S FISCAL
CONDITION AND FIGURING OUT.
WHICH ARE OFTEN PRIORITIES. I
IN ONE WITH THE ELIMINATE OF
THE TWO. ACCOUNTS WE ARE ALSO-
RECOMMENDING SHIFTING OVER ALL
NON CONSTRUCTION RELATED
EXPENSES SUCH AS THE AMOUNT-
PROVIDED FOR TRIAL COURT
OPERATIONS AND HAVING AN
APPROPRIATION TO JUST MAINTAIN
THAT LEVEL OF SUPPORT. WE'RE
ALSO RECOMMENDING DEPOSITING
ALL OF THE REVENUE THAT WOULD
NORMALLY GO INTO THE
CONSTRUCTION ACCOUNTS INTO THE
GENERAL FUND INSTEAD SO THAT
THEY ARE STILL AVAILABE TO
OFFSET ALL OF THOSE EXPENDITURE
OBLIGATIONS THAT WERE SHIFTED
OVER. MOVING FORWARD WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING THE
GOVERNOR'S APPROACH TO FIND ANY
NEW TRIAL COURT CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS FULLY AWARE OF
THE TOTAL COSTS FOR ANY NEW
PROPOSED PROJECTS THE IMPACTS
THAT THE HAVE ON THE GENERAL
FUND. AND HOW LEGISLATURE GOING
TO WEIGH THEM AGAINST OTHER
PRIORITIES. HOWEVER WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DETERMINE WHICH SPECIFIC
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS TO FUND
BASED ON ITS PRIORITIES WHICH
MAY OR MAY NOT INCLUDE ANY OF
THE PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED. BY THE ADMINISTRATION
OR THE JUDICIAL BRANCH AND THE
BUDGET YEAR OR THE ADDITIONAL
TWELVE PROJECTS THAT ARE SLATED
TO COME ON BOARD IN THE NEXT
FOUR YEARS. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. NOT THANK
YOUNG ANNETTE OPEN IT UP TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- BUT BEFORE
THAT I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION- I
ACTUALLY HAVE TWO QUESTIONS.
THE FIRST ONE IS FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. AND IF THEY
CAN SPEAK TO WHAT THE DELAYS
ARE LOOKING LIKE FOR TRIALS AND
CIVIL MATTERS. ALL RIGHT NOW. I
KNOW THAT THERE'S CONCERN FOR
THE LACE LITIGANTS ARE FACING
PHOENIX THE NEXT PICK AND-
HARDSHIPS- AND SO WHEN THEY
NEED YOU SPEAK TO THAT AND TO
SPEAK OF THIS REGIONAL. OF
VARIANCE OR IF IT'S LOOKING THE
SAME ACROSS THE STATE. WE MIGHT
HAVE THAT ROBBO YOUNG
POTENTIALLY RESPOND TO THAT IF
THERE'S SUCH DATA DATA. WE HAVE
IN TERMS OF CIVIL ACT WORKLOAD
DELAYS. AND ANY REGIONAL
ISSUES. PROPERTY ABLE TO
PROVIDE ANY YEAH HI THIS IS.
DON THIS IS ROBERT YOUNG I AM
THE CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER I
HAVE A COUPLE OF PIECES OF DATA
REGARDING- CIVIL COME. CIVIL
CASES SO IN TERMS OF- DELAYS-
ONE SUCH DELAYS IN AROUND
CONTINUANCES OF FIRST CIVIL
CASES AND CRIMINAL CASES ON
AVERAGE- WE SEE- THERE'S A
DELAY ON AVERAGE ABOUT. ELEVEN
PERCENT. IN TERMS OF THE
CONTINUANCES BY AND THEN. WE
ALSO SEE AVERAGE NUMBER OF DAYS
A LAPSE FROM FILING TO
DISPOSITION BOB FOR CIVIL
UNLIMITED CASES HI THERE THAT
INCREASE THEIR- BY ABOUT
EIGHTEEN PERCENT- AND WE SEE
THAT VARYING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THERE'S- NOT. CONSISTENCY
ACROSS THE STATE IT VARIES BUT
ON AVERAGE. THE- THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE SEEING. AND THERE A DAY.
RECORD OF HOW I MEET WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH THESE
DELAYS AND MITIGATE THEM. SO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS- A
SET OF PROPOSALS- THAT WOULD
SUPPORT- MANY PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THE- EARLY PANDEMIC
DISPOSITION CALENDAR- WE'VE
GOT- SOME PROGRAMS IN THERE
THAT WOULD SUPPORT REMOTE
HEARINGS- AND SO SOME OF THOSE
WILL HELP OUT WITH THE DOLLARS.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES MISTER
LUCKY NUMBERS ARE STILL. YEAH
JUST REAL BRIEFLY IT APPEARS
THAT THE JUDICIAL BRANCH'S
BUDGET WITH THIS YEAR'S
ADDITIONAL SEVENTY TWO POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS PAIRED WITH
LAST YEAR'S ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SIX POINT NINE. A MILLION
LEAVES THE COURT FOR THE
PROXIMAL A ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT. AND
WHAT THAT DIVERSITY SUSTAINED
IN TWENTY TWENTY CUTS TO THE
COURTS WHY IS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TOP PRIORITY
TO EXPAND TO MAKE FUNDING
PERMANENT. FOUR TWO PILOT
PROGRAMS. EVERY FOR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FLEKKEN. IF YOU NEED
FOR YOUR OWN PERSONAL FINANCE
IF I MAY ASK. FOR THE ABILITY
TO PAID PILOT PROGRAM THAT WE
ARE ADDRESSING. NO YEAH YES
ACTUALLY IT IS. OKAY AND SOON
OUR PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE
TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE TARGETED
FINING KEY RELIEF TO
INDIVIDUALS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE A CALIFORNIA REGARDLESS
OF WHICH SUPERIOR WHAT RICK
REGARDLESS OF WHICH COUNTY THEY
ARE IN IN IN THE PROPOSAL IS ON
A TIERED APPROACH I STARTED
WITH TWELVE STARTING WITH JUST
OVER TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR AND THEN IT'S
ON A PHASED IN APPROACH WITH
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. SET ASIDE
IN THE ONGOING YEARS TO ROLL
OUT TO MORE COURTS ON A YEAR BY
YEAR BASIS- AND THEN FOR THE
SECOND HIGHWAY I WAS- TRYING TO
GET WHICH ONE YEAR THAT'S WHAT
YOUR DRESSING WITHOUT. I DON'T
REMEMBER. WHAT IS IT SELF HELP
SELF HELP. OKAY TO SELF HELP
WAS A NEW ISSUE INCLUDING THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT AS A
LIMITED TERM FUNDING AND THAT
IS SET TO EXPIRE AT THE END THE
CURRENT YEAR THE PROPOSAL IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WOULD
EXTEND THIS FUNDING ON GOING IN
THIS FUNDING GOES TO SUPPORT
OVER MILLION INDIVIDUALS EACH
YEAR WITH THROUGH CRITICAL SELF
HELP ISSUES WHICH HAVE ONLY
BEEN EXACERBATED SINCE THE
ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC. SO WE'RE
REALLY WE'RE SEEKING TO
CONTINUE THE NINETEEN POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS- EACH YEAR IN
AN ONGOING BASIS. OKAY THANK
YOU MR STONE. THANK YOU OF IT I
THINK JUST SOME GENERAL
COMMENTS AS OPPOSED TO
QUESTIONS BECAUSE WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE TOUCHING ON A LOT OF
THINGS WITH THIS ISSUE AND THEN
THE THREE PANELS THAT ARE
COMING UP WITH ISSUE NUMBER TWO
AS WELL. AND WHAT THE PANDEMIC
HAS REALLY SHOWN IS THAT. WE
DON'T HAVE THE SAME LEVEL OF
ACCESS TO JUSTICE IN ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COURTS AS I THINK WE
SHOULD STRIVE FOR. AARON WE'VE
BUILT OVER THE YEARS A BUDGET
FOR JUDICIAL COUNCIL FOR THAT
THE COURT SYSTEM. THAT IT HAS
BEEN BASED ON KIND OF BUILDING
UP FINES AND FEES AND MAY
HAVING MADE OTHER DECISIONS
THAT. THAT SHOW TO BE FAIRLY
SUSPECT NOW THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO SORT THROUGH HOW TO LOOK
INTO THE FUTURE AND I LOOK AT
SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS. AND
YES WE NEED SELF HELP. AND I
COMPLETELY AGREE THAT THE WORK
AROUND THE ABILITY TO PAY AS
WELL AS THE RELIANCE ON FINES
AND FEES. REALLY SHOW THE THAT
WE'VE BUILT. REVENUES FOR THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH CUTTING IN THE
WRONG WAY IT'S ALSO HARD FOR ME
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT TO DO WITH
THE- REMOTE CIVIL PROCEEDINGS
PIECE OF THE TRAILER BILL HERE
WITHOUT. ALL OF US HAVING A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
IMPACT THAT THE PANDEMIC HAS
HAD ON OUR COURTS D. TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEES ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE HELD A HEARING NOT
LONG AGO. THAT WAS TALK ABOUT
ACCESS TO JUSTICE IN THE CIVIL
LEGAL SYSTEM HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT IT SHOWS. IS THAT THE
ANSWER ABOUT ACCESS IS VERY
VERY DIFFERENT COURT TO COURT
AND THE COURTS DIDN'T REALLY
HAVE A GOOD EXPLANATION OF WHY
HOW THAT'S WORKING OR WHAT
THEY'RE WILLING TO DO ABOUT IT.
AND MEMBERS OF BOTH COMMITTEES
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEES EXPRESS A GREAT DEAL
OF WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE
COURTS TO FUND TO DO THE RIGHT
KINDS OF THINGS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE NECESSARY BUT WE LEFT AS
HE THAT HEARING. NOT SURE OF
WHAT DIRECTION WE SHOULD BE
GOING SO IF THIS IS THESE THREE
BUDGET PROPOSALS IS ALL THERE
IS. AND I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE
MORE BUDGET PROPOSALS THAT MAY
BE COMING OUT FROM JUDICIAL
BRANCH BUT IF THIS IS REALLY
ALL THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT WE
ARE TRULY WOEFULLY SHORT. OF A
BROAD SOLUTION OF ANSWERING THE
QUESTION ABOUT ACCESS WE HAVE
VERY INCONSISTENT STANDARDS.
COURT THE COURT AND IT SEEMS
EVEN COURTROOM TO COURTROOM
BECAUSE OF INDIVIDUAL JUDGES.
DECISIONS OF WHAT THEY'RE
WILLING TO DO OR NOT DO AROUND
THE PANDEMIC AND AROUND ACCESS
AND SO THAT LACK OF CONSISTENCY
I THINK. UNDERMINES THIS NOTION
OF BROAD ACCESS TO JUSTICE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I DON'T REALLY
SEE ENOUGH HEAR OR UNDERSTAND
WHAT TO DO WITH THESE PIECES IF
WE'RE GOING TO SOLVE THE
BROADER ACCESS ISSUE. THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC BUT ALSO AFTER THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE THOSE SAME.
WEAKNESSES IN THE SYSTEM AND
THE WAY WE FUNDED TRIAL COURTS.
STILL EXIST EXISTED BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND THEY ARE GOING TO
EXIST AFTER THE PANDEMIC SO I'M
KEEP HOPING THAT WE COULD WORK
WITH JUDICIAL COUNCIL THAT YOU
DISCUSS WOULD WORK WITH US. IN
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEIR NEEDS
REALLY ARE AND HOW WE RE THINK
THE SYSTEM CAN PROVIDE SOME
STRONGER CONSISTENCY. AMONG ALL
OF THE COURTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ON V. THE ISSUE OF
THE COURT FACILITIES FUNDING TO
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH WHAT
THE L. A. L. IS RECOMMENDING
THAT WE BRING THAT INTO THE
GENERAL FUND AND- BECAUSE OF
THESE FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN
FUNDING THE CORE CONSTRUCTION
ANYWAY HAVE BEEN. IN THE PAST
BROUGHT INTO THE GENERAL FUND
WHEN THE STATE WAS IN FISCAL
CRISIS THAT YOU SHOWS THAT THE
SORT OF FUNGIBILITY OF THOSE
FUNDS. THESE OF THE GENERAL
FUND SO I THINK WE SHOULD JUST
SORT OF DROPPED THE PRETENSE.
DEAL WITH THAT BUT THEN THAT
ALSO GIVES AND IT SHOULD GIVE
THE LEGISLATURE SOME BETTER
INPUT AND UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THE LONG TERM PLANS ARE A LOT
OF THE- PLANS THAT THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH IS WORKING ON FOR COURT.
CONSTRUCTION CORPS FACILITIES
IS MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS OLD
AND THIS IS COME UP IN THIS
COMMITTEE. A NUMBER OF TIMES SO
FOR US TO HAVE SOME STRONGER
OVERSIGHT IN THE DECISIONS THAT
ARE BEING MADE WHAT COURTS.
FACILITIES NEED TO BE MADE AND
WHAT WAS. PART OF A DECISION
TWENTY YEARS AGO ISN'T
NECESSARILY THE SAME WE
WOULDN'T SO TO COME TO THE SAME
CONCLUSION NOW SO FOR. THE
COURTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY UNDER
CONSTRUCTION IN MOVING FORWARD
I THINK THAT'S FINE. BUT COURTS
OTHER COURT CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS THAT ARE IN THE
PIPELINE I THINK WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE.
ADDRESSING THE CURRENT NEEDS.
OF WHERE THOSE FACILITIES NEED
TO BE BUILT. SO THAT WE HAVE A-
AGAIN THIS IS THIS IS THAT
ACCESS TO JUSTICE ISSUE THAT'S
BEEN BROUGHT UP TIME AND TIME
AGAIN. THAT WE KNOW WHERE THOSE
FACILITIES ARE GOING TO GO IN
AND THAT THEY'RE GOING INTO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED THEM THE
MOST RATHER THAN JUST WHAT HAVE
BEEN ON THE BOOKS. FOR THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS. SO FOR US TO
BRING THOSE. THESE PARTS OF
MONIES INTO THE GENERAL FUND
AND THE LEGISLATURE. HAVE
INSIGHT AND OVERSIGHT OVER THE
DECISION SICK IT MADE AND WHAT
THE PIPELINE IS I THINK IT'S
ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE. SO
THERE'S A LOT THERE'S THIS KIND
OF INTER TWINED IN WHAT I JUST
SAID THA HAVE TO DO WITH THIS
ISSUE. AND WITH THE WITH THE
NEXT ISSUES COMING UP. BUT IT'S
I WILL TELL YOU IT'S JUST HARD
FOR ME TO UNDERSTAND HOW. ALL
OF THIS. RELATES AND HOW WE
WRAP OUR HEADS AROUND. A SINGLE
BUDGET THIS YEAR FOR THE COURT
SYSTEM. AND TRYING TO ADDRESS
THE PANDEMICS AND I WOULD I
HOPE. AND I WAS SPEAKING FOR
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE'S AND I
WAS THE NOT THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEES. WHEN WE OFFERED
SOME HELP IN THE INTEGRATIVE
WILLINGNESS TO LOOK AT FISCALLY
WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP THE
COURTS. ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF
ACCESS THAT THEY NEED AS WE
COME OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC. BUT
SO FAR WHAT I'VE WHAT I'VE SEEN
FROM THE COURTS. I JUST LEASE
BECAUSE SCRATCHING MY HEAD I
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH
THESE PROPOSALS. THEY'RE NOT
COMPREHENSIVE. AND WE'RE
AGAINST WHAT OF PIECE MEALING
OUT HOW WE DEAL WITH THE COURTS
BUDGET. AS OPPOSED TO GETTING
OUR HANDS AROUND. THE BIGGER
PICTURE. SO CONSISTENCY IN
BUDGETING CONSISTENCY IN ACCESS
CONSISTENCY COURT TO COURT AND
COURTROOM TO COURTROOM. TO
ANSWER SOME OF THE- THE ACCESS
ISSUES AND THEN CONSISTENCY IN.
IN FUNDING AND HOW WE ADDRESS
THAT IN. REDUCING THE RELIANCE
OF THE COURTS FUNDING ON THE
FINES AND FEES. AND THIS KIND
OF EXTERNAL STRUCTURE. THAT
LEADS TO THINGS LIKE NEEDING TO
DO THE ABILITY TO PAY EXPANSION
PILOT PROGRAM. BECAUSE WE WE'VE
BUILT A SYSTEM WHERE THE
POOREST OF CALIFORNIANS WHO RUN
AFOUL OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
OUR REALLY DOUBLY PENALIZED
BECAUSE THE WE HAVE STACKED SO
MANY ADD ONS TO THE FINES THAT
THEY'RE GETTING WE WERE ADDING
ALL OF THESE FEES. THAT IT IT
IS DISPROPORTIONATELY LANDING
ON THOSE WHO REALLY CANNOT
AFFORD IT. THAT'S WHAT THESE
PROPELLER PROGRAMS ARE ABOUT SO
I THINK. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE TAKING A BROADER
LOOK AT COURTS FUNDING GETTING
THEM THE FUNDING THAT THEY NEED
WITHOUT HAVING TO DEAL WITH THE
MECHANISMS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
IN PLACE OVER THE YEARS TO
COBBLE TOGETHER. A COURTS
FUNDING SYSTEM BUT WE NEED TO
JUST CANCEL WORK WITH US ON
THIS WE NEED REALLY BETTER
RELATIONSHIPS AND BETTER
INFORMATION MOVING BETWEEN.
JUDICIAL BRANCH. THE BUDGET
SUBS AS WELL AS THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE'S BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
POLICY OVERSIGHT. OVER THOSE
COMMITTEES AND THEN REALLY GET
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THE COURTS. NEED TO BE DOING
AND HOW WE CAN BE HELPING THEM
THROUGH THIS BUDGET CYCLE PUT
IN PLACE THE PROGRAMS THAT THEY
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD AND NOT DO
IT SORT OF PIECEMEAL LIKE THIS.
SO I HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS OTHER THAN HELP US
OUT TO HELP US FIGURE OUT. HOW
WE CAN HELP YOU GET SOME OF
THESE DONE BUILD SOME
CONSISTENCY BACK. IMPROVE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE ON A
CONSISTENT MANNER ACROSS ALL
FIFTY EIGHT QUARTS. A. N. AND
HAVING A MORE RATIONAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT. WHAT THE
BUDGETS REALLY BUT THE-BUDGETARY NEEDS ARE HOW WE FUND
THEM- INSTEAD OF. WHAT HAS BEEN
COBBLED TOGETHER OVER THE YEARS
SO THAT'S WHAT I'M HOPING WE
CAN START TO DO A BETTER JOB
OF. THIS YEAR COMING OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC IS PANDEMIC IS REALLY
SHOWING THE WEAKNESSES IN HOW
WE'VE ADDRESS COURT FUNDING.
OVER THE YEARS. THANK YOU YOUR
SON I SAY WELL YOU THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE A QUESTION MAYBE-
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
JUDICIAL COUNCIL COULD. COMMENT
ON THE L. A. O.'S PROPOSAL
TOOK- TO MOVE EVERYTHING INTO
THE GENERAL FUND IF KNOWING
THAT WITH THESE PLANS ARE GOING
TO BECOME AND ALL THAT. AND
KNOWING THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
CREATE A MORE JUST SYSTEM THAT
LOCKS AWAY FROM. THE SYSTEM
WHERE A HUNDRED DOLLAR BASE FEE
FOR A PARKING TICKET. THAT
BEING ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS IS A BATTERED ALMOST
THIRTY. FIVE ADD ONS. FROM THE
CHART I'M TRYING TO BE.
POSSIBLE CAN YOU GUYS COME IN
AND THAT. I JUST REMIND
APARTMENT OF FINANCE I WANTED
TO ADDRESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONES A CALM IN REGARDS TO
FUND CONSOLIDATION. OUR GOAL OF
FUND CONSOLIDATION WAS TO AVOID
A GENERAL FUND OBLIGATION IN
THE BUDGET YEAR SINCE THE STFC
AT THE STATE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FUND WAS GOING TO
BE INSOLVENT IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. IF WE LEFT IT ALONE AND
THEN ALSO TO YOUR POINT IN
REGARDS TO CONSISTENCY WE WERE
SEEKING A CONSISTENT SO LUCIEN
NOT ONLY FOR THESE CORE
CONSTRUCTION FUNDS BUT ALSO THE
OTHER SPECIAL FUNDS. BUT THE
TRIAL COURT TRUST FUND IN TO
HAVE A SOLUTION WHERE WHAT WE
DECIDE TO DO WITH THE STATE
COURT FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION
FUND ANY IMMEDIATE CRITICAL
NEED TO COUNT. SOMETHING
SIMILAR THAT WE DO FOR THE
OTHER SPECIAL FUNDS- I'M- SO IF
YOU WANT TO DISCUSS THAT
FURTHER- WE CAN I JUST I WAS
TRYING. TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
THAT YOU BROUGHT UP. THIS
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ON AT ANYTHING.
SISTERLY ADAM BARRINGER MEAN IN
TERMS OF THE STATE COURT
FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION FUND
AND THE IN A MEETING CRITICAL
NEEDS ACCOUNT MERGER AND OUR
FOCUS IS ON ENSURING THAT THE
FUNDS TO THE TO THOSE TO THOSE
NEEDS IN TERMS OF OUR STAFF.
THE CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM THE
DEBT SERVICE ARE MAINTAINED AND
SO WE DON'T HAVE TO GO POSITION
ON THE FINAL FINAL SOLUTION BUT
RATHER JUST ENSURING THAT OUR
PROGRAM IS FULLY FUNDED. THANK
YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER BENNETT
SAYS I'M SORRY I'M- THIS IS A
ROBERT- YEAH. CAN I ADDRESS-
THE QUESTION ABOUT THE LARGER
PICTURE AROUND THE- JUDICIAL
BRANCHES PLAN PLEASE DO. A
TERRIFIC STYLE- I JUST WANTED
TO. MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
AWARE THAT OUR THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH HAS BEEN FOLLOWING A
PLANT BASED ON THE CHIEF
JUSTICE'S. XS THREE D. VISION
SO THAT'S PHYSICAL REMOTE AND
EQUAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE AND SO
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO IS REALLY
BASED ON THAT STRATEGIC PLAN TO
MOVE TOWARDS PROVIDING EQUAL
ACCESS TO JUSTICE TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA AND PROVIDING
EQUITY. THIS PARTICULAR BUDGET
PLAN. IS ONE STEP TOWARDS
REALIZING THAT. ENDPOINT
DIVISION- THIS PARTICULAR PLAN
INCLUDES FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF MODERNIZATION OVER
TWO YEARS THIS WILL BE THE
SECOND YEAR THAT WILL BE
RECEIVING THAT I'D INCLUDES THE
PANDEMIC EARLY DISPOSITION
CALENDARING PROGRAM SUPPORT FOR
SELF HELP THAT YOU'VE HEARD.
ONLINE TRAFFIC A COMMUNICATIONS
AND THOSE ARE ALL PIECES- OTHER
MUCH BIGGER PLAN DESIGNED TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND THE LEGISLATURE'S
PLANS TO INCREASE EQUITY- AN
ACCESS ROUTE THE STATE AND WE
DO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE. TOGETHER TO
LOOK AT- HOW WE CAN ENHANCE AND
UP WITH A CREATE MORE
UNIFORMITY WITHIN THOSE
SERVICES BUT WE DO HAVE AN
OVERALL PLAN AND IT'S FOCUSED
ON- ACCESS TO JUSTICE. THANK
YOU WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
SOME ARE THOSE DETAILS MISTER
JONES SAWYER- YOU KNOW- WHEN I
CAME IN A TWENTY TWELVE- I WAS
CHAIRED THIS COMMITTEE.
COMPACTORS MY FIRST
CHAIRMANSHIP. AND DURING THAT
TIME. THERE WAS A PROBLEM WITH
THE COURT CONSTRUCTION FUND- AT
THE TIME WE'VE GONE TO
RECESSION. AND- WE BORROWED TRY
TO BE TO MONEY TO BALANCE THE
BUDGET OUR VERY HARD TO TRY TO
RESTORE ALL OF THAT MONEY. BUT
IN THAT CONVERSATION WITH THE
DAN AOC ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICE
OF THE COURTS. IT BECAME CLEAR
EARLY ON- IN MY TENURE. THAT B.
B. A. R. C. AND THE COURTS
REALLY PLAYING. WE NEITHER ONE
OF US KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON
WITH THE COURT FUNDING- WHEN
THINGS WOULD GET DONE HUMMING
PROJECT COULDN'T GET DONE. HOW
MANY PROJECTS WERE ON SCHEDULE
WHICH ONES HADN'T EVEN BEEN
STARTED. AND AS WE STARTED TO
DIG IN AND DAY AGAIN AND TRY TO
GET. SOME SPECIFIC IDEA OF HOW
TAXPAYERS MONIES ARE BEING USED.
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERY YEAR OR TWO
YEARS- THE MINISTRY OF OFFICE
THE COURT WAS ASKING FOR MORE
MONEY FOR CONSTRUCTION WITHOUT
A REAL PLAN FOR HOW TO GET
THINGS DONE IN ADDITION AT THE
SAME TIME IF I REMEMBER BACK
THEN- DLC WAS TALKING. CLOSING
FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE. WHERE
A MOTHER WHO HAD A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CLAIM. HAD TO GET ON A
BUS A HUNDRED MILES AWAY TO GET
A RESTRAINING ORDER. AND THEY
WANTED TO CLOSE THE CLOSEST
COURT TODAY AT THAT MOMENT. SO
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE- THE
PLANTED KIND OF BRING
EVERYTHING IN. AND ALSO TAKEN
AWAY FROM THE COURT BACK THEN I
BELIEVE THE PJ'S TO PRESIDING
JUDGES. HEAD UP HEAVY HEAVY
HAND IN DECIDING HOW COURT
CONSTRUCTION WITH BUILDINGS AND
WHAT WOULD BE DONE- I THINK
EARLY ON WE REALIZED THAT WAS A
HUGE HUGE MISTAKE. AND I WILL
TELL YOU AS SOMEONE. WHO DID
CONSTRUCTION FOR THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES. WHEN WE ALLOW L.
A. P. D. THE BILL POLICE
STATIONS- IT WAS A HUGE MISTAKE
AND ALMOST EVERY PROJECT CAME
IN- OVER BUDGET AND RARELY DID
WE GET THEM DONE ON TIME
BECAUSE THAT WAS NOT A POLICE
OFFICER'S CORE CONFIDENCE JUST
LIKE IT'S NOT A JUDGE'S CORE
COMPETENCE TO DO FACILITIES
MANAGEMENT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. OR EVEN TO BE
RESPONSIBLE. FOR A PROJECT
MANAGEMENT OF A CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT AND SO WE TOOK THAT OUT
OF THEIR HANDS IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES. WE WERE ABLE TO
GIVE. BUILDINGS DONE ON TIME
UNDER BUDGET. AND MOST OF ALL
REPUBLICANS HAVE SOME
CONSISTENCY WHERE IN POLICE
STATIONS YOU WOULD HAVE. ONE
POLICE CAPTAIN BILL THE TAJ
MAHAL. OFFICE AND ANOTHER ONE
WITH BUILDING A FAIRLY MODEST
AND IT WAS NO CONSISTENCY AND
THAT'S WHY THEY CAME IN- NOT IN
THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE FOR USING
TAXPAYER MONEY. UP TO WHAT WE
LEARNED IN THE CITY IS YOU NEED
TO BRING. THIS WHOLE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT IN HOUSE.
GET SOME PROFESSIONALS THAT
ACTUALLY KNOW HOW TO DO
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT
MANAGEMENT. SO THAT WE CAN COME
UP WITH THE BEST PLAN. TO GET
THE FACILITIES DONE BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT ACCESS TO JUSTICE
SPECIALLY. FOR LOW INCOME AND
MINORITY. AMENITIES IS BASED
OFF OF WHERE THEY CAN GO TO A-
AND I DON'T WE'RE- IT ON DAT.
AS OPPOSED TO A PATIENT ON THE
CAN. OF A PARTICULAR PJ ARE
JUDGED. TO GET TO A COURT. AND
IS NOT BASED ON WHAT AT NOT IS
TO BEST FOR THE RESIDENTS IN
THAT AREA. AND SO I WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE US HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION BECAUSE WE ALSO
NEED TO WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. YOU CAN I
JUST FEEL LIKE WE DESTROY. IN A
LOT OF WAYS AND I KNOW WE HAVE
NOW DID. COUNCIL BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE THEY HAVE NOT FULLY GOTTEN
OUR HANDS AROUND THIS. IS A LOT
OF MONEY I MEAN THIS IS A LOT
OF MONEY THAT WE NEED TO MOVE
ON. WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE SOME
DECISIONS ON WHAT WE WILL AND
WON'T DO. WHAT WE WILL AND
WE'LL FIND. ABBOTT MOST
IMPORTANT WHAT WE WILL NOT FUND
ANYMORE. ARE NOT HOLDING OVER
TO HEAD OF THE- OF THE ASSEMBLY
GOVERNOR OFFICE. THAT YES WE
STARTED THIS BUT YOU'VE GOT TO
KEEP GIVING US MORE MORE MONEY
YOU GOT TO KEEP RAISING THE
PIECE OF THE PAPER. AND YOU'VE
A KEY. FUNDING OUR INABILITY TO
GET OUR ARMS AROUND THIS IN A
SUBSTANTIVE WAY. AND IT AND SO
I BELIEVE THAT THE L. A. L. HAS
AS MERRICK. AND WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND I THINK WE
SHOULD WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. SERVING I TO HIRE SOME
OUTSIDE CONSULTANTS TO COME UP
WITH A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN. ON
HOW WE TAKE CARE OF THIS
PROBLEM- AND YOUR WE GET A TWO
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES OR
WHOEVER'S IN CHARGE THE
MAINTENANCE OF THESE BUILDINGS-
TO ENSURE THAT. WE HAVE THE
BEST. OUTCOME THE MOST
IMPORTANT MADE THE BEST USE OF.
TAXPAYER MONEY AS WE MOVE
FORWARD FROM HERE. FIVE I CAME
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE. THESE
ISSUES THIS IS TWENTY TWENTY IN
THESE ISSUES ARE SO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THESE ISSUES ARE
STILL HERE THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND SO. WE'VE GOT TO
WE'VE GOT TO REFERENCE ON TO
ROUND THIS AND GET THIS DONE.
AND I DON'T HONEST YOU MEAN. WE
NEVER WANT TO SEE THIS AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN WE NEED TO
HAVE BOOKS ARE MOVING TOWARD A
SOLUTION. AND I THINK THE BEST
WAY IF THE LEGISLATURE THREE
SERIOUS ABOUT THIS. IS A BRING
THOSE FUNDS IN. SO THAT WE CAN
GET. THE COURTS TO HELP THEY
NEED- TO BETTER UTILIZE THAT.
THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER. MATT
MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST BRIEFLY
RESPOND- YES- VERY COULD I
WOULD DEFINITELY WANT OFFER A
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO WITH THE
STAFF OF THE MEMBERSHIP ON.
SORT OF THE PROBLEM IS THAT
WHICH WE GO THROUGH- ARE
PROGRAM BUT I NEEDED OVER TO
BECAUSE MY MCCORMICK I THINK
DESCRIBED REASSESSMENT PROCESS
AND THE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HOUSING- NOT FIVE YEARS
FOR OF- PROPOSAL IN THE-
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN- BUT
DEFINITELY WILL TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY'S AWARE OF WHAT DOING
AND WE ARE WE'RE CLASS. WITH
THE MINISTRY ANALYSTS ON OUR
SOCIETY NEEDS SO WE CAN WORK
WITH TO THE HAVE THAT'S. OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR OTHER QUESTIONS
COME FROM OMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
THEN GONNA MOVE ARTIST NUMBER
TWO IS YOU KNOW TWO HEY THREE
SUB PANELS TO THE FOR SUB PANEL
ONE IS ON HOW THE SELF HELP
CENTER AND WE HAVE HOW JUDICIAL
COUNCIL I NEED TO L. A. L. L.
JESSE WERE FROM DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. IT WAS CHAD ALL THE
INTERNET. I'M I WILL. THE NEXT
ISSUE IS RELATED THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL. TERMINATE NINETY ONE
MILLION DOLLAR OF COULD. SERVER
THAT WERE FOR THE EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT AND IT SAID WE HAVE
TWENTY HEALTH. IN THIS REQUEST
IS TO CONTINUE THE NINETEEN
POINT ONE MILLION IN FUNDING
FOR COURT BASED SELF HELP
CENTERS THIS MISTER MY
DESCRIBED. OVER 95% OF THE
FUNDS ARE USED FOR ATTORNEYS
AND PARALEGALS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION AND EDUCATION FOR
PEOPLE WITHOUT LAWYERS ABOUT
THE COURT PROCESS. HELP THEM
COMPLETE THEIR NECESSARY COURT
DOCUMENTS AND PREPARE FOR THEIR
HEARINGS. EACH COURT IN
CALIFORNIA HAS A SELF HELP
CENTER DEDICATED TO ASSISTING
THE FOUR POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO COME TO COURT
EACH YEAR WITHOUT A LAWYER.
THESE FUNDS ALLOWED COURTS TO
DOUBLE THEIR STAFF SO THERE ARE
NOW THREE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
ATTORNEYS AND PARALEGALS
HELPING PEOPLE EVERY DAY WITH
THEIR LEGAL PROBLEMS. AND 46%
OF THOSE WHO STAFF ARE
BILINGUAL. COURTS WERE ALSO
ABLE TO EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
LOCATIONS WHERE SERVICES WERE
OFFERED TO MAKE IT MORE
CONVENIENT TO THE PUBLIC. SO WE
NOW HAVE A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE SELF HELP CENTER SITES.
AND THEY UPGRADED THEIR
TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE SO
THEY WERE ABLE TO QUICKLY MOVED
PROVIDING REMOTE SERVICES SUCH
AS VIDEO CONFERENCING AND LIVE
CHAT DURING THE PANDEMIC. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN SELF HELP
CENTERS PROVIDED SERVICES TO
OVER A MILLION IN PERSON AND
REMOTE PRISONERS. AND A RECENT
JUSTICE GAP STUDY BY THE STATE
BAR FOUND THAT 16% OF LOW
INCOME PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
WHO RECEIVE LEGAL ASSISTANCE
GET IT FROM COURT A SELF HELP
CENTERS. WELL CUSTOMER
SATISFACTION SURVEYS SHOW THAT
OVER 96% OF THE PEOPLE COMING
TO SELF HELP WE'RE VERY
SATISFIED WITH THE SERVICES.
THEY ALSO REPORTED A NEED FOR
MORE STAFF ADDITIONAL HOURS AND
SHORTER WAIT TIMES FOR SERVICE
APPOINTMENTS. THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL PROVIDED A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS WHICH LOOK CAREFULLY
AT HOW DIFFERENT TYPES OF
SERVICES ARE NEEDED FOR
DIFFERENT CASE TYPES AND THE
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES. THE
PANDEMIC FOR MEDICALLY AFFECTED
THOUGH SERVICE MODALITIES NEEDS
ARE CHANGING QUICKLY. FOR
EXAMPLE SELF HELP CENTERS WERE
ASSISTING WITH 22% OF THE
LANDLORD TENANT CASES FILED IN
CALIFORNIA. PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC IS ALMOST CERTAIN THAT
THESE NUMBERS WILL INCREASE AS
THE EVICTION MORATORIUM ARE
LEFT DEAD. TO ADDRESS THIS
CHALLENGE THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
CONTINUES TO COLLECT DATA AND
CONVENES WEEKLY WEBINARS WITH
SELF HELP STAFF TO KEEP THEM
ABREAST OF CHANGES IN THE LAW
AS WELL AS TO SHARE BEST
PRACTICES AND PROVIDING
SERVICES. AS CENTERS CONTINUE
TO INNOVATE WITH ON TO SERVE AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE.
ESCORTS COME UP WITH NEW
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS
TRANSLATIONS WAYS OF PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE. THEIR SHARED
QUICKLY THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND WE DEEPLY THE SUPPORT OF
THE LEGISLATURE FOR THIS
PROJECT WHICH HELPS SO MANY
PEOPLE GET ACCESS TO THE
COURTS. PARTICULARLY AT THIS
TIME WE KNOW THE NEED CONTINUES
TO GROW. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU L. L. ANNUALLY WITH
THE L. A. L. WE HAVE THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THIS ITEM
FOR- LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION
OUR FIRST RECOMMENDATION IS
THAT WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPT BUDGET
TRAILER LEGISLATION DIRECTING
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO CONTRACT
WITH AN EXTERNAL RESEARCHER TO
FINISH THE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS THAT WAS REQUIRED AS
PART OF THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET. AND TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW FUNDING
CAN BE ALLOCATED BY DELIVERY
METHOD AND HE'S TIED TO
MAXIMIZE THE BENEFIT TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC AND TO THE COURT
I NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
AS OF THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTED OF THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
TO COMPLETE OR TO CONTRACT WITH
A RESEARCHER TO COMPLETE A COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS IN TIME FOR
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS. THE REPORT THAT
WAS SUBMITTED EARLIER THIS YEAR
HAD A LOT OF HOPEFUL OUTCOME
DATA AND REFLECTED EXTENSIVE
JUDICIAL BRANCH EFFORT AT
COLLECTING INFORMATION HOWEVER
INCOMPLETE BECAUSE IT MISSES
THE FINAL KEY PIECES OF A COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS SPECIFICALLY
CALCULATING THE MONETARY VALUE
OF IDENTIFIED BENEFITS
IDENTIFYING CORRESPONDING COSTS
AND IDENTIFYING THE NET BENEFIT
OF THE VARIOUS SELF HELP
DELIVERY METHODS BY CASE TYPE.
AND SO WITHOUT THIS IMPORTANT
INFORMATION IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO DETERMINE WHAT TOTAL LEVEL
FUNDING IS WARRANTED AND HOW
ANY PROVIDED FUNDING COULD BE
MAXIMIZED- TO SERVE THE MOST
INDIVIDUALS. IN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY POSSIBLE. OUR
SECOND RECORD. IN LINE WITH OUR
FIRST ONE THE DUE DATE FOR THIS
FINISHING UP THE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDE THE
REQUESTED FUNDING FOR ONLY AN
ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS. THIS
WOULD PREVENT A REDUCTION IN
SERVICE LEVELS AND HELP
MAINTAIN ALL OF THE EQUITY
RELATED BENEFITS THAT COME FROM
THESE SERVICES WALL THE COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS WAS BEING
FINISHED. AND THEN FINALLY WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER ADOPTING PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE TO SPECIFY ITS
PRIORITIES FOR THE USE OF SELF
HELP CENTER FUNDING. SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER SPECIFYING THAT A
MINIMUM AMOUNT OF THE FUNDING
BE USED TO PROVIDE SERVICES
REMOTELY AND THIS COULD BE
BENEFICIAL ON AN ONGOING BASIS
BOTH DURING AND AFTER THE
PANDEMIC SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU
HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE.
FURTHER AWAY FROM THE COURT AND
SO IT POBABLY WOULD ELIMINATE
THE NEED FOR THEM TO HAVE TO
TRAVEL THE COURTSTO OBTAIN THE
SERVICES IF THEY WERE AVAILABLE
REMOTELY. THANK YOU ARE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. GREAT THANK YOU THE
FORMER FINANCE. JESSICA MY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
REGARDS TO THE ALEJO'S
RECOMMENDATION FOR LIMITED
THERE WERE FUNDING I JUST LIKE
TO ADD THAT CONTINUED
INVESTMENT SELF HELP SERVICES
BEYOND TWO YEARS IT IS
IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN EXISTING
SERVICE LEVELS ESPECIALLY SINCE
THE ONSET COOKING NINETEEN
THAT'S EXACERBATED ISSUES FOR
UNREPRESENTED LITIGANTS EVEN
MORE CRITICAL HOUSING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FAMILY LAW IN OTHER
SIMILAR ISSUES WERE
INDIVIDUALS. NEED HELP AS LAID
OUT IN THE DATA IT WAS PROVIDED
BY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL THESE
RESOURCES FOR THE ASSISTANCE OF
OVER ONE MILLION SELF
REPRESENTED INDIVIDUALS ARE YOU
THIS MORNING IS NOT CONTINUE
ATTORNEY ATTORNEY WILL BE LAID
OFF EXISTING SERVICE LEVELS.
WILL BE WILL BE TEAMING WITH
THE CLIENT AND THEY'LL BE
REDUCE CAPACITY TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS CONCERNING CRITICAL
CIVIL ISSUES I ALSO LIKE TO ADD
THAT A PLUS BENEFIT ANALYSIS
CAN BE A HELPFUL TOOL TO GUIDE
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS THE
LEGISLATURE AND RECONSIDER
FUTURE INVESTMENTS IN SELF HELP
SERVICES. HOWEVER WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE TIMING OF
THIS ANALYSIS IN PARTICULAR WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT ANALYSIS
CONDUCTED IT'S TIME WOULD BE
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC I
CURRENTLY AS IT STANDS OUT SELF
HELP CENTERS ARE GOING TO
DRASTIC CHANGES IN THE WAY THEY
ARE PROVIDING ASSISTANCE TO
COURT USERS DEVELOPMENT
TECHNOLOGY IF A COST BENEFIT
STUDY WOULD BE COMPLETED IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AND MAY NOT BE
HELPFUL IN THE FUTURE SINCE THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE-
ADMINISTRATION OF SELF HELP
SERVICES. IS CHANGING ITS CUT
BY THE PENTAGON. AS FOR THE-
PROVISION LANGUAGE. THERE ARE
FIFTY EIGHT DIFFERENT COUNTY
SAN COURT EACH CASE. HAS
DIFFERENT NEEDS ON SPECIFIC
POPULAR. AS SUCH DIMINISH.
SUPPORTS THAT SUPPORTS. COURTS
HAVE FLEXIBILITY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES BASED ON THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF THEIR QUARTERS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE AND SO FOR
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS AND- I DO
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN ABOUT
DOING A COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS
NOW BUT COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS
WAS SUPPOSED TO HAVE BEEN DONE.
SO THAT WE COULD UNDERSTAND.
AND WHAT THE OVERALL COST WE'RE
GOING TO BE WHAT THE FUTURE. OF
THE. SELF HELP CENTERS REALLY
AREN'T AND HOW WE GET OUR HEADS
AROUND WHAT THAT FINANCING IS I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE HOW IMPORTANT
HOW CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SELF
HELP CENTERS ARE AS WE'RE
SEEING SUCH AN INCREASE IN IN
SELF REPRESENTED LITIGANTS.
REALLY ACROSS THE STATE SO HOW.
DO WE- YES L. A. O. HAS A GOOD
POINT THAT THAT WORK ON A COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS WAS NOT
COMPLETED AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE THEY'RE COMING FROM ABOUT
PROVIDING JUST A COUPLE YEARS
OF FUNDING. AND DOING SOME
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE. HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THE
INFORMATION WE'RE GOING TO
NEED. IF WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR
IS. MORE CERTAINTY IN THE IN
THE FUNDING OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS OR AT LEAST
BEYOND THE TWO YEARS. L- I AM
HAPPY TO START THAT AT THIS
POINT WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR
CONTINUATION OF THE FUNDING
ASSETS WERE NOT ASKING FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. AND THE
CHALLENGE IS AS I SAY THE WE
COLLECTED DATA IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE HAVE EXTENSIVE DATA
WAS RECORDED- IN- UP IN THE
COST BENEFIT REPORT. AND ALL OF
THOSE SERVICES HAVE DRIVEN FOR
MEDICALLY CHANGED AS WELL AS-
THE IMPACT ON THE COURTS SO-
REVIEWING PAPERS- TAKES A
DIFFERENT AMOUNT OF TIME WHEN
IT'S BEING DONE ELECTRONICALLY-
ALL KINDS OF THINGS ARE JUST
DIFFERENT. AND ANY DATA THAT
WE'RE USING IS- GOING TO BE
FAIRLY CHALLENGING IN TERMS OF
REALLY MAKING THOSE DIRECTIONS
MOVING FORWARD BECAUSE AS
HONESTLY POINTS HOW MANY OF THE
INNOVATIONS THAT WERE.
INCORPORATED AS A RESULT OF THE
COST OF THE PANDEMIC. MAY WELL
BE FABULOUS I MEAN I THINK WE
WANT TO CONTINUE PROVIDING
REMOTE SERVICES WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT WE JUST
DON'T KNOW AT THIS TIME. WHAT
THAT MAKES IS GOING TO BE LIKE
WHEN THE PANDEMIC IS OVER AND
SO. IT IS. CRITICAL THAT THERE
IS FLEXIBILITY IN THE COURTS TO
BE AS INNOVATIVE AND CREATIVE
AS POSSIBLE BUT THEY NEED A
BASELINE. SHOULD BE ABLE TO-
PROVIDE THE ASSISTANCE AND
ALLOW US TO BE ABLE TO COME
BACK TO YOU. WITH- MORE INFO
ABOUT ABOUT WHAT'S NEEDED BUT I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY. THAT
THERE IS IT LEASED THE NINETEEN
BILLION DOLLAR NEED AND THEN
MOVING FORWARD HOW ARE WE GOING%
TO DO THAT BUT AT THIS TIME I
THINK IT IS- AS- A MYSTERY BUT
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO KNOW
WHAT THAT RIGHT MIX OF SERVICES
IS GOING TO BE. OKAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE- A COUPLE COMMENTS
THAT COULD BE HELPFUL FROM THE
L. A- IF IT. WOULD BE HELPFUL
PRETTY GOOD NEARLY. I NEARLY
WITH THE L. A- SO A COUPLE
THINGS THAT COULD BE HELPFUL TO
IN TERMS OF YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT
THE COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH DID DO A LOT OF
COLLECTION OF DATA. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AS
WELL AS NINETEEN TWENTY SO IN
CONTRACTING WITH THE
RESEARCHER. TO RESEARCHER TO
FINISH OFF THAT ANNOUNCES THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE USE OF A
LOT OF THAT HELPFUL INFORMATION
THEY MIGHT NEED TO SUPPLEMENT
IT. BUT THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
MAKE USE OF SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION SO I THINK ABOUT
KIND OF THE FIRST THING THAT WE
WOULD WANT TO- REYES OF KIND OF
A COMMENT. THE SECOND ISSUE IS
IN IN BOTH THE COMMENTS THAT
ARE BEING RAISED BY THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RIGHT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE MIX
WHAT'S THE APPROPRIATE MIX.
THAT GOES BACK TO YOUR COMMENTS
ABOUT WHY A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS IS NECESSARY AND IT IS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE FELT VERY STRONGLY
ABOUT BECAUSE THAT IS THE
LANGUAGE THAT WAS SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDED AS PART. OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET AND SO
IN LINE WITH THAT AS WE ARE
OPERATING IN THE PANDEMIC THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO THINK
ABOUT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
PRIORITIES WHETHER THERE ARE
CERTAIN MINIMUMS. THAT WE WATCH
IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO
BE VERY SPECIFIC YOU WILL SPEND
X. Y. NZ BUT IT CAN'T INVOLVED
SAYING AT THE MINIMUM WE SHOULD
BE DEDICATING A CERTAIN AMOUNT
THIS AMOUNT. TO THAT DELIVERY
AND THAT'S METHOD OR YOU KNOW
IN OTHER PRIORITIES OTHER
METICULOUSLY BY THE LEGISLATURE
SO HOPEFULLY. THAT'S HELPFUL.
THAT IS. AND THEN I UNDER. THAT
AND THAT'S WE'RE- WE'RE
DEFINITELY DEALING WITH SOME
DIFFERENCES THIS YEAR. OR
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. NOT NECESSARILY ALIGNING
WITH THE FISCAL YEARS. IN THE
LEGISLATURE DID ASK FOR SOME OF
THAT INFORMATION THAT WASN'T
COMPLETED. THAT MY FRUSTRATION
ALSO COMES FROM DAY HEARING
THAT WE HELD ON ACCESS TO
COURTS WHERE A LOT. THE ANSWER
TO A LOT OF THE QUESTIONS FROM
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WAS WE'RE
COLLECTING DATA. WILL COLLECT
MORE DATA AT SOME POINT. WE'VE
GOT TO GET ACCESS TO THAT DATA
TO A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT ALL OF THAT MEANS. IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE HOW WE MOVE
FORWARD AND SO JUST CONTINUING
THAT MONEY RIGHT THAT'S THAT'S.
NOT AN UNREASONABLE ASK AT THIS
POINT BUT I THINK AT SOME POINT
TO SELF HELP CENTERS ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND WILL
BE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT INTO
THE FUTURE HOW THEY INNOVATE
AND HOW THEY PROVIDE. BENEFITS
TO. OUR CONSTITUENTS IS REALLY
VERY IMPORTANT. WE NEED TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT
MEANS HOW THAT WORKS IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE PROVIDING
THE CORRECT LEVEL OF FUNDING
AND I'M ALSO SENSITIVE TO THAT
MR REMINDS COMMENT THAT WE A
FIFTY EIGHT COURTS AND- WE
DON'T WANT TO STIFLE INNOVATION
IN THOSE COURTS THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT. NEEDS AND DIFFERENT
PEOPLE YES TO A POINT BUT THIS
IS I THINK ALSO WERE WE GET
WRAPPED AROUND SOME PROBLEMS
HERE IN THAT WE HAVE FIFTY
EIGHT COURTS THAT WANT TO BE
VERY INDEPENDENT. AND DO THINGS
THEIR OWN WAY WHICH MAY OR MAY
NOT BE A GOOD THING. AND IS
LEADING TO DIFFERENCES IN
ACCESS TO JUSTICE COURT TO
COURT TO COURT. AND EVEN SOME
OF THE TESTIMONY THAT WE GOT IN
OUR HEARING PREVIOUSLY. THE TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEES HAD
THAT HEARING ON ACCESS TO
JUSTICE THERE SEEMS TO BE
DIFFERENT RESPONSES FROM
COURTROOM TO COURTROOM MEANING
DIFFERENT JUDGES WANT TO
MAINTAIN THEIR INDEPENDENCE SO
STRIDENTLY THAT THEY'RE MAKING
THEIR OWN DECISIONS. THAT
AFFECT ACCESS SO HOW I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE SUPPORTING SELF
HELP CENTERS BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT THOSE ARE CRITICAL. FOR
UNREPRESENTED LITIGANTS AND
THAT'S A THAT'S ACTUALLY A BIG
PROBLEM THAT WE SHOULDN'T JUST
PAPER OVER BY SINGLE WE HAVE
SELF HELP CENTERS. THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO GIVE PEOPLE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE BECAUSE
WITHOUT. APPROPRIATE
PROFESSIONALS HELPING THEM WITH
THE LEGAL SYSTEM THEY ARE AT A
DISADVANTAGE. BUT I'M ALSO VERY
WORRIED ABOUT. THIS DESIRE TO
ALLOW FIFTY EIGHT COURTS TO DO
THEIR OWN THING ALL THE TIME
WITHOUT SOME CONSISTENCY.
ACROSS THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
BECAUSE WE DO IN FACT HAVE A
STATEWIDE SYSTEM. NOT A
CONGLOMERATION OF FIFTY EIGHT.
DIFFERENT LITTLE FIEFDOMS SO.
WE DON'T WANT TO STIFLE
INNOVATION WE WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT. THAT THE SELF HELP
CENTERS AND IN IN ALL OF THESE
CATEGORIES COURTS ARE ABLE TO
DO WHAT THEY NEED TO DO BUT
ALSO LEARN FROM EACH OTHER HOW
SOME CONSISTENCY AND HAVE IT
LEASED THE MINIMUM STANDARD OF
ACCESS ACROSS ALL OF THE
COURTS. SO I'M WORRIED ABOUT
TOO MUCH FLEXIBILITY OR TOO
MUCH- OF A AN ALLOWANCE FOR
THAT FIFTY EIGHT DIFFERENT
COURTS AND HOW NEAT THAT IS
THAT THEY ALL HAVE THEIR OWN
INDEPENDENCE. SO I THINK WHAT.
IT'S A TOUGH THING FOR US TO
KNOW WHAT EXACTLY TO DO. THESE
OF THE THIS YEAR AND MOVING
FORWARD- SO THAT'S NOT FOR ME
NOT UNREASONABLE REQUEST AND
THE COMMITTEES GOT A KIND OF
SORT THROUGH THAT THE NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLARS- ASK. BUT I DO
AGREE WITH ALEJO THAT JUDICIAL
COUNCIL HAS COLLECTED A LOT OF
DATA YOU GOT TO START PUTTING
SOME OF THAT TOGETHER. AND MAKE
THAT RELATABLE TO US SO THAT WE
UNDERSTAND. WHAT THOSE WHAT THE
FUTURE OF THE SELF HELP CENTERS
ARE GOING TO BE SO THAT WE CAN
ADEQUATELY FUNDED. BECAUSE WHAT
OUR HOPE YOU'RE HEARING IS THAT
THERE IS AN INTEREST IN MAKING
SURE WE ADEQUATELY FUND THOSE
THEY ARE GOING TO BE KEY.
UNFORTUNATELY TO. REALLY
PROVIDING ACCESS TO JUSTICE
SORRY- OTHER MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
JONES SAWYER AND I THINK WE'RE
ALL OF THIS IS NOT MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE I THINK WE ALL AGREE
THAT- SELF HELP CENTERS ARE NOT
ONLY IMPORTANT I LIKE TO ADD
ONE ADDITIONAL UP THEY COULD BE
THE WAVE OF THE FUTURE. AND
ALSO COULD HELP US WITH OUR
BRICK AND MORTAR PROBLEM WITH
PLANTS IF MORE PEOPLE ARE ABLE
TO GO ONLINE AND ABLE TO HANDLE
THEIR JUDICIAL THE CARD
BUSINESS ON LINE. THAT WILL
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
SHOWING UP AT COURT DID DO VERY
SIMPLE MENIAL TASKS THAT CAN BE
HANDLED- ONLINE. AND THEN
INVESTMENT IN THIS IS CRITICAL
NOT ONLY FOR DISADVANTAGED AND
POOR FOLKS. IT COULD BE THE
WAVE OF THE FUTURE THAT COULD
TAKE THIS COURT SYSTEM. INTO
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND
BEYOND. AND SO. ASKING THAT
AFTER TWO YEARS YEAR AND A HALF
THAT WE GET INFORMATION TO MAKE
CRITICAL DECISIONS ON HOW WE
MOVE FORWARD I THINK IS
IMPORTANT AND THAT WE SHOULD
NOT JUST GIVE MONEY. BECAUSE
WE'RE AFRAID THAT WE MAY NOT
GET FUNDED. AND THE NEXT TWO
YEARS AFTER THAT. IN FACT IF
YOU'RE AFRAID OF THAT THAT
MAKES ME EVEN MORE CONCERNED.
IF THE SYSTEM THAT YOU'RE
SETTING UP. IS YOUR FREIGHT
THAT A. N. N. NOT AN AUDIT BUT
A AN EVALUATION OF WHERE YOU'RE
GOING- MAY RESULT IN THIS BODY.
NOT FINDING YOU BECAUSE YOU'RE
GOING IN IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION. I'M VERY CONCERNED.
THAT THAT YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
FAITH. THAT YOU'RE GONNA DO
SUCH A GOOD JOB. THAT NOT ONLY
WILL WE FIND YOU THE NEXT TEN
YEARS BECAUSE WILL HAVE
EMPIRICAL DATA THAT ACTUALLY
PROVES. NOT ONLY YOUR VALIDITY
BUT HOW WELL YOU'RE DOING IT-
IS A CONCERN. SO I DON'T THINK
WE'RE MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE. I
JUST THINK. THAT THE COURTS
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND OTHERS
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO CREATE
A SYSTEM. THAT COULD NOT ONLY
STATEWIDE BE USE BY MAYBE
NATIONALLY EVEN INTERNATIONALLY
A KEY COULD BE USED IN THE
FUTURE IF WE CAN NOW INVEST IN
IT. BUT MOST IMPORTANT WE
ACTUALLY TWEAK IT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- IT IS FUNCTIONING THE WAY
WE WANT TO AND SO I YOU KNOW I
CAN LOOK. AT AND NOT TRY TO DO
A COLLABO ALBUM IF BUT IF SOME
REASON TRYING TO DO A COMPILER
AND I LIKE TO HEAR FROM BOTH.
FINANCE IN LA- DO YOU KIND OF
SEE IT THAT WAY THAT WE'RE ALL
WE ALL- ONE TO SEE A ROBUST
SELF HELP CENTER. AND HOW CAN
WE GET THERE. I COMPLY IF YOU
DON'T MIND HEARING FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ABSOLUTELY
HAVE NO CONCERNS ABOUT THE-
DATA SHOWING THE NEED FOR
EXPANDED ASSISTANCE AND I HOPE
THAT YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO READ THE REPORT BECAUSE I
THINK IT PROVIDES. INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL INFORMATION THE
CERTAINLY HELPFUL FOR ME TO YOU
KNOW WHEN IT'S WINTER WORKSHOPS
HELPFUL ON WHAT CASE TYPES HOW
LONG TWO THIRDS CERTAIN THINGS
TAKE WHEN DOES IT MAKE SENSE TO
DO ONE ON ONE VERSUS A WORKSHOP
AND AS THEY SAY MOVING FORWARD-
WE WILL HAVE WILL. ABSOLUTELY
CONTINUE THAT WORK- I THINK THE
CHALLENGE IS. WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE THIS INCREDIBLE NEED RIGHT
NOW AND- IT TAKING THE
RESOURCES AWAY FROM THAT WORK
IS- IS CERTAINLY CONCERNING BUT
I DO THINK I THINK THAT THE
REPORT THAT WE PROVIDED- WILL
PROVIDE ENORMOUS GUIDANCE
MOVING FORWARD AND ABSOLUTELY
CONTINUE. THAT WE WOULD BE
DELIGHTED TO PROVIDE- AS WE
CONTINUE TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
HOW TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE- IN
THIS NEW THIS NEW WORLD. I NEED.
I NEED ONLY WITH THE L. A. L.
IN LINE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER IS QUESTIONS- WE
DO RECOGNIZE THE BENEFIT THAT
COMES FROM SELF HELP DOLLARS I
THINK THE REAL THEY'RE THE
REASON WHY WE TALK ABOUT THE
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS IN THE
NEED FOR IT IS THAT'S WHAT
GIVES YOU THE INFORMATION ABOUT
WHERE YOU CAN PUT DOLLARS TO
MAXIMIZE THE IMPACT FOR
INDIVIDUALS HER BEING SERVED
AND THERE IS A RECOGNITION
THERE THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
CASE TYPES- YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE GUARDIANSHIP OR
CONSERVATORSHIP. THAT LEND
ITSELF BETTER FOR IN PERSON
SERVICE AND THE OTHER CASE
TYPES- UNITS FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOU'RE STARTING OFF WITH FAMILY
LAW PROCEEDINGS THAT MIGHT LEND
ITSELF BETTER TOWARDS WORKSHOPS
AND TO TALK ABOUT MAXIMIZING
THE USE OF RESOURCES WHEN YOU
KNOW YOU NEED ONE ON ONE- TO
THE BEST OF TIMES FLEXIBLE AND
IT'S A RECOGNITION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AS IT'S THINKING
ABOUT HOW TO FIND A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE THAT
THERE IS- ANY NEED AT THAT
CONVENTION CUT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE HIGHER. AND THE
DOLLAR VALUE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE- IS ABLE TO KIND OF
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR AND SO WE
REALLY FOCUS ON BASICALLY THAT
CLASS BENEFIT ANALYSIS IS
REALLY FOCUSED ON HELPING TO
MAXIMIZE USE OF EVERY DOLLAR
THAT IS PUT IN. FOR SOUTH OF
DOLLARS. THANK YOU. MR LACKING
WE ARE JUST REAL TO FOLLOW UP-
MICHAEL ROOM AT I DO BUT THAT.
L. L. SUGGESTION OF A COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS WOULD WOULD
JUST HELP US BECOME WHAT THE
VOTERS EXPECT US TO BE IN AND
BE GOOD STEWARDS OF- MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE SOME CLARITY
AND SOME CONFIDENCE IN
MAXIMIZING THAT IMPACT WAS JUST
TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW WHEN WE
HAVE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES ALL
THE ONE SIZE FITS ALL IS VERY
DIFFICULT BUT I THINK THAT
THAT'S WHERE. WE NEED TO
COLLABORATE AND DISCUSS WITH
EACH OTHER TRYING TO FIND THE
BALANCE BETWEEN FLEXIBILITY AND
CONTROL BECAUSE- COMPLETE
INDEPENDENCE OFTEN DOESN'T
ALLOW US TO MAXIMIZE OUR OUR
BEST USE OF FUNDS EITHER SO-
I'M HOPING THAT WE WILL PURSUE
IN THE FUTURE A MORE DETAILED
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS SO THAT
WE CAN ACCOMPLISH THOSE GOALS.
THANK YOU- I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR PATIENCE WE
STARTED A LITTLE BIT LATER THAN
EXPECTED- AS WE WERE HEADED THE
LAY ON THE FLOOR. AND IT'S SO
ALL OF OUR PANELISTS ARE
ADJUSTING- TO THE SITUATION
AND- WE HAVE SOME CHILDCARE
ISSUES ALONG THE WAY AS WELL.
AND SO WE DO HAVE MULTIPLE
PANELS FOR A SESSION TO ISSUE
TWO AND ISSUE THREE. ALL OF
THESE ARE VERY IMPORTANT SO
JUST ASK THAT WE ARE MINDFUL OF
TIME ABOUT THAT WE DO COVER THE
IMPORTANT TOPICS AND SO WE
COULD JUST KEEP THAT IN MIND
OKAY WILL APPRECIATE THAT HELP
AS WELL. AS THE WEATHER I'M
GONNA MOVE TO THE SECOND PIECE
OF THIS ISSUE NUMBER TWO THE
ABILITY TO PAY EXPANSION. THE
PANELISTS MAY BEGIN. YES THANK
YOU THIS IS LAW COMPUTER WHICH
AGAIN I UNDERSTAND MY A VIDEO
MAY NOT BE A BIT CHOPPY
SEPTEMBER OFF. ON SELECT ISSUES
RELATED TO REQUEST EXPAND OUR
ABILITY TO PAY PROGRAM
STATEWIDE. GEN CLOSED OF POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO GROWING
TO FIFTY EIGHT POINT FOUR
MILLION. TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE AND RELATED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WE HAVE TO JUST A
COUNCIL SHELLEY CURRENT.
DIRECTOR OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SERVICES OFFICE ANOTHER PETTIT
ACTIVITIES MISSION TECHNOLOGY.
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
PROPOSAL. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M SHELLEY CURRENT- DIRECTOR
OF THE COUNCIL OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SERVICES OFFICE. ATP AS
WE CALL IT IS NOW AVAILABLE IN
SIX COUNTIES AND WE ARE VERY
PLEASED. WITH THE RESULTS TO
DATE- WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
ORIGINALLY ADOPTED- THE PILOTS
ARE REQUIRED THAT THE TOOL
RECOMMEND AT LEAST A 50%
REDUCTION. IN THE AMOUNT THE
CONSUMERS WHAT I'LL COURTS
FOLLOW BITTROLFF RECOMMENDATION
MOST THE TIME WAS 70% OF THE
REDUCTIONS BEING WITHIN TEN
DOLLARS OF THE RECOMMENDED
AMOUNT. THE AVERAGE REDUCTION
IS FIFTY FOUR PERCENT. AND THIS
SAVES THE AVERAGE LOW INCOME
USER SEVERAL HUNDRED DOLLARS
WITH EACH TICKET. A TO PAY ALSO
ADDRESSES THE PROBLEMS OF
LICENSE SUSPENSIONS AN ISSUE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS RAISED
CONCERNS ABOUT FOR MANY YEARS.
USING ATP COUNTS AS AN
APPEARANCE OF USERS AVOID
FAILURE TO APPEAR CITATION.
WITH SUBSEQUENT LICENSE HOLES
AND NO SIMPLE ASSESSMENTS. IN
ANTICIPATION OF THIS HEARING WE
RAN SOME DATA THIS MORNING AND
AS OF THIS MORNING. NEARLY
FIFTEEN THOUSAND REQUESTS WERE
APPROVED FROM OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND BUT AGAINST.
APPROXIMATELY 92% OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS LIVE OVER. 210050%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LINE. I
USERS LIKE THE TOOL WITHOUT THE
TOOL LITIGANTS SHOW UP TO COURT
PASS THROUGH THE- IN THE AMOUNT
OF. THIS ADDS TO THE COST
THROUGH OF WORK CHILDCARE. OR
TRENDS. WHEN WE DO THE TOOL WE
RECEIVED FROM SEVERAL
REPRESENTATIVES OF LOW INCOME
ADVOCATES THE WESTERN CENTER
EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER.
DANGEROUS THE ENCOURAGED US TO
ENSURE THAT THE TOOL IS READILY
ACCESSIBLE SO WE BUILT THE TOOL
TO WORK ON DESKTOPS LAPTOPS AND
SMARTPHONES. WHICH WAS
AVAILABLE IN BOTH ENGLISH AND
SPANISH WE SERVICE USERS AND
OVER 90% OF RESPONDENTS FELT
THAT THE ABILITY TO PAY TOOL
WAS HELPFUL. IN RESPONSE TO A
QUESTION ASKING EXACTLY WHAT
FACTORS MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO
COME TO COURT IN PERSON.
MAJORITY FUNDED THE TAKING TIME
OFF WORK AND FINDING.
TRANSPORTATION WITH THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES. CONCERNS WITH THE
PURPLE HAS RAISED. IN
ALTERNATIVE FOR NUMBER. CIVIL
SO AND BEEN SUGGESTED SO WE GOT-BACK LOOKED AT THE DATA
DEVELOPED BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE IMPACT OF THIS
PROPOSAL MIGHT BE. AND THERE
ARE TWO ITEMS THAT I CAN
HIGHLIGHT IS AND ASK IF YOU
CONSIDER. FIRST I WANT TO NOTE
THAT IF THE PROPOSAL WERE TO GO
FORWARD. LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHO RESPOND TO
THEIR TICKETS ON TIME WOULD
RECEIVE NO BENEFIT. ACCORDING
TO OUR DATA OVER 50% OF ATG
REQUESTED FOR APPROVAL INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHO DO NOT HAVE A
SUPPORT SYSTEM. I'M EXCITATIONS
WITHOUT THE CIVIL ASSESSMENT
REDUCTION WAS. TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY DOLLARS. IF EIGHTY P.
OR ABANDONED IN FAVOR OF A
LIMITED MUSICAL ASSESSMENT.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WOULD RECEIVE
NO BENEFIT. SECOND A SERVICEMAN
IS NOT NECESSARILY AN INDICATOR
OF POVERTY. WELL CERTAINLY LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO HAPPEN CIVIL
ASSESSMENT BECAUSE OF INABILITY
TO PAY. NOT EVERYONE WHO GETS A
SIMPLE ASSESSMENT IS
NECESSARILY LOW INCOME. SO WE
HOPE THAT YOU'LL APPROVED THIS
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE TARGETED
PROGRESSIVE RELIEF TO THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS. MAY BE
ELIGIBLE. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. SPEAKER
DELEO- ANNUALLY WITH THE L. A.
L. WE HAVE A FEW
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR YOU ON THIS
ITEM- FIRST WE ACTUALLY
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REJECTS THE PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD CANCEL
THE PILOT AND THE CURRENTLY
REQUIRED EVALUATION AND EXPAND
THE POOL STATEWIDE- AND THIS IS
BECAUSE CERTAIN COMPONENTS OF
PROCESS OF BEING ROLLED OUT
SUCH AS ONLINE TRIALS- THAT
SHOULD BE COMING OUT AND BEING
TESTED IN THE SPRING AND SO
THAT COULD HAVE AN IMPACT ON
COSTS. ADDITIONALLY AND
EVALUATION OF A COMPLETED PILOT
IS REALLY HELPFUL TO ACCURATELY
DETERMINE THE IMPACTS OF THE
VARIOUS ACTIVITIES BEING TESTED
TO THEN INFORM FUTURE
LEGISLATIVE- DECISION SO FOR
EXAMPLE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT
TO CONSIDER A HIGHER AUTOMATIC
REDUCTION FOR LOWER INCOME
INDIVIDUALS OR REDUCTIONS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO DON'T CURRENTLY%
QUALIFY UNDER THE DEFINITION OF
LOW INCOME- BUT OUR SECOND
RECOMMENDATION IS IF THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO MOVE
FORWARD AND EXPANDS THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE OF THE
ABILITY TO QUE PIECE OF THE
TALK WE DO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ONLY APPROVED THE
TWELVE POINT THREE MILLION
REQUESTED FOR THE BUDGET YEAR.
AND THIS WOULD PROVIDE LOWER
INCOME INDIVIDUALS WITH THE
RELIEF- BUT IT WOULD PREVENT
THE PROGRAM FROM AUTOMATICALLY
ROLLING OUT BEYOND THE TEN
PORTS THAT WOULD BE SUPPORTED
USING THESE DOLLARS- AFTER THE
BUDGET YEAR BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A CHANCE TO
SORT OF EVALUATE TAKE THE
INFORMATION FROM THE EVALUATION
THAT STILL AND USE THAT AS PART
OF ITS DELIBERATIONS- THE FINAL
PIECES THIS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE DOES INCLUDE- LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR ALL
INFRACTION PROCEEDINGS TO OCCUR
REMOTELY- AND SO ON THAT ONE IF
THE LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED
IN IMPROVING ITBECAUSE IT DOES
HAVE BENEFITS OF PROMOTING
EQUITY AND INCREASING ACCESS.
WE O RECOMMENDS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH TO SUBMIT AN EVALUATION
OR REPORT ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE LANGUAGE IN ORDER TO
INFORM FUTURE LEGISLATIVE
DECISIONS IN THIS AREA SUCH AS
WHETHER TO EXPAND REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS TO OTHER CASE TYPES
FOR EXAMPLE IS. REALLY RIGHT
NOW THE IMPACT ON COURT
WORKLOAD AND HOSTAGE ANOTHER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS ON THIS ITEM.
I JUST ZERO NINE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE GO AHEAD. BASED ON
PRELIMINARY DATA WE KNOW THAT
THIS PROGRAM IS PROVIDING
SUBSTANTIAL AND CRITICAL RELIEF
TO LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS WHO
CURRENTLY FACE UNDUE FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP FROM FINES AND FEES
UNFORTUNATELY THIS RELIEF IS
CURRENTLY LIMITED TO
INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN ONE OF
THE SMALL NUMBER OF COUNTIES
PARTICIPATING IN THE PILOT
PROGRAM GIVEN THE BURDEN FINES
AND FEES IMPOSED ON WELCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHICH HAVE BEEN
COMPOUNDED BY THE RECENT
IMPACTS FROM THE ECONOMIC
RECESSION. WE STILL THERE'S AN
OUTAGE WE FEEL THERE IS AN
URGENT NEED TO EXTEND TARGET
REALLY WALLOWING COMMITTEE
BIGGLES REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY LIVE FURTHERMORE THIS
PROPOSAL ALLOWS FOR THE
TRAVELERS TO MODERNIZE THEIR
OPERATIONS WITH ADDITIONAL
FEATURES SUCH AS ONLINE
EDUCATION INFRACTIONS WHICH
FURTHER PROMOTES ACCESS TO
JUSTICE FOR COURT USERS ONLINE
EDUCATION OF INFRACTIONS IS
ALSO CRITICAL TO PROMOTE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING WHICH
MEDICAID PUBLIC HEALTH RISKS
FACED BY CALIFORNIANS.
OTHERWISE AFTERSHOW TO REPORT
DURING THE ACADEMIC INFRACTION
GENERALLY ACCOUNT FOR MORE THAN
60% OF COURT FILINGS WHICH
MEANS A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
IN THE SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHAT COULD ACTUALLY
BENEFIT FROM BEING ABLE TO
EDUCATE THEIR INFRACTIONS
REMOTELY RATHER THAN GOING INTO
THE PORT. ALTHOUGH WE DO NOT
HAVE COMPREHENSIVE REPORTING
RESULTS ON THE HIGHWAY AS
MENTIONED ABOVE THE RETENTION
BEFORE HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO HELP
COMES FROM THE PARTY'S BEEN
COUNTIES THAT IMPLEMENTED
ONLINE UNITED NATIONS IS
PROMISING INTRODUCED BINDING
FEES FOR LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS
BY FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AS OF JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR
INTERMINGLING. WE'RE PROPOSING
A PHASED ROLLOUT OF THE PROGRAM
AND ITS ADDITIONAL IT DOES NOT
MAKE IT BECOMES AVAILABLE BASED
ON THE REPORT JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WILL BE ABLE TO
COURSE CORRECT AND MAKE ANY
NECESSARY CHANGES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. WITH THIS PROCESS
THANK YOU. AT THANK YOU A
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S- I A
QUESTION- BEFORE OPEN UP THE
COMMITTEE. SO WE KNOW THAT THE
PILOTS ARE SHOWING THAT. YOU
SET THE COURTS ARE FOLLOWING
THE RECOMMENDATION- BUT WE DO
KNOW THAT IF I CONSISTENT
ACROSS ACROSS THE COUNTIES THAT
WE SEE DIFFERENT APPLICATIONS-
AND DIFFERENT COURT ROOMS OUT
THERE AND SO HOW CAN WE ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE MORE CONSISTENCY
ACROSS THE COUNTIES. IF I MAY
MADAM CHAIR THIS IS SHELLY
BERMAN WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL- WHEN THE LEGISLATION
WAS ORIGINALLY ADOPTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE THE LEGISLATURE
REQUESTED THAT- LANGUAGE BE
INCLUDED WHERE PEOPLE RECEIVE
AT LEAST A 50% AFFECT WHICH
WOULD RECOMMEND A 50% BENEFIT.
SOME COURTS CHOSE TO PROVIDE-
GREATER RELIEF- BECAUSE THAT
WORKS FOR THEM VOCALLY AND SO
MOST COURTS HAVE FOLLOWED WITH
THE LEGISLATURE HAS SUGGESTED
OTHER COURTS HAVE GONE A LITTLE
BIT FURTHER- BUT WHAT WE REALLY
HOPE FOR IS. A DISCRETION
BECAUSE WITH JUDICIAL OFFICERS
DO IS THEY LOOK AT THE FACTS OF
THE CASE AND THEN MAKE A
DETERMINATION. I WILL NOTE
THAT- CONSUMERS ARE RECEIVING
ABOUT A 54% THAT'S THE AVERAGE
REDUCTION. AND AROUND 70% OF
THE TIME- THE JUDICIAL OFFICERS
ARE WITHIN TEN DOLLARS OF. THE
AMOUNT THAT'S RECOMMENDED FROM
THE FULL. MEMBERS. I DON'T HAVE
A CONSISTENT WITH WITH WHAT WE
SAID BEFORE I WONDER FOR GOING
ABOUT THIS THE RIGHT WAY
BECAUSE THIS IS A PROBLEM WITH
THE RISEN FROM THE FEE
STRUCTURE IN THE IN THE COURTS
AND FIND THAT WE'RE DOING THIS
AND PROVIDING SOME RELIEF BUT
THAT'S DETRIMENTAL TO HOW WE
FINANCE THE COURT SYSTEMS AND
BECAUSE WE'VE JUST PUT OFF THAT
DISCUSSION AND BUILT A SYSTEM
WHERE. THESE FEES AND FINES ARE
ARE SO IMPORTANT WE'RE NOT
HAVING TO COME AROUND AND IN
PROVIDE A PILOT TO LOOK AT THE
BILLION TO PAY WHEN WE REALLY
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT THE AT.
THE UNDERLYING. WAY THAT WE
HAVE BUILT THE SYSTEM SO I HOPE
THAT SOMETHING THAT THAT WILL
REMAIN ON THE TABLE AND WE'RE
NOT JUST GOING TO BE. LOOKING
AT AT A RELIEF TO. A FINANCING
MECHANISM- THIS ABILITY TO PAY
PILOT PROGRAM WITHOUT REALLY
LOOKING AT THE UNDERLYING CAUSE
OF WHY WE GOT TO THE SITUATION
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO LOOK AT.
IN THE FUTURE SO. I THINK THIS
IS GOOD AS FAR AS IT IS BUT I
THINK WE ALSO NEED TO TAKE
HARD LOOK AT THE WHAT WE'VE
BEEN RELYING ON TO FUND. COURTS.
NORTHERN OR FURTHER QUESTIONS
ON THE SANDEMAN GONNA MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT A PANEL ON REMOTE
CIVIL PROCEEDINGS. BEGAN YES
THANK YOU AGAIN THIS IS LUCK
WITH YOUR SEARCH FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. THAT'S
PROPOSAL IS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO LAUGH REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS AND ALL CIVIL
ACTIONS THIS LANGUAGE IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE BRAND'S
POST CONDIMENT BUDGET TIME TO
PROVIDE FOR GREATER EQUITY IN
ACCESS TO JUSTICE. FOR THE
PUBLIC IN CIVIL MATTERS THIS
BUDGET PLAN INCLUDES TWO OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE PEOPLE'S TO
DISCUSS. AND WE WILL DISCUSS
ADDITIONAL- PROPOSALS LATER
FIRST WE HAVE PRESIDING JUDGE
OF ALAMEDA SUPERIOR COURT-
SINCE JUDGE TESTED TELL US TO
PROVIDE. A BRIEF DESCRIPTION OF
HOW REMOTE PROCEEDINGS HAVE IT
WILL MATERIALLY BENEFIT COURT
USERS AND COURT OPERATIONS YOU
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY THE ARRIVAL
YOUNG ON THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. ON
THE PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. THIRTY
EVERYONE AND THANK U. S. SOCCER
SAID MY NAME IS HARD AS A CHILD
I AM THE PRESIDING JUDGE OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT.
I'M ALSO THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
TRIAL COURT PRESIDING JUDGES
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. AND I'M HERE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
TRAILER LEGISLATION THE TRAILER
BILL PROMOTING THE CONTINUANCE
OF REMOTE PROCEEDINGS EVEN
AFTER THIS PANDEMIC. NOW WHEN
THE CORONA VIRUS PANDEMIC
FORCED THE UNFORTUNATE CLOSURE
OF OUR COURT AND DRASTIC
MODIFICATION OF COURT
OPERATIONS ONE YEAR AGO WE
STRUGGLED TO FIGURE OUT. HOW
OMITS THE PANDEMIC WHITE MEAT
MIGHT WE BE ABLE TO RE OPEN AND
CONTINUE COURT OPERATIONS IN A
WAY. THAT WOULD MAINTAIN AND
PROMOTE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF ALL OF OUR CORE USERS. AND
OUR COURT PERSONNEL. THE ANSWER
WAS THROUGH REMOTE OPERATIONS.
AND THE WAY WE WERE ABLE TO DO
THIS WAS WITH THE HELP AND
ASSISTANCE OF THE CHIEF JUSTICE
AND THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL. IT
WAS AN APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
WHERE THE CHIEF JUSTICE AND THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ENACTED
EMERGENCY RULE THREE WHICH
AUTHORIZED EACH OF OUR COURTS
TO ENACT EMERGENCY LOCAL RULES
THAT MIGHT REQUIRE. REMOTE
APPEARANCES IN COURT
PROCEEDINGS. ALAMEDA COUNTY WAS
ONE OF A NUMBER OF COURTS THAT
CONSISTENT WITH THIS AUTHORITY
ENACTED LOCAL RULES. OUR
EMERGENCY LOCAL RULES MANDATED
REMOTE APPEARANCES ACROSS ALL
NON CRIMINAL JUDICIAL
PROCEEDINGS. AND THIS IS HOW WE
WERE ABLE TO RE OPEN. AND
RESUME COURT OPERATIONS ACROSS
ALL CASE TYPES THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC DESPITE THE SPIKES
DESPITE THE SEARCHES AND
INCLUDING JURY TRIALS. WHAT WE
LEARNED FROM THIS WAS THE
REMOTE PROCEEDINGS GAVE US
TREMENDOUS BENEFITS FIRST AND
FOREMOST IT UNQUESTIONABLY
EXPANDED ACCESS TO OUR COURTS.
THAT OPPORTUNITY WAS FELT BY
LITIGANTS WHO PREVIOUSLY PRE
PANDEMIC HAD TO TRAVEL ACROSS
THE COUNTY TAKE TIME OFF WORK
MAKE ARRANGEMENTS FOR CHILD
CARE DEPENDENT CARE AND SO ON
TO SIT IN THE COURTHOUSE
PERHAPS ALL DAY FOR A COURT
HEARING THAT MIGHT TAKE AS
LITTLE AS THIRTY MINUTES. THESE
LITIGANTS NOW CAN ACCESS THEIR
COURT APPEARANCE CAN
PARTICIPATE FULLY REMOTELY
WITHOUT THAT SUBSTANTIAL
ALTERATION TO THEIR SCHEDULE.
SIGNALLY ATTORNEYS WHO
PREVIOUSLY HAD TO CLEAR
CALENDARS NOW ARE ABLE TO
REPRESENT MULTIPLE CLIENTS IN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS. THIS
BENEFIT BENEFITS THE LITIGANTS
WHO ARE HIRING THE ATTORNEYS
BECAUSE THEY NO LONGER HAVE TO
PAY THOSE TRAVEL COSTS THEY NO
LONGER HAVE TO PAY FOR THE TIME
THAT THE ATTORNEYS ARE WAITING
IN COURT. NOW THESE ACCESS
OPPORTUNITIES ARE WHAT WE HOPED
AND EXPECTED WOULD HAPPEN WHEN
WE ENACTED OUR OWN EMERGENCY
REMOTE ROLES BUT WE'VE IN FACT
FOUND ADDITIONAL BENEFITS THAT
WERE NOT ORIGINALLY
CONTEMPLATED. FOR EXAMPLE IN
HIGH CONFLICT CALENDAR COURT
SUCH AS FAMILY LAW PROBATE
RESTRAINING ORDER CALENDARS WE
FOUND THAT REMOTE APPEARANCES
ACTUALLY DECREASE THE TENSION
LEVELS IN THOSE COURTS. BY NOT
HAVING TO SIT ACROSS THE TABLE
FROM SOMEBODY WHO YEAR IN IT D.
BATTLE WITH. THAT TENSION IS
REDUCED SUCH THAT REMOTE
APPEARANCES HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
ABLE TO FACILITATE SETTLEMENT
AND DIFFERENT CASE AND ISSUE
RESOLUTION OPPORTUNITY. IN
OTHER SENSITIVE AREAS WE'VE
ALSO SEEN THE BENEFITS OF
REMOTE APPEARANCES FOR EXAMPLE
IN CERTAIN JUVENILE PROCEEDINGS
OR COLLABORATIVE COURTS REMOTE
APPEARANCES ENABLED LITIGANTS
TO MAINTAIN THEIR CONTINUUM OF
CARE. THEY CAN BE EFFECTIVELY
REPRESENTED AND CAN PARTICIPATE
IN COURT REMOTELY AND STILL
MAINTAIN THEIR HOUSING THEIR
TREATMENT AND THEY'RE
ADDITIONAL CARE OPPORTUNITIES.
IN ADDITION. JURORS LIKE OUR
REMOTE APPEARANCES REMOTE
APPEARANCES HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND THE POOL
OF POTENTIAL JURORS WHO WORK
WITH OUR COURTS IT ADDRESSES
THE NEEDS OF THOSE THAT MIGHT
HAVE TRANSPORTATION ISSUES OR
CERTAIN HEALTH OR HOME
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT NEED TO BE
DEALT WITH POTENTIALLY
BROADENING THE SCOPE OF THOSE
THAT CAN ALSO SERVE OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM AS JURORS. IN ADDITION
THOSE JURORS THROUGH ROAD
APPEARANCES HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE AND HEAR THE
EVIDENCE THE SAME WAY SOMETHING
THAT OUR OLD COURTHOUSES DO NOT
NECESSARILY AFFORD. THE REMOTE
APPEARANCES HAVE BEEN SUCH A
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY. THAT HAS RECENTLY AS
JUST LAST MONTH ON FEBRUARY
EIGHT WE ENACTED A NON
EMERGENCY LOCAL RULES TO
PROMOTE THE CONTINUANCE OF
REMOTE APPEARANCES EVEN POST
PANDEMIC AS CONSISTENT WITH THE
LAW. AND THAT'S JUST ONE REASON
WHY WE SUPPORT THIS TRAILER
LANGUAGE. AS WE KNOW AND AS HAS
BEEN REFERRED TO AT THIS YEAR
AND SO FAR THE LEGAL SYSTEM IS
OFTEN SLOW IN PARTICULAR THE
COURTS AND NOT QUICK TO ADJUST.
THE PANDEMIC HAS FORCED OUR
RAPID MOVEMENT IN ALL
DIRECTIONS THAT WE DID NOT
ANTICIPATE. BUT SOME OF THIS
MOVEMENT HAS BEEN FOR THE CUT.
AND THAT IS WITH REMOTE
APPEARANCE WHAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO DO IS CARRY THIS POSITIVE
MOMENTUM FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO SERVE ALL OF THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA. AS
EFFICIENTLY. AND EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE THE TRAILER
LEGISLATION WOULD ENABLE THAT
TO HAPPEN WITH OUT CREATING A
GAP. WITHOUT CREATING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A PAUSE FOR A
STOP BACK THAT WOULD SERIOUSLY
UNDERMINE THE GREAT PROGRESS
THAT WE'VE MADE SO FAR. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME I'M NOT HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
CONCLUSION OF OUR SPEAKERS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I JUST
DEPARTMENT FINANCE THE GOAL OF
THE LANGUAGE IS TO PROMOTE
MODERNIZATION AND ACCESS TO
JUSTICE. ALLOW COURTS THE
REMOTE TECHNOLOGY BUILD UP
DURING THE PANDEMIC I'M JUST
LIKE YOU KNOW THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE AND THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL THE POTENTIALLY REFINE
THE LANGUAGE IN REGARDS TO THE
ALEJO'S RECOMMENDATION. FOR A
PILOT TO POTENTIALLY BE
COMPLETED I JUST WANTED TO NOTE
THAT THE TRUMP WORDS HAVE BEEN
ADMINISTERING HERBAL
PROCEEDINGS FOR CIVIL CASES
OVER FOR JUST ABOUT A YEAR AND
THAT CAN YOU COME FROM A BILL
TO PROVIDE DIGESTIBLE DATA
CONCERNING THESE PROCEEDINGS
WHICH COULD POTENTIALLY REMOVE
THE NECESSITY FOR A PILOT
PROGRAM TO BE COMPLETED. AGAIN
THIS WILL NEED TO TAKE PLACE IN.
FUTURE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE
HAVE DONE AROUND. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S THE LET'S
ANALYST. I NEED ONLY WITH THE
L. A. L. ARE UNDERSTANDING OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE A
COPY OF OUR HAND OUT BUT IT WAS
POSTED ONLINE ALONG WITH THE
AGENDA AND IS ALSO AVAILABLE ON
OUR WEBSITE ON THIS ISSUE- IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME WE'RE JUST
GOING TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW KEY
THINGS THAT WILL- HELP
UNDERSTAND OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
ON THIS ISSUE. IN THE FIRST
THING THAT WE JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS WE VIEW THIS LANDS
AT THROUGH THE LENS OF
PROVIDING THIS AUTHORITY ON AN
ONGOING BASIS WHICH MEANS AFTER
THE PANDEMIC ENDS AND WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A
SITUATION AND USE APPROPRIATE
USE OF REMOTE PROCEEDINGS
DURING THE PANDEMIC BUT THEN
ALSO AFTER THE PANDEMIC SO I
THINK THAT'S THE FIRST THING
THAT WE WANT WANT TO HIGHLIGHT.
ON BECAUSE OF THE BENEFITS WE
DO THINK THAT THE EXPANSION OF
REMOTE PROCEEDING IS WARRANTED
BUT THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS
THAT WE HAVE AND SO THE FIRST
THING THAT WE WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR USE IN ALL CASE
TYPES ARE PROCEEDINGS. OR
WHETHER THERE SHOULD BE STATE
LAW THAT INCLUDES A CERTAIN
MINIMUM STANDARDS TO ENSURE
THAT COURT USERS ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE SIMILAR EXPERIENCES
AND SO CURRENTLY THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE ACCESS SPECIFIC AT
LEAST SIGNIFICANT
IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS TO THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH IF YOU LOOK AT
OUR HAND OUT ON PAGEFIVE- IT
LAYS OUT THE KEY QUESTIONS BUT
INCLUDES HOW WOULD COURTS USE
THE FORTY IS IT GONNA BE
REQUIRED OR OPTIONAL HOW WOULD
THE COURT PROCESSES CHANGE.
WOOD FAIRNESS EQUITY PRIVACY IN
PUBLIC ACCESS ISSUES BE
ADDRESSED AND IF SO IN WHAT
MANNER AS A BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE DETAILS ON THESE ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION IT'S REALLY HARD
FOR US TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
IMPACTS ON TRIAL COURT
OPERATIONS PROCESSES AND COSTS
WOULD BE AND SO IF YOU LOOK AT
PAGES SIX AND SEVEN OF THE ONLY
A HAND OUT IT LAYS OUT SOME OF
THOSE. KEY IMPACTS SUCH AS YOU
KNOW WHAT WOULD BE THE NET
IMPACT ON COURT WORKLOAD AND
COST BUT GOING BACK TO
SOMETHING THAT IS SIMPLY MEMBER
STONE ACTUALLY BROUGHT UP WHAT
WOULD BE THE IMPACT ON ONGOING
FACILITY- AND SO IN LIGHT OF
THESE CONCERNS WE DO HAVE TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS THE FIRST
RECOMMENDATION IS ON PAGE.
EIGHT OF THE HANDOUT AND
SPECIFICALLY ON THIS ONE. WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LET. TO THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH TO SUBMIT A
DETAILED PLAN. FOR HOW REMOTE.
WOULD BE AND- BY CASE TYPE AND
WE'RE PROCEEDING TYPE. SO THIS
PLAN WHICH ADDRESSES SOME OF
THOSE IMPLEMENTATION QUESTIONS
WOULD HELP THE LEGISLATURE
DETERMINE WHETHER. AND HOW TO
MODIFY THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE TO
ENSURE THAT. REMOTE PROCEEDINGS
IS USED IN A WAY THAT IS ON THE
IN LINE WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES SUCH AS YOU KNOW
SETTING MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR
EXCLUDING CERTAIN TYPES OF
PROCEEDINGS. FROM WROTE FROM
REMOTE- OPERATING REMOTELY. AND
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
INFORMATION CAN BE PROVIDED IN
THE BUDGET YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
MY SPINAL CORD. BUT IF THEY
CAN'T THEN IT COULD BE A
DISCUSSION FOR THE NEXT BUDGET
HERE. OUR SECOND RECOMMENDATION
IS IF THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO
MOVE FORWARD BEFORE A PLAN IS
RECEIVED AND THIS IS GONNA BE
ON PAGE NINE OF YOUR HAND OUT.
AND UNDER THIS ONE WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PILOT REMOTE PROCEEDINGS FOR
TWO YEARS AND LESS COMPLEX CASE
TYPES OR PROCEEDINGS. SUCH AS
INFRACTIONS ARE SMALL CLAIMS
PLACES AND REQUIRING EVALUATION
BY NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. THIS APPROACH WOULD INFORM
LEGISLATIVE DECISIONS ON
WHETHER TO EXTEND EXPAND OR
MODIFY THE AUTHORIZATION ONCE
THE PILOT ENDS. AND THIS WOULD
ALLOW FOR ANY IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES TO BE IDENTIFIED AND
RESOLVED IN AREAS THAT HAVE
LESS IMPACT ON COURT USERS
LIVES. BEFORE BEING EXPANDED TO
MORE COMPLEX CASE TYPES AND
PROCEEDINGS WHICH WOULD HAVE
THE BENEFIT OF MINIMIZING
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND
COSTS- IN RELATION TO MR ROMIJN
COMMENTS ABOUT THE PANDEMIC AND
USING THAT AS A PILOT. WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF LESSONS LEARNT
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC- BUT THE
KEY THING THAT WE WOULD
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT INDIVIDUAL
COURTS HAVE HAD DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES. BASED ON THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEIR LOCAL
PRIORITIES AND SO I THINK THAT
THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
WE ARE SAYING THAT IF YOU DON'T
WANT TO GO WITH OUR FIRST
APPROACH OUR FIRST
RECOMMENDATION IN TERMS OF THE
PLAN. YOU THINK ABOUT PILOTING
ACROSS THE STATE SO WE HAVE A
BETTER SENSE OF HOW. TRIAL
COURTS GENERALLY ACROSS THE
STATE. WOULD BE IMPACTED. THANK
YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANYONE ELSE
THAT TO SPEAK ON THE SIDE OF.
MADAM SHERRY AND ROB- YEAH
AGAIN THAT FOR THE R. J.
COUNCIL PROVIDE A BIT MORE
FIRST ON THE ISSUE. THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU ROBERT- YEAH FROM
G. CAL- I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON THE
ROLE PROCEEDINGS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. AND WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT LIKE WE'RE DOING
TODAY AT THIS HEARING A
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY BY VIDEO
NOT ONLY OFFERS SAY IT'S SAFE
AND CONVENIENT WAY FOR THE
PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE IN
IMPORTANT PROCEEDINGS DURING
THE PANDEMIC. ABOUT WILL
PROVIDE CONTINUED EXPANDED
ACCESS TO JUSTICE IN THE FUTURE
I REMOTE APPEARANCES AS WELL AS
MANY OF THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WHICH INCLUDE
MODERNIZATION FUNDING. ENDEMIC
EARLY DISPOSITION CALENDAR
PROGRAM SUPPORT FOR SELF HELP
AN ONLINE TRAFFIC EDUCATION ARE
ALL PIECES OF A MUCH BIGGER
PLAN DESIGNED TO INCREASE
EQUITY AND ACCESS ROUTE THE
STATE. THE PANDEMIC WHILE THE
NUMBER OF CASE FILINGS DROPPED
BY ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT. THE
NUMBER OF CASES POSITIONS HAVE
BEEN REDUCED BY ABOUT. 50% IN
TWENTY TWENTY COMPARED TO
TWENTY NINETEEN IT'S ONLY
BECAUSE OF REMOTE HEARINGS THAT
THIS NUMBER IS NOT WORSE.
FUNDING FOR REMOTE HEARINGS
HAVE BEEN PART OF THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH'S STRATEGIC PLAN FOR
TECHNOLOGY FOR ABOUT SEVEN
YEARS SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN.
WE'VE ALL EXPERIENCED THE
CHALLENGES OF REMOTE PROCEEDING
SUCH AS FORGETTING TO GO OFF
MUTE BUT WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
PUBLIC THAT REMOTE HEARINGS
PROVIDE EQUITY. IN THE
COURTROOM. M. FOR EXAMPLE
PROVIDING JUVENILES AN EQUAL
SPACE ON THE VIDEO SCREEN
RATHER THAN BEING OVERSHADOWED
BY ADULTS IN A LARGE
COURTHOUSE. REMOTE PROCEEDINGS
ARE LEVELING THE PLAYING FIELD
AND PROGRESS IS UNDENIABLE.
WE'VE HAD SUCCESS. IN
TELEPHONIC HEARING FOR MANY
YEARS AND NOW WHERE TELEPHONIC
HEARINGS HAVE GIVEN PEOPLE A
VOICE IN COURT. PROCEEDINGS
HAVE NOW GIVEN THEM AN EQUAL
PRESENCE WITHOUT THIS TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WILL BE LIMITING
ACCESS AND BE TAKING AWAY
VALUABLE SERVICE TO THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE LINE
WHICH IS VERY BROAD AND IT'S
NOT CLEAR TO ME ARE WE ALLOWING
EACH. COUNTY TO EMPLOYMENT- THE
ONLY PROCEEDINGS. HOWEVER THEY
WANT. CAN SOMEONE ANSWER THAT
QUESTION FOR ME. GO AHEAD- THE
HEAD. IT IN TERMS OF THE-
PROMOTE PROCEEDINGS WELL WHAT
WE HAVE ACTUALLY DONE DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND- AS MR
ROMANIAN HAS MENTIONED WE HAVE
TREATED THIS PANDEMIC PERIOD AS
THE PILOT PERIOD AND SO DURING
THIS TIME WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS
WE HAVE COLLECTED FEEDBACK BOTH
FROM THE PUBLIC AS WELL AS FROM
THE COURTS IN TERMS OF BEST
PRACTICES- CONSISTENCY USE AND
SO WE'VE ACTUALLY PUBLISH SOME
GUIDELINES IN A PANDEMIC.
CONTINUITY OF OPERATIONS
RESOURCE GUIDE- WHICH TALKS
ABOUT- GENERAL CONFIGURATION
BEST PRACTICES THAT COURTS CAN
USE AND SO WE ANTICIPATE HI N.
AS WE SEE NOW- THAT COURTS WILL
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENCES BASED ON
THEIR LOCAL DEPENDENCIES OUR
TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SO FORTH- HOWEVER WE DO.
ANTICIPATE THAT PEOPLE WILL
BEGIN FOLLOWING THOSE
GUIDELINES FOR CONSISTENCY AND
LEVERAGING BEST PRACTICES
ACROSS THE DIFFERENT COURT.
WITH SOMEONE ELSE CAN I SAY
SOMETHING ON THAT. AVERAGE THIS
IS A NEARLY WITH THE L. A. L.
WE WERE JUST GONNA WE WERE
GOING TO BRING UP THAT THAT IS
ONE OF THE KEY IMPLEMENTATION
QUESTIONS THAT WE BELIEVE NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED IN OUR READING
OF THE LANGUAGE WE DO THINK
IT'S QUITE BROAD AND THE
DISCRETION IS PROVIDED TO BOTH
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. AS WELL AS
THE COURTS IN TERMS OF HOW TO
MOVE FORWARD IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION. THANK YOU I DO
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS THAT
WILL HAVE SOME COUNTIES WHO
WILL. PROCEED WITH THE MAILLET
PROCEEDING SOME MIGHT NOT DO
ANY. SO MICHAEL ALL THE WAY AND
SO. IT'S GOING TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE SOMETHING CONSISTENT
ACROSS. THE STATE. AS WELL AS
WE DO BEST PRACTICES ENSURE%
THAT IMPLEMENTATION IS FAIR AND
EQUITABLE. ALLOWING SOME
FLEXIBILITY. OUT THERE AND SO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. THE MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANYTHING TRIED.
OKAY HI IN THAT CASE I WILL
MOVE ON TO- THE NEXT ISSUE
ISSUE NUMBER THREE DOJ OVERVIEW-
WE WILL HAVE A SUB COMMITTEE
FOR THE DNA LAB CONSOLIDATION.
THE PANEL MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THIS IS CHRIS RYAN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
I'M IN THE INTEREST OF TIME WE
WILL- ABBREVIATE OUR COMENTS
BUT WE ARE CERTAINLY OPEN TO
QUESTIONS. THE DEPARTMENT'S
PROPOSED BUDGET IS ONE POINT
ONE BILLION FOR THE BUDGET YEAR
APPROXIMATELY 70% OF THOSE-
FUNDS ARE SPECIAL FUNDS AND
FROM APPROXIMATE THIRTY
SEPARATE SPECIAL FUNDS AN
APPROXIMATE 30% OF THE BUDGET I
REQUEST GENERAL FUND THREE
AN APARTMENT THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS APPROXIMATELY
FIVE THOUSAND EMPLOYEES IN
OFFICE BUILDINGS LABS FIELD
OFFICES AND TASK FORCES ACROSS
THE STATE FROM A BUDGET
PERSPECTIVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS COMPRISED OF THE
DIVISION OF LEGAL SERVICES
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INFORMATION
SERVICES DIVISION THE DIVISION
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION. AND OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF TODAY IS THAT-
THERE ARE FOUR BCPS THAT WILL
COVER AT A AT A HIGH LEVEL- TO
THE EXTENT THERE ARE QUESTIONS
ON THOSE BCPS WE HAVE FOLKS
AVAILABLE. SO THE FIRST PCP
THAT WILL COVER THE HEALTHCARE
RIGHTS AND ACCESS DIVISION
WORKLOAD THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REQUEST TEN POSITIONS AND TWO
POINT ONE MILLION. FROM THE
PUBLIC RIGHTS AW ENFORCEMENT
SPECIAL FUND IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND I'M GOING TO THE
DOJ TO ADDRESS THE WORKLOAD
RELATED TO HEALTH CARE RIGHTS
AND ACCESS- THIS IS A PROPOSAL
ON THIS PORTION OF THE
PROPOSAL- WAS PRESENTED LAST
YEAR IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
BUT DURING THE MAY REVISED-
THIS PART OF THE PROPOSAL WAS
THE GENERAL FUND REQUEST AND SO
DURING THE MAY REVISE IT WAS
PULLED OUT- WE HAVE BROUGHT IT
BACK- WITH THE NEW FUNDING
SOURCES SPECIAL FUND- THAT CAN
FUND THESE OPERATIONS THROUGH
SETTLEMENT. FUNDS AND THE
WORKLOAD RELATED TO THESE
POSITIONS RELATES PRIMARILY TO
OUR ABILITY OR CAPACITY TO
CONDUCT COMPETITIVE IMPACT
ANALYSIS RELATED TO HOSPITAL
CONSOLIDATION TRANSACTIONS. AND
OVERSEEING THE ACTIVITY IN THE
WORK- SO STAYED WITH THE SUTTER
CASE- AND TO INVESTIGATE AND
BRING SUIT AGAINST OTHER LARGE
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEGUN
TO MIMIC- SUTTER'S ANTI
COMPETITIVE CONDUCT. WITHOUT
THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. THE
HEALTH CARE RIGHTS AND ACCESS
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO ENGAGE. IN
ALL THE ACT PLANNED FOR AND
BRINGING. AGAINST OTHER HEALTH
SYSTEMS THAT WE BELIEVE TO BE
ENGAGED IN SIMILAR ANTI
COMPETITIVE ACTIVITIES. THE
NEXT REQUEST- THAT'LL COVER
RELATED TO THE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE UTILIZATION REVIEW
AND EVALUATION SYSTEM THIS IS
THE CARE SYSTEM. IT'S A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
INFORMATION SERVICES SYSTEM-
AND THIS IS A SYSTEM THAT IS
ALREADY IN PLACE- THESE ARE
HELP DESK POSITIONS- THE
FUNDING FLOWS TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE THROUGH A
REIMBURSEMENT AGREEMENT-
COVERS- IT'S ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND- AND
COVERS POSITIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH PROVIDING HELP DESK
SERVICES- TO FOLKS THAT ACCESS
THE INFORMATION OR ART. ARE
INPUTTING INFORMATION INTO THE
SYSTEM- IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE
CURES PROGRAM RECEIVED AN
AVERAGE OF. ALMOST FIVE
THOUSAND CALLS RELATED TO-
EMAILS AND- AND CALLS PER MONTH
AND SO WE'RE E'RE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE SPLIT
CONTINUE THESE POSITIONS THAT
I'VE BEEN WORKING FOR US FOR
THE PAST FEW YEARS. THE NEXT
PROPOSAL IS THE NORTHERN REGION
CONSOLIDATED FORENSIC SCIENCE
LABORATORY CAMPUS- AGAIN THIS
IS A PROPOSAL THAT WE HAD
STARTED LAST YEAR- LAST YEAR
YOU SAW SOME. PROPOSAL RELATED
TO LAND ACQUISITION THIS
PROPOSAL IS SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION RELATED. TO GLAVIN
OFFICE SPACE IN SACRAMENTO. AND
SO IT WOULD CONSOLIDATE BRENT
BUREAU FORENSIC SERVICES-
RICHMOND IN A LAB THE
SACRAMENTO REGION CRIME LAB.
CALIFORNIA CRIMINALISTICS
INSTITUTE AND THE HEADQUARTERS
STAFF ALL INTO. ONE FACILITY-
THE FINAL PCP PROPOSAL THAT
WILL COVER AND THEN I
UNDERSTAND LA YOU HAVE SOME
COMMENTS- RELATES TO THE DNA
IDENTIFICATION FUND BACKFILL-
THIS IS A FUND THAT HAS SEEN
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE DROPS- THE
LAST EW YEARS- AS WAS
DISCUSSED DURING THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL'S BUDGET- RELATED TO
FINES AND FEE REVENUE. ANSWER
THIS BACK PHIL- BACK FEELS
THOSE THOSE REVENUES IT
DIMINISHED AND INSURES THAT THE
FORENSIC LAB. HAS THE REVENUE
NEEDED TO MAINTAIN ITS CURRENT
OPERATIONS- SO WITH THAT WE
WILL- TURN IT BACK OUT TO YOU
OR TURNED OVER TO ALEJO. L. A.
OVERHEAD. I NEED ONLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE HAVE FOUR RECOMMENDATIONS
RELATED TO THE BUREAU OF
FORENSIC SERVICES OF THESE ARE
ITEMS THREE AND FOUR ON YOUR
AGENDA WILL START WITH- ITEM
FOR WHICH IS THE BACK FELT- WE
RECOMMENDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
BACKFILL BUT ONLY FOR TWO YEARS
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THERE
ARE SUFFICIENT REVENUES AND THE
FINGERPRINT FEES ACCOUNT WHICH
IS USED WHICH IS BEING USED TO
BACKFILL- A PORTION OF THE
FUNDS THAT ARE THAT ARE BEING
PROVIDED TO THE BUREAU- AND
THIS IS BECAUSE THE REVENUES
HAVE BEEN LOWER. THAN IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
THE FUNDS COULD BECOME
INSOLVENT IN A COUPLE YEARS OF
THE REVENUES DO NOT
SUFFICIENTLY INCREASE ON THIS
TWO YEARS WOULD ALSO PROVIDE.
THE BUREAU WITH FUNDING WALL
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS FOR NEW
FUNDING FRAMEWORK ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED. SO MY LOOK AT OUR
SECOND RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IS TO IMPLEMENT A
NEW FUNDING FRAMEWORK- TO
REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PARTIALLY SUPPORT THE BUREAU OF
FORENSIC SERVICES BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. AND THIS IS BECAUSE OF
THE SUBSTANTIAL BENEFIT THAT
CERTAIN LOCAL AGENCIES AND
FORTY SIX COUNTIES ARE
RECEIVING FROM THE BUREAU-
WHICH IS PROVIDING SERVICES TO
THOSE LOCAL AGENCIES AT NO
CHARGE. AND SO REQUIRING THAT
LOCAL AGENCIES CONTRIBUTE TO
PAY A PORTION. OF THE COST TO
SUPPORT THE BUREAU COULD
PROVIDE GREATER INCENTIVE FOR
THEM TO PRIORITIZE THE WORK
THAT IS BEING SUBMITTED TO DOJ
AND REDUCE THE AN ONGOING NEED
FOR GENERAL FUND SUPPORT- SO
CURRENTLY THE SUBMISSIONS ARE
REALLY ONLY LIMITED BY DOJ'S
OVERALL CAPACITY AND THE LEVEL
OF FUNDING THAT THE STATE
PROVIDES TO THE SUPPORT THE
BUREAU. WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THOSE TWELVE COUNTIES IN EIGHT
CITIES THAT ARE OPERATING THEIR
OWN LABS ARE CURRENTLY SERVE
PRIORITIZING. THEIR WORKLOAD.
OUR THIRD RECOMMENDATION- YOU
KNOW TO HELP WITH THIS FUNDING
FOR MARK IS THAT WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE
DOJ DEVELOP AND REPORT ON A
PLAN NO LATER THAN OCTOBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. FOR
CALCULATING EACH LOCAL AGENCIES
AND SERVICE PROVIDES DOJ WITH
THE FLEXIBILITY TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. TO DETERMINE WHAT
THE SPECIFICS OF THAT FUNDING
FROM WORK WOULD LOOK LIKE SO
SHOULD THERE BE A DIFFERENCE IN
SHARE BASED ON THE TYPE OF
FORENSIC SERVICE. BEING USED
THE SPEED OF THE SERVICE OR THE
TECH- OR SIZE OF THE AGENCY. I
IN LINE IS THAT IT REALLY ITEMS
OF YOURS ON THE CONSOLE.
FACILITY WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL UNTIL THE NEW FUNDING
FRAMEWORK IS IMPLEMENTED. AND
THIS IS BECAUSE THE NEW FUNDING
FROM WORK WOULD PROVIDE GREATER
INCENTIVE FOR- ENTITIES TO FIND
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY OF
OBTAINING LABORATORY SERVICES
AND THAT COULD CHANGE THE NEED.
FOR THE FACILITY AND IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU. COMMENTS BY
MAY. TEN WEBER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YES QUITE SOME PICTURES
SO SPECIFICALLY ON THE DNA
IDENTIFICATION AND FIND THE
BACK FELL OBVIOUSLY WE PUT THAT
COVERS BUDGET INCLUDES ON GOING
FUNDING I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT IS AN ONGOING
ISSUE WE PUT IN ONE TIME
FUNDING THE LAST FEW YEARS AND
ALSO ALTHOUGH THAT FUNDING IS
ON GOING IT WILL IT'LL BE
ADJUSTED EACH YEAR THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS BASED ON ACTUAL
REVENUES EXPENDITURES. AND THEN
JUST ONE COMMENT ON HOW ITS
RECOMMENDATION TO POTENTIALLY
HAVE COUNTIES PAY SOME PORTION
OF YOUR FORENSIC SERVICES COSTS
I THINK WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT- BECAUSE THE WORD
ABOUT SMALLER COUNTY THAT THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY FOR SOME
SERVICES THEY MAY HAVE TO-
UNFORTUNATE PRIORITIZED BY
GIVING CERTAIN DNA INFORMATION
AND- YOU MAY BE AT THAT PROCESS
THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN ISSUE
NUMBER THREE. I'M SURE WE HAVE
A VERY MILLER AVAILABLE-
THERE'S- INTEREST IN HEARING
HOW THE NEW MODEL COULD IMPACT
LOCALS. I'M GONNA I'M GONNA
HOLD OFF ON THAT TO FOR THE
SAKE OF TIME. I REMEMBER
SEVENTY QUESTIONS. ON THIS
ISSUE LOW- WE HAVE HEARD A
LITTLE BIT IN MY OFFICE ABOUT
THE DNA LAB CONSOLIDATION- AND
THERE'S BEEN A DISCUSSION ABOUT
TO IS CONSOLIDATING THE
SACRAMENTO AREA LABS AND IF WE
WERE TO DO THAT SMALLER SCALE
DO WE KNOW HOW MUCH THAT WOULD
COST- AND IS THE DOJ OPEN TO
CONSIDERING ONLY CONSOLIDATING
THE SACRAMENTO AREA LABS. YOU
WANT TO HANDLE THAT. YES THANK
YOU- MANAGER THIS IS VERY
MILLER WITH THE GIRLFRIEND SIX
SERVICES IN THE DIVISION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. B. THAT PROPOSAL
HAS BEEN LOOKED AT OR WHETHER
OR NOT WE WOULD JUST NEED TO
CONSOLIDATE JUST SACRAMENTO IN
RICHMOND BUT IT'S CONTRARY TO
THE GOAL OF. ACTUALLY SAVING
MONEY IN BEING IN THE BAY AREA
WITH THE RICHMOND LABORATORY
THAT IS A VERY EXPENSIVE LEAST
FOR THE BUREAU AND WE DON'T
HAVE THE MOST COMPETITIVE
SALARY IN THE STATE FOR THE
CRIMINALIST FORENSIC SCIENTISTS
THAT WE EMPLOY THEIR- WE HAVE
FOUND THAT. THINGS ARE MOVING
TOWARDS A LOT OF THE SACRAMENTO
AREA. CANDIDATES IN THE SCHOOLS
APPLYING FOR THAT AREA BUT NOT
NECESSARILY TAKING JOBS BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE A COMPETITIVE
SALARY IN WE SPEND A LOT OF
MONEY IN THAT SO. THANK YOU
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
ON THIS ISSUE SO I'M GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE THANK YOU ALL
AND THEN WE WANT TO ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR I THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WILL PRESENT ON VARIOUS
BUDGET PROPOSALS TO IMPLEMENT
LET'S LOOK. LEGISLATION THE
PANEL MAY BE GETTING. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR CHRIS RYAN- CHIEF
OF THE DIVISION OF OPERATIONS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
I THANK YOU- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES EIGHT
LEGISLATIVE BCPS TO BEGIN THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE NEW
STATUTORY MANDATES REQUIREMENTS
ACROSS MANY DIVISIONS AT DOJ-
THE EIGHT PROPOSALS TOTAL
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND SEVENTY POSITIONS
OF THE EIGHTEEN MILLION
ASSOCIATED WITH LEGISLATIVE
BCPS APPROXIMATE THIRTEEN
MILLION IS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT. AB FIFTEEN OH SIX THE
POLICE USE OF FORCE BILL AND
WE'LL SPEND SOMETIME TALKING
ABOUT THAT TODAY ON THE OTHER
BILLS GENERALLY SPEAKING- OUR
WORK ASSESS STATED THAT WITH
THEM SUPPORT SPECIFIED FOR DOJ
TO SUPPORT SPECIFIED WORKING
GROUP'S- ALSO TO DEVELOP
REGULATIONS OR MAKE CERTAIN.
CHANGES TO OUR IT SYSTEMS- TO
BE COMPLIANT WITH THE NEW-
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS. WITH TO
AB FIFTY NO SIX- THIS WORKLOAD-
IT'S A NEW WORKLOAD FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS THAT
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT WORKLOAD AND
AS WE- INDICATED- IN THE
EIGHTIES LETTER TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY ON JANUARY
TWENTY SIX. WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT FOLKS WORKING
WITH DOJ IN THE MINISTRATION OF
THE LEGISLATURE ATTEMPT TO
IMPLEMENT THIS LEGISLATION- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS TO
SECURE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES AND
TIME CRITICAL NEED TO ESTABLISH
A THOROUGH. AND INDEPENDENT
PROCESS TO ADDRESS THE OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTING INCIDENTS ARE
SPECIFIED IN AB FIFTEEN A SIX.
ARE THE CURRENT PROPOSAL DOES
NOT INCLUDE WHAT DOJ HAS
ESTIMATED IS NEEDED TO FULLY
IMPLEMENT THE REQUIREMENTS OF
AB FIFTY A SIX. FOR EXAMPLE IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE RESOURCES FOR
POLICE PRACTICES DIVISION-
WHICH WILL BE REQUIRED TO BE UP
AND RUNNING BY JULY ONE. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. IN ADDITION- THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL ONLY PROVIDES
THREE TEAMS- ACROSS THE STATE
WHILE WE BELIEVE THAT FOUR
TEAMS- ARE WHAT'S NEEDED GIVEN
THE GEOGRAPHIC. SIZE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WHERE THESE
INCIDENTS- TYPICALLY HAPPEN
ACROSS THE STATE AND SO WE'RE
HOPING TO ADD AN ADDITIONAL
TEAM. THESE INVESTIGATIONS OF
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS
CONTAIN MANY ACTIVITIES AND
EACH ARE INCREDIBLY COMPLEX THE
DIVISION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
LIMITED EXPERIENCE IN
INVESTIGATING OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS OUR EXPERIENCE IS
LIMITED TO ONE REVIEW OF AN
INVESTIGATION. CONDUCTED BY A
LOCAL AGENCY AFTER THE CASE WAS
COMPLETED IN ADDITION DALY
INDEPENDENTLY CONDUCTED ONE
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING
INVESTIGATION IN A SMALL COUNTY
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN- I WE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT OUR MODEL OR
ESTIMATE. WAS BASED ON
APPROXIMATELY FORTY INCIDENTS-
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT WILL
REQUIRE THE INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE. AND THAT ARE
ESTIMATED NEED FOR THIS PROGRAM
ON THE WHOLE IS ABOUT TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS- RAMPING UP TO
THIRTY MILLION WHEN THE POLICE
PRACTICES DIVISION IS UP AND
RUNNING AS WELL- WE'RE OPEN TO-
I CAN GIVE YOU SOME INFORMATION
ON. HOW WE GOT THERE. WE FEEL
LIKE A- WE HAVE A GEOGRAPHIC
NEED- WE HAVE 20% OF USE OF
FORCE- CURRENT NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PROFIT LEVIN PERCENT
IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND 61%
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- SO OUR
MODEL THAT WE HAD. PRESENTED
DURING THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
I WAS A MODEL TO ADDRESS THE
STATEWIDE- INCIDENTS THAT WE'VE
BEEN SEEING OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS- ALL- WE HAVE EXPERTS- IF
THERE'S QUESTIONS- SO AT THIS
POINT ALL- I'LL TURN IT BACK TO
YOU. THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE APARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES TIM WEBER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I JUST
WANNA SAY THAT WOULD BE THE
FUNDING PROVIDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOWS DOJ TO
ESTABLISH INVESTIGATIVE PROGRAM
COLLECT DATA AND ACTUAL
WORKLOAD IT'S MIDDLE CLASS THE
FUTURE- IF NECESSARY. I DON'T
BUDGET INCLUDES. FUNDING FOR
THREE TEAMS ONE EACH AT CENTRAL
SOUTHERN. AND NORTHERN REGION.
I WOULD HAVE TO I HAVE TO
PROTECT ENTIRE STATES. AND
WE'RE GOING TO WORK IN THE PART
OF JUSTICE AS HE CAN- MEDICAL
WITH MINOR AND IF THESE
RESOURCES ARE NECESSARY AS MR
REID MENTIONED THE POLICE BACK
TO DIVISION FUNDING WAS
INCLUDED THIS POINT SO THE PARK
THAT'S WHAT TO COME BACK IN A
COUPLE YEARS SURPLUS FUNDING
AND AT THAT POINT TO GET UP TO
ME TO RE EVALUATE. THE PROGRESS
THAT THE BASKET TEAMS. THANK
YOU ALEJO. I NEED A WITH THE L.
A. O. WE HAVE NO CAN ON THESE
PROPOSALS THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER PRESENTERS WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THE FEDERAL. NUMBER
THE LAST ITEM MADAM CHAIR THE
LAST ITEM I THINK WE WERE
PLANNING TO COVER WAS THE BILL
RELATED TO SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REQUEST ONE POINT NINE MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND ONE MILLION IN
TWENTY TWO THIS IS A SYSTEM-
IT'S PART OF OUR- CHARGE TO
CONVENE A WORKING GROUP
NECESSARY TO SUBMIT A PLAN. FOR
THE REPLACEMENT OF THE JUVENILE
COURT AND PROBATION STATISTICAL
SYSTEM- SO WE DO HAVE MARC ST
PIERRE AVAILABLE IF THERE ARE
QUESTIONS- BUT THAT WAS JUST A
BRIEF UPDATE ON A CONVERSATION
THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING IN. IN
THIS BUDGET COMMITTEE THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS. THANK THANK
THANK YOU FOR THAT- MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS. IT I JUST WANT TO
CHECK ON THE- ON AB PITINO SIX
THE POLICE USE OF FORCE- THAT
DEFINITELY SHOULD BE A PRIORITY
OF THIS LEGISLATURE WENT
THROUGH QUITE A BIT TO GET THIS
LOG PLACE- IS PROBABLY GOING TO
BE THE- THE BENCHMARK FOR ANY
OTHER. FEDERAL LEVEL POLICE USE
OF FORCE OR IN ANY OTHER STATE
USING IT SO WHAT EVER.
RESOURCES WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT NOT ONLY THAT DOJ HAS
D. A. THE PERSONNEL TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN. BUT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
EFFECTIVE AND ABLE TO GET THEIR
JOB DONE SO I WOULD JUST ADD IN
THEIR ACCOUNTABILITY THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE ABLE TO
GET THIS THIS WORK DONE OF
QUICKLY. AND COMPETENTLY AND-
AND WHATEVER HELP YOU NEED TO
ENSURE THAT. THIS GETS DONE-
YOU CAN CALL MY OFFICE. THANK
YOU SELLER WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR THAT
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE I DO APPRECIATE
EVERYONE BEING SO- TO THINK
THAT THEIR COMMENTS. WE'LL HAVE
THE PANEL BEGAN WE'RE GONNA BE
DISCUSSING ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. A GOOD EVENING
CARE SEEING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JEFF NEDELMAN WITH%
THAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
I'M GOING TO PRESENT A BRIEF
OVERVIEW AT THE REQUEST TO
PROVIDE FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. THAT SUPPORTS
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENTS.
ASIAN MARKETS ARE ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURING THE CONTINUED CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM SUCCEED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL A RECENT CHANGES
INCLUDING AB NINETEEN FIFTY M.
S. B. TWENTY THREE WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT THE
WORKLOAD AND RESPONSIBILITY. OF
COUNTY PROBATION APARTMENTS. WE
HAVE THE FUNDS TO SERVICE START
UP RESOURCES TO COUNTIES. ASIAN
AGENCIES COMPLEX WE SPEND IN
THE MATTER MOST APPROPRIATE TO
THEIR POPULATIONS THE CURRENT
MEETING GAPS FOR SERVICES MAY
BE DIFFERENT IN EACH COUNTY.
FOR EXAMPLE SOME COUNTIES MAYBE
RESOURCES AND YOU CANNOT
SERVICES TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
APPROPRIATE PLACEMENTS FOR YOU
EQUITEC CONFIDENCE IN. OTHER
COUNTIES MAY PROACTIVELY YET
CASTING THEIR DAHLE POPULATION-
AND PROBATION CASES SO THAT
THEY CAN CONNECT INDIVIDUALS TO
CASE PLANS QUICKER. OTHERS MAY
WANT TO ENHANCE OR EXPAND THEIR
EXISTING CONTRACTS WITH
COMMUNITY SERVICE PROVIDERS.
ALEX WITT LOADED. LOW TOLD YOU
CAN OUR POPULATIONS OR WITH FEW
WORDS WITH SPECIALIZED NEEDS
SUCH AS SEX OFFENDER OR
INTENSIVE BEHAVIORAL TREATMENT
MAY ALSO USE THIS FUNDING TO
ESTABLISH REGIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS. WITH NEIGHBORING
COUNTIES TO ENSURE AND. IT'S
CHEAP EFFICIENCIES THROUGH
SCALE. HAS TO BE OKAY OF FUNDS.
WE ESTIMATED DON'T PROBATION.
AND ACT YOU COURT WORK BUT BY
LOOKING THE PAST FIVE YEARS OF
COUNTY DATA. PRETTY AVERAGE
CORE IT'LL PROBATION POCKET AND
THEN IF YOU CAN HELP ME HOW IN
THE OF JUDGE SYSTEM WITHIN. THE
CALIFORNIA PART OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION.
ADMINISTRATION METHODOLOGY FOR
COUNTY ALLOCATION WE BOTH
JUVENILE. AND ADULT. OCCUPATION
DATA. WE BELIEVE THAT USING
THIS MIX OF THE DEBATE OUT
ADULT PROBATION. TO HIS
APPROACH. BECAUSE RECKITT THE
WORKLOADS WITH SUPPORTING THE
VARIOUS POPULATIONS SERVED BY
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENTS.
ALTHOUGH THE USE OF HISTORICAL
DATA AND FORMS THAT LOCATION
INTENT IS TO PROVIDE PROVISION
APARTMENTS WITH THE FLEXIBILITY
TO USE THESE FUNDS TO MEET THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF THEIR
INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES. THAT ARE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE L. A- DO YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING. THANK YOU
RECREATIONAL ARE OVER THE L. A.
O. BASED ON THE INFORMATION
THAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
PROVIDED PREVIOUSLY THE
PROPOSAL KATHY PROMISED ON. THE
IDEA THAT KIND OF A BASIC
MARKETS LOTS OF THE RESOURCE AS
WELL RECENT CHANGES HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED- RELATED TO THE
ISSUES THAT ARE GOING TO JUST
MENTION SOMEONE THAT JUVENILE
JUSTICE SIDE. WAITED AS THE
EIGHT TWENTY THREE WHICH IS A
REAL LIFE WE HAVE A LINE IN OF
THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE DJJ. AND MAYBE NINETEEN
FIFTY WHICH THE REDUCTION IN
PROBATION TERMS. HOWEVER WE
HAVE FOUND THAT. THAT THEY JUST
MAKE HAS NOT BEEN DONE- WHY DO
WE NEED ADDITIONAL FOR THE
PURPOSE FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU JEFF
ON- THAT MONEY TO GO TO THE
INTENT TO SOME OF SB TWENTY.
BASED ON PAST OF THE DAY J.
ROBERT THAT HAS NOT DEMONSTRATE
ARE INTO SIX THE LOCAL FUNDING
FOR THE ALLOCATION PLAN ABOUT
WHAT THE BETWEEN THREE
ANALYTICAL THAT THAT'S WHAT
ALLOCATED BY THE MINISTRY HAS
PROPOSED FOR THIS NEW FUNDING
IT'S BASEBALL ONE COMPONENT OF
THE FUNDING FORMULA THAT WAS
USED IN SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE.
BUT YOU CAN ALL COMPONENTS. AND
THEN ADDED TO THAT THAT THE
QUESTION THIS FUNDING THE NEW
DOES NOT. TOPICAL WHAT THE
TRUCK THIS THAT SHE- ON THAT I
DON'T. SIDE SB NINETY FIFTH
TRACK DECREASED RATE WORKER
BECAUSE THAT WOULD. PROBATION
AT STILL FROM REESE FOR
PROBATION DEPARTMENT. SO NOT
CLEAR WHY JUST FUNDING WOULD BE
NEEDED THAT PURPOSE. IT IS TO
THE PROPOSAL GOES TO LACK ANY
OF ACCOUNT. MECHANISM THAT
STATE THAT DOES NOT BECOME A
BUILDING THAT YOUR SYSTEM IS
NECESSARY BECAUSE THE BANKING
DEPARTMENT SEVEN SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTED PASSED PROGRAMS
SUCH AS SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
WHICH IS THE GRANT PROGRAM
DEMOCRATS FUNDING TO. GO
TOWARDS EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES AND PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS TOOK. PART ON HOW
THE NEW STUFF. THESE ACCOUNTS
MECHANISMS MECHANISM THAT BUILT
INTO SB THREE. SB SIX EIGHT.
LIKE BIG TO THE THAT AND SO ON
WHY. SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT WOULD
USED AS A JUSTIFICATION FOR WHY
NO ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISMS
ARE NOT YET BUT THE CITY
PROPOSAL. ADMINISTRATION ALSO
INDICATED THAT IT THINKS WORK
REQUIREMENTS SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
AND SB COULDN'T VERY WOULD
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT TRANSPARENCY
THE PROPOSAL IT'S YEARS. FROM
NOT THE SUBJECTS THAT
REQUIREMENTS OF I DON'T. SB SIX
SEVEN EIGHT PROGRAM OR THE S.
B. TWENTY THREE POINT PROGRAMS.
EXPLORATIVE THAT USE THE
PROPOSED FUNDING ANY WAY THEY
SEE FIT. NOT JUST FOR THE
PURPOSES ARE OUTLINED IN THESE
PROGRAMS. YEAH IT'S THE SIX
SEVEN USD EIGHT POINT THIRTY.
THE REPORT ON THE BUT I HAVE A
BUILDING THAT THIS THE REPORT
ON THESE PROGRAMS. I DON'T
REALLY HAVE ANY BEARING ON
PROVIDED TRANSPARENCIES BUT THE
USE OF THE PROPOSED FUNDING
BECAUSE RATED PARTS CONTINUES
THE FUNDING AND SOMEONE THAT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY FALL UNDER
THOSE REPORT REQUIREMENTS. DUE
TO LACK OF JESSICA PROVIDED FOR
THE PROPOSAL BY THE NUTRITION
AS WELL AS ANY SORT OF
ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISM BUILT
INTO THE PROPOSAL WE WERE
CHECKED. THANK YOU. BUT THANK
YOU THE ARMY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CAN EXPLAIN TO ME. YOUR
RATIONALE- FIRST SAME THAT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
OTHER FUNDING STREAMS ARE
SUFFICIENT TO PROVIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THIS
PROPOSED BUDGET IT FEELS LIKE
YOU'RE ASKING THIS COMMITTEE
NOT TO DO THEIR JOB- WHICH IS
PART OF WHAT WE DO IS PROVIDE.
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR SPENDING.
THANK YOU MEDICARE- EXCELLENT
QUESTION JUST EIGHT OF THEM
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AGAIN. WHEN WE- CREATED THE
PROPOSAL WE BELIEVE THE VARIOUS
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
AND A JCPS S. B. MISTER RYAN
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
RECENTLY MENTIONED AS PART OF
BEING- INVOLVED WITH SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE AND THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THERE WOULD BE
SUFFICIENT. BUT WE ARE HAPPY
AND SUPPORTIVE OF TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SO WE WOULD
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON. I'M GOING
FORWARD WITH. LOOKING INTO
ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THIS BUT WHAT
FUNDING. THANK YOU WILL
DEFINITELY TAKE YOU UP ON THAT
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS. I JUST
WANTED TO BE INCLUDED IN THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE- TO GIVE A
BRIEFING TO MY STAFF AND TO ME.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE THIS IS-
VERY IMPORTANT FOR ME SO IF YOU
IF YOU GET ME UP TO SPEED
BEFORE I MAKE A DECISION. I
WOULD BE GREAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I STILL WORRY AND I
BROUGHT THIS UP LAST YEAR. THAT
WHAT WE'VE DONE OR ARE ON A
PATH TO DO IS JUST RELYING
JUVENILE JUSTICE OUT TO THE
COUNTIES IN PROVIDE OF A BUNCH
OF MONEY AND SAY. HAVE ADDED
AND THAT WOULD BE A HUGE
MISTAKE TO DO YOU CAN LOOK AT
SOME OF THE WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE IN LA RIGHT NOW. THAT'S
ACTUALLY FOCUSING ON CREATING
ITS OWN DEPARTMENT OF YOU
SERVICES IN IN TRYING TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THAT THE CONNECTIONS
ARE BEING MADE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THOSE USED TO HELP
THEM WITH THE DECISIONS THAT
THEY MADE. GET THEM DRESSED
RECIDIVISM PROBLEM TO GET THEM
BACK INTO INTO SOCIETY AND IN A
MUCH STRONGER WAY. AND THAT'S
WHAT I HAVE HOPE WE ARE ON THE
PATH TO DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE SHIFT AWAY FROM CORRECTIONS
AND INTO HUMAN SERVICES. IS I
THINK A VERY GOOD STEP BUT
WITHOUT A ROBUST STATEWIDE PLAN
SETTING APPROPRIATE STANDARDS.
HOLDING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
ACCOUNTABLE. AND YES PROVIDING
FUNDING OUT TO THE COUNTIES TO
MEET. THEIR ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING AT THE STATE LEVEL AND
THAT IS PROVIDING COMPREHENSIVE
CONSISTENT SERVICES TO KIDS
ACROSS THE BOARD. THAT'S REALLY
THE PATH THAT THAT WE SHOULD BE
OUT SO IT'S HARD FOR TOOK TO BE
A LOOK AT THIS CHUNK OF MONEY
GOING OUT TO COUNTIES. KNOWING
WHETHER IT'S ENOUGH KNOWING
WHETHER IT'S APPROPRIATE
KNOWING THAT WHAT THE ULTIMATE
GOALS OF THIS REALIGNMENT.
NEEDS TO BE IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
BETTER OUTCOMES FOR KIDS IN THE
END WHAT I WANNA MAKE SURE OF
IS THAT REGARDLESS OF THE
COUNTY THAT HE A CHILD IS IN
WHETHER IN DEPENDENCY OR
DELINQUENCY. THAT THEY'RE
GETTING AN APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
SERVICES AND HELP TO SOLVE THE
ISSUES THAT THEY FACE SO IT'S-
WHAT SORT OF THE AGGREGATE. WAY
THAT THIS IS COMING. IT'S A
LITTLE HARD TO KNOW WHAT THE
TRACK IS THAT IF WE'RE NOT
DILIGENT AND NOT PAYING
ATTENTION. THAN WHAT WE'VE JUST
DONE IS A REALIGNMENT AT TO THE
COUNTIES AND THE STATE'S
WASHING. THEIR HANDS OF IT AND
THAT WOULD BE A REAL TRAGEDY
BECAUSE THEN WE'RE GOING TO SEE
OUTCOMES SIGNIFICANTLY
DIFFERENT OVER TIME. DEPENDING
WHERE A CHILD IS AND THAT IS
THAT IS SOMETHING WE ABSOLUTELY
HAVE TO AVOID BECAUSE IF THAT
HAPPENS THEN. THIS WHOLE
EXERCISE WILL BENEFIT. THANK
YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS OF MR
STUNNING THING THAT SETS US UP
NICELY FOR OUR NEXT AND FINAL
ITEM ON THE HEARING. I WILL BE
CARRYING ON THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY COMMUNITY
RESTORATION AND THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. AND
WE'LL HAVE OUR PANEL SPEAK IN
THE ORDER IN WHICH IS LISTED IN
THE AGENDA YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
WELCH I AM THE DEPUTY SECRETARY
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AT THE
DEPARTMENT. AT THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY AND I AM
HERE TO TALK ABOUT OUR PROPOSAL
TO ESTABLISH THE OFFICE OF
USING COMMUNITY RESTORATION
WE'RE REQUESTING RESOURCES
THREE POINT FOUR MILLION IN
BUDGET YEAR AND THREE POINT ONE
MILLION I'M GOING TO SUPPORT.
NINETEEN STAFF AND CONTRACTS
FOR SPECIALTY SERVICES SUCH AS
EVALUATION EFFORTS. YOUR YOUR
AGENDA FOR THE MEETING TODAY
PROVIDED A VERY GOOD OVERVIEW
OF THE VARIOUS DIFFERENT DUTIES
AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE
OFFICE. SO BECAUSE IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I WILL NOT
REVIEW THEM IN DETAIL HERE BUT
I DO WANT TO RESPOND TO SOME OF
THE POINTS THAT WERE MADE. IN
THAT DOCUMENT. SB EIGHT TWO
THREE BEGINS THE PROCESS OF
CLOSING. THE DIVISION OF YOUTH
JUSTICE AND REALIGNING THAT
POPULATION TO THE COUNTY'S
JUSTICE WHAT WAS DISCUSSED- SO
THAT YOU CAN REMAIN CLOSE TO
HOME. THE STATUTE ALSO
ESTABLISHES THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION OR
THE O. Y. C. R. AT THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY- THE- Y. C. R.
WILL HELP TO ENSURE THE LONG
TERM AND SUSTAINED SUCCESS OF
TRANSITIONING RELYING USED TO
COUNTY BASED CUSTODY. CUSTODY
PROGRAMS AND SUPERVISION
CONSISTENT WITH THE PROJECT
HINGED. UPON US OF REFORMS.
THANK AGREE TO THE- BY THE ARE
TO HELP FILL. TO FILL THE
REHABILITATIVE PURPOSE OF THE
STATE'S JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
YOUR TRAUMA INFORMED AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
PROGRAMS. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL MEETS THIS OBJECTIVE
SPECIFICALLY THE- I SEE ARE
WILL BE FOCUSED ON IMPROVING
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AS
A WHOLE. TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF
BEST PRACTICES POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WILL LEAD
TO IMPROVED OUTCOMES AND
INTEGRATED PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES TO BEST SUPPORT ALL
JUSTICE SYSTEM INVOLVED YOUTH.
WE WILL ACHIEVE THIS BY
LEVERAGING THE EXPERTISE OF OUR
LEADERSHIP OUR STAFF AND
COORDINATING WITH INITIATIVES
THAT ARE UNDERWAY IN OUR
VARIOUS DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS
ACROSS START AGENCY. THE BCP WE
ARE DISCUSSING. REFLECTS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE- I SEE OURS SPECIFIC
OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS ARE FOCUSED
ON THE REAL LINE POPULATION IT
IS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
POSITION THAT THE- I SEE OUR
ARMS BUT PERSON WILL FOCUS ON
THE PORTION OF THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE POPULATION THAT WAS
REALIGNED TO THE COUNTIES. IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THIS INCLUDES
ALL. OF THE. SEVEN SEVEN B.
OFFENSE CERTAIN. YOU IRKS YOU
ME YOU CERTAIN OFFENSE AS WELL
AS HIGHER NEEDS YOU. THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN SENT TO DJJ PRIOR TO
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE O. Y. C.
R. WILL FOCUS SERVICES ON THESE
UNITS BECAUSE THEY ARE THE MOST
LIKELY TO BE PLACED IN JUVENILE
JUSTICE FACILITIES. AND THEY
ARE OFTEN TIMES THE MOST IN
NEED OF THE MOST INTENSIVE
TREATMENT AND PROGRAMMING.
FRANKLY AND THAT. THESE ARE
USED WITH A VERY HIGH NEEDS AND
VERY HIGH RISK. AND FOCUSING ON
THIS POPULATION. REALLY
SUPPORTS ACHIEVING THE GOALS OF
SB EIGHTEEN THREE. ALL UNITS
ARE IMPORTANT- I BELIEVE THAT
DEEP IN MY HEART IS WHY I DO
THIS WORK- SHOULD THE OFFICE
RECEIVED ANY KIND OF A
COMPLAINT OUTSIDE THE SCOPE.
SPECIFICALLY DISCUSSED JUST NOW
ABOUT THE ARMS PERSONS
RESPONSIBILITIES. IT IS THE
ROLE OF THE LIKE THE ART
DIRECTED TO THE RIGHT PLACE AND
DOING THAT BY. CONVERSING WITH
OUR COUNCIL AND WORKING WITH
OUR OTHER DEPARTMENTS THIS IS A
PART THIS IS PART OF THE REASON
WHY HAVING THE- YC ARCHEAN HHS
IS SO IMPORTANT WE HAVE
CONNECTIONS TO OUR DEPARTMENTS.
THOSE ARE CONNECTIONS TO CHILD
WELFARE MENTAL HEALTHAND
HEALTH CARE SERVICES- I WOULD
ALSO ADD. THE HHS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE VERY FOCUSED
ON SUPPORTING THESE YOU GET THE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THEY NEED
DURING THIS TRANSITION. THEY
HAD SIGNIFICANT NEEDS AND
WARRANT AS FOCUSING ON THEM AT
THIS CRITICAL POINT IN TIME. WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE USE
THAT ARE REALIGNED AND THAT THE
USE THAT WOULD HAVE GONE TO DJJ
CAN STAY IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
GET THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED
THE SUPERVISION THAT THEY NEED.
AND THE CARE THAT THEY NEED SO
THAT THEY DO NOT GRADUATE A AND
FALL DEEPER INTO THE ADULT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
BRIEFLY I JUST WANTED TO
PROVIDE YOU UPDATES OF WHERE WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS. OF THE
CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL HAS
ESTABLISHED THE COMMITTEE THAT
IS REQUIRED TO BE ESTABLISHED
TO WORK DIRECTLY WITH THE
OFFICE THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE. AND BE STAFFED BY HHS
IN ORDER TO ADVISE AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO
POLICIES PROGRAMMES APPROACHES.
THAT IMPROVE USE OUTCOMES. SHE
IS ATTENTION AND REDUCE
RECIDIVISM FOR REALIGNED YOU WE
HAVE BEGUN TO MEET- OF OUR
FIRST MEETING WAS LAST MONTH-
COUNTIES WILL RECEIVE JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT GRANT
FUNDS. BY FILING A PLAN WITH
THE OFFICE NO LATER THAN
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THE O. Y. C. R. IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR REVIEWING THESE PLANS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY INCLUDE ALL
STATUTORILY REQUIRED ELEMENTS.
IF THE PLAN DOES NOT IT CAN BE
RETURNED TO THE COUNTY- AND IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE CONTINUED
FUNDING. THE COUNTY WILL HAVE
TO SUBMIT A PLAN. NO LATER THAN
MAY FIRST OF EACH YEAR. ALSO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS A
ROLE TO PLAY. IN DEVELOPING A
PLAN TO MODERNIZE THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE DATABASE AND REPORTING
SYSTEM BY JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THE NEW PLAN WILL
INCLUDE DATA AND OUTCOME
MEASURES NEEDED TO PRODUCE
RECIDIVISM REPORTS AND TO
ARGUMENT CASELOAD AND PLACEMENT
CHANGES DUE TO THE REALIGNMENT
OF DJJ TO THE COUNTIES. WE WILL
ALSO USE THAT THE- I SEE ARE.
THESE ELEMENTS TO ASSESS COUNTY
PLANS FOR COMPLETENESS IN
ADDITION. TO DEVELOPING
EVALUATION TOOLS- INCLUDES I
JUST TO SAY THE HOUSING THE- I
SEE ARE AT HHS WILL FACILITATE
LEVERAGING THE EXPERTISE OF OUR
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS- WHO ARE
COMMITTED TO IMPROVING
CHILDREN'S OUTCOMES IN LIFE'S
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES. AND SPECIAL OFFICES
LIKE THE OFFICE OF THE SURGEON
GENERAL ALL OF THESE CAN
SUPPORT THE- I SEE IT- I SEE
ARE IN ITS EFFORTS TO IDENTIFY
BEST PRACTICES. WE ENVISION
SIGNIFICANT INTERACTION BETWEEN
A Y. C. R. AND THESE
DEPARTMENTS TO WRITE STRONG AND
EFFECTIVE CONNECTIONS TO LOCAL
IMPLEMENTERS. WHO IT WAS BONTA
FOR SERVING THESE YOUTH IN
THEIR COMMUNITY AND TO BRING
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. SO WITH THAT I
CAN TAKE ACTION- WE ALSO- I
KNOW WITH OTHER PANELISTS HERE
AS WELL. THANK YOU MISS WORKING
FROM MY OTHER PANELISTS BEFORE
WE OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS.
SHE'S STICKING AROUND. NEXT
PANELIST. YES HI GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE MY NAME IS FRANKIE
BECAUSE MINE. I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE YOUTH JUSTICE INITIATIVE
AT THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUR
LONG SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF.
THE LEGISLATURE IN XP TWENTY
THREE. WELL LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AND THE GULF
OF UNDERSTANDING TO LAW SENATE
BILL EIGHT TWENTY THREE. PER
CENT TO MOTIONS THE CLOSURE OF
DJJ THEREBY TRANSFERRING THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SERVING ALL
YOUTH AND CALIFORNIA'S JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM TO THE COUNTIES.
PROVIDING SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
TO COUNTIES TO CARRY OUT THIS
PLAN. RECOGNIZING THE
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES AS
WELL AS THE NEED FOR OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR COUNTIES
USE OF STATE FUNDING AND FOR
THE TREATMENT OF ALL
INCARCERATED YOUTH. SENATE BILL
EIGHT TWENTY THREE ALSO
ESTABLISHED THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
YOU THE COMMUNITY RESTORATION
OR ALL I SEE ARE. TO OVERSEE
THE ENTIRE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM ACROSS THE FIFTY POUNDS.
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY THREE
CLEARLY OUTLINES THE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE O. Y.
C. R. TO INCLUDE STATE
OVERSIGHT OF ALL JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEMS ACROSS THE
FIFTY POUNDS. ADMINISTRATION OF
THE REALIGNMENT BLOCK GRANT
FUNDING AND EVENTUALLY ALL OF
THE STATE'S JUVENILE JUSTICE
GRANT PROGRAMS. DATA COLLECTION
AND REPORTING ON OUTCOMES FOR
ALL YOUTH IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. IDENTIFYING
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS TO BEST
SUPPORT ALL YOUTH IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
IDENTIFYING AND DISSEMINATING
BEST PRACTICES AGAIN FOR ALL
YOU IN THE YOUTH IN HE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
COUNTIES TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
ALL YOUTH IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND TO
ESTABLISH AN OMBUDSPERSON TO
INVESTIGATE COMPLAINTS FROM ALL
INCARCERATED YOUTH THEIR
FAMILIES STAFF AND OTHERS ABOUT
THE HARMFUL CONDITIONS
PRACTICES AND VIOLATIONS OF LAW
IN LOCAL FACILITIES. IN EXPECT.
INEXPLICABLY THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION NOW SEEKS TO
DEPART FROM THE STATE LAW. FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S OWN COMMITMENT
TO MOVE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
JUSTICE SYSTEM TOWARDS A HEALTH
BASED MODEL IMPORTANT WAYS.
FIRST THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION THE TRADITION OF
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY THREE
SEVERELY LIMITED SCOPE OF THE
L. Y. C. R. IN WHICH MANY OF
ITS CRITICAL RESPONSIBILITIES.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO DEVELOP
AND EXPAND LOCAL DIVERSION
OPPORTUNITIES AND TO IDENTIFY
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
IMPROVED OUTCOMES AND
INTEGRATED PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES TO BEST SUPPORT ALL
DELINQUENT YOUTH. ALSO THE
GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION'S
INTERPRETATION OF AB SB TWENTY
THREE DRAMATICALLY LIMITS THE
SCOPE OF. THE OUTLETS PERSON'S
ROLE AMHERST ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING. ITS PROTECTION. TO
ONLY WITH. EFFECTS OR USEFUL
OTHER WOULD HAVE INCARCERATED
DJJ PRIOR TO THOUSAND SEVEN.
HOWEVER STATE LAW IT'S CLEAR
THAT ALL YOUTH IN JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM FACILITIES WILL
BE PROVIDED WITH THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE
OMBUDSPERSON. THE MINISTRATIONS
OF ROHINGYAS INTERPRETATION OF
CLEARLY DEFINED LAW IF
IMPLEMENTED WOULD BE ILLEGAL
AND WOULD LIKELY RESULT IN
MISUSE OF STATE FUNDS. THE
MALTREATMENT OF VULNERABLE
COURSE FIFTIETH AND COSTLY
EDUCATION TO CORRECT ANY
DEFICIENCIES OR ABUSES THAT
OCCUR I DON'T LOCAL PRACTICES
THAT RESULT FROM A LACK OF
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
EVEN MORE CONCERNING IS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUEST ONLY
NINETEEN PERMANENT POSITIONS
AND METER THREE POINT. IN THE
DOCK- THE. GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION. TWENTY ONE POINT IN
EVERYTHING RECORD TWO THOUSAND
OPERATE DEAL C. R. WHETHER A
RESULT OF THE MESSENGER OF
CLEARLY DEFINED LAW OR AN
ATTEMPT TO UNDERMINE THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO OVERSEE
SUPPORT AND HOLD ACCOUNTABLE
COUNTY SYSTEMS THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION'S NARROW
INTERPRETATION AND PROPOSED
UNDER RESOURCING OF LIFE WE ARE
MUST BE CORRECTED. I URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAINTAIN THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO PROVIDING
MEANINGFUL OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR COUNTIES
PRACTICES AND SUPPORT THE
IMPROVEMENT OF THE ENTIRE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
ENSURE THE WELL BEING OF ALL OF
YOUR YOUNG PEOPLE IN IN THAT
SYSTEM- AND FULLY RESOURCE IN
ALL I SEE ARE. TO CARRY OUT ALL
OF ITS DUTIES THANK YOU. NEXT
HOLLISTER. THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS DOMINIQUE
NANA DIRECTOR OF YOUTH JUSTICE
POLICY AT THE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA I TRULY
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
ANALYSIS OF THIS BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL AND ONE THAT ITS
WHOLLY INSUFFICIENT THE
DRAMATIC UNDER ESTIMATE IN
STAFFING AND FUNDING APPEARS TO
BE THE RESULT OF TWO THINGS A
WRONG INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW
REGARDING- I SEE OUR SCOPE AS
MR BECAUSE MINE EXPLAINED. AS
WELL AS A FUNDAMENTAL
MISUNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT
WILL TAKE FOR- I SEE ARTS
FULFILL ITS DUTIES WITH
FIDELITY TO ITS MISSION. THIS
PROPOSAL CREATES A SHELL OF AN
AGENCY. IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE
HOW THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD. HAS NEARLY FIVE TIMES.
FIVE TIMES THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING PROPOSED FOR- I SEE
ARE. AN AGENCY RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE SAFETY AND TREATMENT OF
THOUSANDS OF OUR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH. I'D LIKE TO GIVE THREE
EXAMPLES OF HOW GROSSLY
MISGUIDED THIS PROPOSAL IS.
FIRST WILL NEED TO STAFF ARE
ASSIGNED TO RECEIVE INVESTIGATE
AND RESOLVE CONCERNS FROM
INCARCERATED YOUTH THEIR
FAMILIES AND STAFF ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. FOR PERSPECTIVE IN
TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN AT
MORE THAN SIXTEEN THOUSAND YOU
WERE SECURELY DETAINED INSIDE
NINETY FACILITIES STAFF BY
THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYEES THAT'S
TO STAFF TO ENSURE ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE ARE SAFE AND SUPPORTED.
SECOND THERE'S ONLY ONE DATA
SPECIALIST TWO RESEARCH AND
ANALYZE PROGRAM OUTCOMES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S ONE
DEDICATED STAFF MEMBER TO MEET
THE STATED GOAL OF HHS TO HAVE
RESEARCH AND DATA DRIVE ITS
ACTIONS AND DRIVE ITS POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND FINALLY- I
SEE ARE IS FUNDAMENTAL IN. THAT
THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FULLER IS THAT THE
STATE IS INVESTING PRODUCES
POSITIVE OUTCOMES. YET ONLY
THREE STAFF AND IT'S ABOUT
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
COUNTIES AND DEVELOPING THEIR
SPENDING PLANS. AND THAT'S
THREE STAFF TO THOROUGHLY
REVIEW AND THEN POSSIBLY
RETURNED FOR REVISION PLANS
FROM FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
THAT'S THE EQUIVALENT OF
NINETEEN COUNTIES AND PLANS PER
PERSON. AND WE'RE OVER THIS
PROPOSAL MADE IT NO MATTER GEN
OF THE STAFF NEEDED TO
IMMEDIATELY COLLABORATE WITH
THE BOARD OF STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS ON THE
ADMINISTRATION OF ALL JUVENILE
JUSTICE GRANTS AND THEN TO
EVENTUALLY TAKE FULL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ALL THESE
GRANTS BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
THE NUMBER OF PROPOSED STAFF
POSITIONS IS UNQUESTIONABLY TOO
LOW REGARDLESS OF HOW MUCH
SUPPORT THE STAFF WERE SUPPOSED
TO RECEIVE FROM THEIR TEAM
MEMBERS ARE FROM OTHER
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN HHS. AND
IT'S FAR BELOW COMPARABLE
OVERSIGHT AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND NATIONWIDE. MORE
STAFF IS FULLY MORE STAFF FULLY
DEDICATED TO DISTINCT WAYS YOUR
DUTIES AS SORT SORELY NEEDED.
AND MORE RESOURCES TO EQUIP THE
STAFF TO FULLY PERFORM THEIR
DUTIES IS ESSENTIAL TO ENSURE
THAT REALIGNMENT DOESN'T HARM
AND IN FACT ADVANCES THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF OUR CHILDREN
AND YOUNG PEOPLE. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE TIME TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY. THANK YOU DO WE
HAVE A COMMENTS FROM.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THIS IS
ALLISON YOUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
COMMENT AT THIS TIME I DO WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE IF YOU JUST AGENCY HAS
A CHANCE TO SPEAK AND HAPPY TO
ADD ON. AS WELL. GO AHEAD.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO REST WAIT
FOR QUESTIONS OR TO RESPOND TO
THE PANELISTS. THAT GROUP.
WEBER QUESTIONS. AFTER L. ALE.
MARK MORROW WITH THE L. A. O.
WE COULD NOT RAISE CONCERNS BUT
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL WE ARE
FROM THE HAPPY REYES MY ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON IT. I
WOULD HOPE THAT. YOU MOVED TO
THE GRANT FROM THE FCC TWO- I
SEE ARE WOULD BE OCCURRING IN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX
AN HOUR SOMEBODY STARTS AND
THEN BE A SIXTY. ACCORDING TO
PORTANTINO'S PROGRAM THAT NOT
CLEAR THAT WOULD ALL BE PLAY
OUT IT IS COULD NOT BACKYARD. I
WILL BE BACK TO- TO SPEAK TO
THEIR UP TO. MAKE IT. AT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT ARE. WE
START OFF WITH THE QUESTION
FOR. THE ADVOCATES ARE IN YOUR
COMMON STARTED TO TOUCH ON
THIS- ALREADY. WHAT IN YOUR
OPINION WHAT WOULD BE AN
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF RESOURCES
FOR THIS OFFICE. THIS IS
DOMINIQUE NOW AND I CAN TAKE
THAT QUESTION AND SO BASED ON
CONSULTATION WITH BUDGET
EXPERTS AND OUR RESEARCH INTO
COMPARABLE DEPARTMENTS ACROSS
THE STATE AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WE'VE ESTIMATED THAT A
MINIMUM TO KEEP SIX POSITIONS
ARE NEEDED. THAT COULD BREAK
THAT DOWN A LITTLE BIT MORE BUT
FIFTY SIX AT A MINIMUM. KK
BAKER HAD A BREAK THAT DOWN A
LITTLE MORE PRESS. SURE SO WE
COMPILED STAFFING ESTIMATES FOR
EACH OF THE PRIMARY FUNCTIONS
OF- I SEE OUR AND WE AND WE
GIVE A RANGE FOR FIVE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF STACKING
CONFIGURATIONS. SO WITH REGARD
TO THE OMBUDSMAN DUTIES I WE
HAVE ESTIMATED THIRTEEN
SEVENTEEN FULL TIME EMPLOYEES
AND THIS IS AFTER WE LOOKED AT
THE TEXAS JUVENILE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICE OF THE
INDEPENDENT ADVANCEMENT AND
THEY ALSO HAVE THIRTEEN FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES. AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE MOST RECENT DATA
FOR WHICH WE CAN MAKE
COMPARISONS WE CAN SEE THAT
THEY'RE ABOUT THE SAME NUMBER
OF YOUTH IN JUVENILE FACILITIES
IN TEXAS AS IN CALIFORNIA IN
FACT TEXAS HAS SLIGHTLY FEWER.
THAT'S BURKE IS WHAT'S YOUR
BIRTHDATE IT OUT CATION ABOUT
ACCIDENT. EGGMAN SPEAK PLEASE I
WAS BASED ON THE FLORIDA
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
THEY HAVE AN OFFICE THAT
RESURGENT DATE INTEGRITY HE
THAT HAS EIGHTEEN FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES AND GETTING CAUGHT
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION INSIDE
YOU PROFITABILITY'S IS ACTUALLY
ALMOST DOUBLE THAT OF
FLORIDA'S. I WITH THE GUARDS TO
EVALUATING THE EFFICACY OF
LOCAL PROGRAMS AND PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
COUNTIES WE ALSO ESTIMATE
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY THREE F.
T.'S AND AGAIN THAT'S BASED ON
THE FLORIDA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE PROGRAMMING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE DEPARTMENT
WHICH HAS TEN AND AGAIN WE HAVE
ALMOST DOUBLED I'M THOSE
NUMBERS AS IN FLORIDA. AND
FINALLY AS FAR AS THE GRANT
ADMINISTRATION IT WE ARE
ESTIMATING A MINIMUM OF EIGHT-
AND UP TO TEN F. T. E.'S AND
THIS IS BASED ON LOOKING AT THE
FORTY STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS THEY HAVE A
CORRECTIONS PLANNING GRANT
PROGRAM DIVISION THAT HAS
TWENTY SEVEN F. T. E.'S FOR
EIGHTEEN ACTED GRANT PROGRAMS.
AND- I SEE ARE WILL ADMINISTER
BOTH THE NEW REALIGNMENT BLOCK
GRANTS AS WELL AS ALL JUVENILE
JUSTICE GRANTS CURRENTLY
ADMINISTERED BY THE BCC SEVEN
MOUNTS TO AT A MINIMUM SEVEN
JUVENILE JUSTICE GRANT
EVENTUALLY AND THEN THEY HAVE
TO COORDINATE WITH THE BCC ON
ADDITIONAL SEVEN GRANTS THAT
SUPPORT BOTH ADULT AND JUVENILE
RELATED PROGRAMS SO ALL OF
THOSE. WOULD ADD UP TO AT A
MINIMUM FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU
FOR THE- OF HOW AND SERVE- CAL.
HAS THE LARGEST JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY.
AND GIVEN THE COMMENTS FROM THE
ADVOCATES- AND ALEJO. IN YOUR
OPINION. THREE MILLION
INSUFFICIENT TO SET UP. THE
OFFICE THAT WILL HAVE THE
SUBSTANCE AND BE ABLE TO
PERFORM ITS DUTY. WE DID AN
ASSESSMENT AND I THINK IF YOU.
I WANTED TO AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE- S. THE ADVOCACY OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT WANTING TO IMPROVE THE
SYSTEM FOR CHILDREN WHO ARE
JUSTICE INVOLVED- RBC P. AS I
MENTIONED AT HAS A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT- INTERPRETATION OF
THE SCOPE OF THE OFFICE OF THE-
PERSON- AND THAT'S- AND- WE'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN MULTIPLE STAFF
PEOPLE WORKING ON THAT I KNOW
THERE WAS A MENTION THAT THERE
WERE TWO STAFF THAT WERE.
DEDICATED TO THAT POSITION BUT
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY WE'VE
ORGANIZED OUR ORG CHART INTO
UNITS THAT REPORT TO AN
EXECUTIVE OFFICE OF WHICH OF
COURSE IS WHERE WE'LL HAVE OUR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AS WELL AS
ON THE COUNCIL AND WE WOULD
ENVISIONED TO PEOPLE BEING
FULLY DEDICATE TO RECEIVING
THOSE BUT IT REALLY WILL BE THE
WORK OF THE OFFICE TO
DETERMINE- OUT TO ASSESS REFER-
IN MANY CASES THEY WILL BE
GOING BACK LEAD DIRECTLY TO THE
FACILITIES AND THE
ADMINISTRATORS AND TRYING TO
RESOLVE THE ISSUE LOCALLY.
BECAUSE OF THE OVERALL YOU KNOW
THAT WE WANT. OUR COUNTY
IMPLEMENT TO BE. AND THAT IS
REALLY OUR PRIMARY FOCUS AT
THIS TIME THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE SHIFT IN POLICY. UP FOR
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WILL NO
LONGER BE REFERRED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
WHICH CURRENTLY SERVES AROUND
SEVEN HUNDRED USE. AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE USE OF
ARE TAKING CARE OF AND ANY USE
THAT WOULD HAVE. HAD DJJ- AS AN
OPTION IN THE FUTURE HAVE THE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
THAT NEED TO BE PROVIDED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND SO THAT'S
REALLY OUR LASER FOCUS. AT THIS
TIME- CERTAINLY WE BELIEVE
WITHIN. THE OFFICE BUT ALSO IN
LEVERAGING THE KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERTISE OF OUR VARIOUS
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS. WERE
ALREADY DOING A LOT OF WORK IN
THIS AREA I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO COORDINATE THAT
WORK I THINK WE FEEL THE
OFFICE. IS AN OFFICE IN ITS
RESPONSIBILITY WOULD BE TO
COORDINATE DEPARTMENTS IN THAT
WAY SO- WE'VE GOT WORK GOING ON
AT DEPARTMENTS SOCIAL SERVICES
WITH OUR SYSTEM OF CARE WORK.
OBVIOUSLY A CONTINUUM OF CARE.
FOR MARK WITH OUR FOSTER CARE
YOUTH. WE'RE DOING IT WORK WITH
CD AND OTHER DEPARTMENTS
OUTSIDE OF OUR OFFICE- WILL BE
COLLABORATING WITH THE COUNCIL
ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH REALLY
FOCUSES ON. THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
NEEDS OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
POPULATIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS SO. I DO
THINK I AM. WE REALLY DO A STEP
INFILL AT THIS TIME- THAT. THE
POSITIONS THAT WE BASS FOR AND
THE ONGOING CONTRACTING FUNDS
THAT WE'VE ASKED FOR IN ORDER
TO ACQUIRE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE. I WOULD REALLY BE A
SUFFICIENT. I HAVE THE MORE
QUESTIONS THAT ON THE NOTE WAIT
OFTEN SEE OF MY COLLEAGUES COME
WITH A MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU- AVERAGE THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT I'M EXTREMELY.
CONCERNED ABOUT- ESPECIALLY.
SINCE WE'VE ALREADY- LAST WEEK
EXPERIENCE WHEN WE THOUGHT WE
HAD AN OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
CALLED THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS. AND THEY
TOLD US. QUITE FRANKLY THAT
WE'RE THE ONES THAT SET THEM UP
AND IF THERE'S ANY DEFICIENCIES
IN WHAT THEY DO IS THE
LEGISLATURE THAT MESSED IT UP
IF THE GOVERNOR THAT MESSED IT
UP BECAUSE WHERE I DIDN'T GET
ENOUGH RESOURCES INTO GIVEN
ENOUGH MONEY OR A STORY THE BE
ABLE TO HANDLE THEIR TASK FOR
WHICH WE BELIEVE. THAT WHAT
THEY WERE DOING. I'M GETTING UP
EARLY FEELING IN THE PIT OF MY
STOMACH THAT THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION
MAYBE GOING DOWN THAT SAME
PATH. AND SO I'M SAYING THAT SO
YOU KNOW IN THE CONTEXT OF WHY
WE'RE ASKING THESE QUESTIONS
NOW WHY IT IS SO IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW AS CHAIR
PUBLIC SAFETY. I NOW HAVE THE
TASK OF EITHER ELIMINATING B.
S. C. C. RESTRUCTURING BE SEC
OR DOING SOMETHING WITH IT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES ARE OR I
NEED TO RESEARCH WHAT THEY WERE
ORIGINALLY INTENDED TO DO. NOT
TAKING SURVEYS AND CINEMA
PUNDITS ON A ON A IN A SHELL
IT'S BELIEVED THAT THEY WOULD
BE OVERSIGHT. AND SO WHAT EVER
WE NEED BECAUSE THE ANIMAL
BLAME COLLECTED EFFICIENT
BECAUSE I AM ONE NOW. ELECTED
OFFICIALS LOVE TO MAKE LAWS.
BUT WERE NOT GOOD AT
IMPLEMENTATION. OF GIVING STAFF
ENOUGH RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO
DO THEIR JOB. AND SO. WHAT I
NEED FROM THE ADVOCATES. WHAT
THEY BELIEVE. AND I MEAN AROUND
THE NUMBER OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE LISTENING TO YOU DURING THE
ALPHABET SOUP OF A- OF
RESOURCES F. T. E.'S IN. AB
SEASON HERE THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS A LOT I NEED A
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER YOU NEED
TWENTY MILLION FIFTY MILLION.
R. THREE MILLION I DON'T IT
IN ON THIS RIGHT NOW GOT ALL
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT I
HAVE NO CLUE WHAT THAT TOTAL
AMOUNT IS. BECAUSE IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU BELIEVE YOU NEED AND
WE HAVE A DISCUSSION WITH THE
OUT WITH THIS NEW HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICE AGENCY OR Y. C.
R. NEEDS. MAYBE HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT WE TRULY
NEED TO MAKE THIS SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
AND I FROM L. A. COUNTY AS A AS
THE CHAIRS FROM L. A. COUNTY.
WE WILL BE MOST IMPACTED IF
THIS EXPERIMENT DOESN'T WORK
LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN WE WILL
BE MOST IMPACTED IF THIS
EXPERIMENT DOESN'T. WORK AND
SHALL WE SHOULD NOT. NOT GIVE.
EVERYONE ENOUGH RESOURCES TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS VERY
SUCCESSFUL AND SO WHAT I NEED.
PROBABLY FROM BOTH OF YOU IS
ONE FOR ME ADVOCATES. WHICH YOU
BELIEVE IS NEEDED TO MAKE TO
SUCCESSFUL AND THAT AND A
BOTTOM LINE COSTS. AND IF THIS
IS YOUR FINAL ANSWER FROM THE
INTERNAL. SIDE WITH OUR OUR
BUREAUCRACY- LET IT LET IT BE
SO BUT IF YOU TRULY BELIEVE.
THAT MAYBE YOU NEED SOME MORE
RECESSED SOURCES TO BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL. I DON'T CARE IF YOU
WHISPER IN MY EAR I WILL TELL
THE GOVERNOR YOU TOLD ME. JUST
LET ME KNOW. WHICH TRULY TRULY
NEED TO MAKE THIS THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM PROGRAM YOU
CAN TELL ME NOW OR MY OFFICE.
WHATEVER WORKS BEST FOR EITHER
SIDE. BEFORE I MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT MEMBER THE SEVEN ANYONE
ONE ANSWER NOW OR YOU'RE GONNA.
ANSWER LATER. I WILL TELL THE
GOVERNOR. RIGHT NOW AND THEN I.
I'VE I APPRECIATE THAT I DO
RESPECT IT BUT AND AT THIS
POINT IN TIME AT NINETEEN
POSITIONS THAT WE'VE ASKED FOR
AND THE FUNDING LEVEL THAT
WE'VE REQUESTED. IS WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS NECESSARY TO FULFILL
THE OBLIGATIONS IN STATUTE.
OKAY CAN COME TO MY OFFICE AND
THEN IN EXPLAINED TO ME IN
DETAIL WHY YOU BELIEVE THAT SO
THAT'S- RIGHT BECAUSE IT HOURS
LATER ON HOLD UP EVERYBODY
RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
A SYSTEM. BAKER AND I WANT TO
SHARE WITH THAT ENDING WITH
WELLS. YOU HAVE A LOT OF
ADVOCACY HERE ON THIS COMMITTEE
AND WANTING TO HELP IT LOOKS
LIKE THE ADMINISTRATION HAS.
COME LIGHTLY INTERPRETED OR
INCORRECTLY INTERPRETED WHAT
THE SCOPE I THINK OF YOUR
ORGANIZATION IS SUPPOSED TO DO.
AND WE ALL THINK IT NEEDS TO BE
MORE OF US HERE AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE TASK AHEAD N.
WHAT'S BEING ASKED IS. IT'S NOT
JUST WORKING WITH THE COUNTY'S
BECAUSE- NOT EVERY COUNTY WILL
BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT. ALL OF
THE SERVICES FOR THOSE KIDS.
SOME HAVE TO BE DONE REGIONALLY
ACCREDITED HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO WORK TOGETHER. THERE ARE
A LOT OF OTHER QUESTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE RAISED. AND WILL
NEED SOME SIGNIFICANT GUIDANCE
FROM THE STATE AB HELPED IN
PUTTING SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS
TOGETHER. SO I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE AND THEN EVEN JUST DEALING
WITH IN YOUR OWN AGENCY. AS WE
SAW WITH CC ARE THE CONTINUING
CARE REFORM. GETTING D. HUMAN
SERVICES SIDE ESPECIALLY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKING WITH
THE CHILD WELFARE SIDE THE
HUMAN SERVICES SIDE WAS NOT
VERY EASY TO DO BECAUSE THEY
WERE SO VERY DIFFERENT
PERCEPTIONS OF WHAT THE
MISSIONS WERE AND WHAT. THE
SENSE OF OUTCOMES WERE GOING TO
BE SO I THINK THIS IS MUCH MORE
COMPLEX TO DO AND AS SOON AS
YOU START TASKING THOSE OTHER.
YOUR SOURCE SISTER AGENCIES
WITHIN HHS THEY'RE THEY'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING FOR MONEY AND
MAYBE THAT'S COMES OUT OF A
DIFFERENT BUDGET SO MAYBE WE'RE
NOT SEEING THOSE. THOSE THOSE
REQUESTS COME UP. BUT FOR ME
I'D RATHER SEE YOU HAVE ENOUGH
PEOPLE AND RESOURCES. TO TRULY
BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT AND IF
IT'S A QUESTION ABOUT. SCOPE
AND HOW MUCH AUTHORITY YOU HAVE
VERSUS WHAT WE THINK YOU SHOULD
HAVE THAT THAT'S A CONVERSATION
WE NEED TO HAVE. AN ABSOLUTELY
CLARIFY WE DID IN FACT TRY TO
GET MORE THORNY THE
OMBUDSPERSON. THAN I THINK WAS
THERE BUT WITH RESPECT TO THE
REST OF YOUR STAFF. HAVING
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT IN PEOPLE
TO PERFORM ALL OF THOSE
FUNCTIONS AND PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES AND THAT BACK COMMON
STANDARD. AMONG ALL OF THE
COUNTIES OF WHAT WE EXPECT THEM
WHEN THEY'RE TAKING CARE OF OUR
KIDS ACROSS STATE IS REALLY
WHAT WE'RE- WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. SO I THINK YOU'RE
HEARING SOME SKEPTICISM ON OUR
PART THAT YOU'VE BUILT ENOUGH.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE YOUR
INTERNAL MACHINATIONS ARE COULD
ONLY IMAGINE ABOUT WITH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND OTHERS.
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL YOU HAVE TO
BE SUCCESSFUL. WITH THIS AND
WORKING WITH THE COUNTIES THAT
THE COUNTIES ARE GETTING OF
RESOURCES YOU'RE GETTING ENOUGH
RESOURCES. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS ALL WORKS SO YOU'RE YOU'RE
HEARING SOME SKEPTICISM ON OUR
SIDE THANK IN THIS LOOKS A
LITTLE THIN. FOR WHAT OUR
EXPECTATION OF. YOUR AGENCY IS.
N. I THINK WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE WITH
WHAT YOU THINK YOU'RE EXPECTING
WHAT WE'RE EXPECTING. AND IF
NOT THEN. WE DEFINITELY NEED TO
SORT THAT OUT. SO HELP HELP US
HELP YOU. THANK YOU I WILL TAKE
THAT BACK THANK. WE APPRECIATE
THAT AND I WILL CERTAINLY TAKE
THAT BACK. THANK YOU FOR ME WE
CARE FROM ALL OF US HERE IS
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF CONFUSION
ABOUT HOW AGES- HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CAME UP
WITH THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL- AND
CONCERNED ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
WE'RE FINDING IT AT A- PROPER
LEVEL. OF MOST OF OUR HEARINGS
HAVE BEEN ABOUT- WHY ASKING US
FOR SO MUCH MONEY AND THINK
THAT THEY WERE ASKING WHY ARE
YOU ASKING THIS FOR SO LITTLE
MONEY. WHICH IS THE RARE
POSITION TO BE IN- AS I DO WANT
TO. POINT THAT OUT- AND SO WITH
THAT I GUESS IT DID TRY TO
CLARIFY SOME SOME OF THAT
CONFUSION TO HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. THAT CAN YOU CONFIRM
THAT YOU TOLD YOUR STAFF AT THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR THE OFFICE
WAS CREATED WITH. I'LL JUST
HAVE AN AFFAIR. WITH AN ARAB.
OF ONLY DJJ YOUTH. THEY'RE NOT
ACTIVELY UNDERSTOOD THE
QUESTION BUT- HE THERE ARE
DIFFERENT- FUNCTIONS WITHIN THE
OFFICE I THINK THAT IN TERMS OF
OUR POLICY ROLES AND IN TERMS
OF PROMOTING AND DISSEMINATING
BEST PRACTICES. AND THAT IS
VERY CLEARLY OUTLINED IN
STATUTE TO BE FOR THE BROADER
LARGER SYSTEM AND ALL USED IT
MAYBE JUSTICE INVOLVED BUT FOR
THIS PECIFIC ROLES AROUND THE
HONEST PERSON AND THAT
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY AND
THAT THAT IS VERY NARROWLY
FOCUSED- IN OUR BELIEF ON THE
RELAUNCH POPULATION. ASKING
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTION. I
THINK THAT FIRST TO ANSWER OUR
QUESTION AND SO GIVEN THAT YOU
ARE NOT LETTING US KNOW THAT
YOU DO THINK THAT IT'S WIDER AT
THINK AGAIN THAT THE DOLLAR
MONTH STILL SEEMS QUESTIONABLE
AND SO I WOULD THINK THAT THAT
THE COMMITTEES REQUESTING AN
UPDATED B. C. P. THAT'S BASED
ON THE DUTIES ARE LAID OUT IN
THE STATUTE- EARLIER YOU SAID
THAT YOU THOUGHT THAT WHICH YOU
SUBMIT IT WITH. THAT YOU KNOW
WE ARE RECOMMENDING THAT WE
WORK TOGETHER TO TRY TO COME UP
WITH SOMETHING THAT. INK MAYBE
FITS OUR INTERPRETATION IS
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
THIS IS ALLISON YOUR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IF I MAY ADD ON TO
MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS VERY
QUICKLY SO. THIS IS WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT FORWARD
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE THINK HOW.
WE WHAT WE BELIEVE WILL TAKE.
IT WILL TAKE TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN TERMS OF EMPLOYMENT
IMPLEMENTING THE SAME OFFICE I
THINK WE CAN SAY THAT THERE'S A
FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENT ABOUT
HOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
INTERPRETING THE STATUTE BUT WE
REALLY SAW THE OFFICES AS
HAVING TO CORPS OVERSIGHT
COMPONENTS. AND I WOULD HAVE MY
COLLEAGUE FILL IN ANY GAPS THAT
I MISS UN BUT WE SEE IT ALL
RIGHT- REVIEW OF THE PLANS AS
IT PERTAINS TO THAT I SIX
HUNDRED AND NINETY YOUTH THAT
ARE CURRENTLY HOUSING DJ THAT
WOULD BE REALIGNED TO THE
COUNTY IS. AND THE REALIGNMENT
OF THE CRANE STARTING JULY
FIRST FINE AND THEN WE SEE AT
THE PRINCE OF THE OFFICE OF THE
OMBUDSPERSON THAT'S- THE WHOLE
GOAL HERE OF THE REALIGNMENT
AND PUTTING THE YOUTH BACK AT
THE COUNTIES IS BECAUSE WE SEE
MORE SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES. AND
SO WHEN THERE'S A CORE BELIEF
THAT THE COUNTY IS I IN
ADDITION TO THE FUNDING THAT'S
BEEN APPROPRIATED WOULD BE ABLE
TO SERVE THESE YOUTH AND HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN SERVING
YOU'VE PREVIOUSLY. AND SO.
THAT'S I THINK WHERE WHERE
THERE'S A I NEED A DISAGREEMENT
IS WHAT IS THE SCOPE OF THE
OMBUDSPERSON FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE THE VISION HERE IS
THAT. AND THEY OMBUDSPERSON IS
THERE TO REALLY FOCUS ON THAT
YOU THAT HAVE THE HIGHEST NEEDS
WHICH ARE THAT THE REAL LINES
POPULATIONS. AND INCLUDING THE
POPULATION THAT WOULD BE
REALIGNED UNDER SB EIGHT TO
THREE AND IF THEY WERE TO GET
OTHER COMPLAINTS FROM OTHER
YOUTH THEY'RE CERTAINLY GOING
TO BE HELPING THOSE AT
INDIVIDUALS AND- IT DIDN'T FIRE
YOU DON'T POINTS OF CONTACT
WHETHER IT'S AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL OR OTHERWISE WHERE THEY
CAN HAVE THEIR COMPLAINTS
ADDRESSED. I THINK THE QUESTION
IS WHAT DOES THE OMBUDSPERSON
DO WITHIN THE OFFICE AND THAT
THE FOCUS THERE AND THE
INTENTIONAL. FOCUS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS ON THE REAL
LINE POPULATIONS I II THE
HIGHEST NEED YOU WITH BUT BUT
NO YOU WITH IS GOING TO GO ON
THE SERVER IT'S JUST ABOUT
CONNECTING THEM TO THE
RESOURCES. AND THAT WILL BE
ABLE TO HELP THEM IN TERMS OF
ANY COMPLAINTS THAT ARISE. I
JUST WANTED TO ADD IN THAT
COMMENTED IDON'T KNOW IF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE H. AGENCY AS
AN- ELSE ADD. THAT IS CORRECT
BECAUSE OF THE ARE RISKS. IS
ALSO TO REFER. THOSE USED TO A
PLACE WHERE THEY ACTUALLY CAN
GET THE HELP THAT THEY NEED AND
THAT'S YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT
VARIOUS DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS
WE HAVE OTHER HONEST PERSONS-
CERTAINLY AGAIN YOU KNOW. IF
ANYTHING AGREE JUST A LEGAL YOU
KNOW TERRIBLE THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING
TO DO WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
ADDRESS THOSE THOSE PARTICULAR
ISSUES- BUT AGAIN. WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSED ON THESE KIDS THESE ARE
THE KIDS THAT ARE MOST LIKELY
GOING TO BE IN THE ACTUAL GIVEN
OUT TO SPECIFICALLY- AND THEN
THE ONES WHO ARE GOING TO BE
RECEIVING EXTENSIVE TREATMENTS
AND SO I THINK THAT IT JUST
MAKES I THINK WE THINK IT MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE TO REALLY.
FOCUSED ON THE KIDS WHO NEED-
WE NEED. TO GERMANICA COMMENT.
THE SERVICE LINE IT WAS NOT
HAVE NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW I WILL LET YOU MAKE. IT I
MEAN I. YEAH I'M- HERE I'LL
TALK ABOUT. INTERPRETATIONS AND
LANDREAU WHY DOES INTERPRET
INTERPRETATIONS WERE MADE WHEN
ALL THE NEEDS TO HAPPEN IS HAVE
A CONVERSATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WHO. HAD ANY
INTENTION WHEN THEY DRAFTED
THIS LANGUAGE AND GO STRAIGHT
WE HAVE AND IT IS CLEAR AND
WORK AND WE'RE TELLING THEM HE
ATTENTION WAS THAT THIS BE A
ROBUST OFFICE WITH A LOT OF
RESPONSIBILITIES BECAUSE A LOT
OF THAT STATE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE. WHO NEEDS SUPPORT
IS THE MOST WONDERFUL KIDS IN
OUR STATE AND IF WE HAVE AN
UNDERFUNDED OVERSIGHT ENTITY
WITH A LOT OF RESPONSIBILITIES
THINGS ARE GOING TO GO WRONG
AND LYFT WILL BE HARMED IF NOT.
PEOPLE WILL BE KILLED RIGHT AND
SO FOR PEOPLE TO SUGGEST. THAT
BABY NIPPLE AT ALL AND ARE
ASKING THE QUESTIONS TO THE
APPROPRIATE PEOPLE TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THIS LOG OUT. IT'S JUST WRONG I
THINK IT SHOWS A LACK OF
COMMUNITY IN A LACK OF.
ACCOUNTABILITY WE NEED TO GET
THIS RIGHT EQUITIES JONES
SAWYER SAID AND SO I THINK WE
DO NEED TO MAYBE. GO BACK TO
SCHOOL READ THE STATUTE. FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE WORDS. MEAN AND-
THEN FROM THAT. FIT THE PLAN.
BUT THIS IDEA THAT WE- BE MORE
MONEY BECAUSE WE ARE NARROWING
THE SCOPE. OF WHAT WE THINK
THIS STATUTES SAID WHEN THAT IN
FACT NOT THE REALITY. IS
DISRESPECTFUL TO THE KIDS WHO
NEED THIS HELP. THINGS WILL
HAPPEN AND IT'LL BE. ON
EVERYBODY'S HANDS THAT'S ALL
I'M SAYING IS THESE THESE ARE
NOT QUESTIONS THAT CAN'T BE
ANSWERED THE LEGISLATURE ZERO
INFORMED. THE ADVOCATES THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WE WERE ALL
INVOLVED IN THIS CONVERSATION
WE KNOW VERY WELL WHAT WE
INTENDED TO HAVE WHAT WE
LEGISLATIVE. IT'S IN PRINT. AND
SO THERE'S ALWAYS YOU KNOW
TALKING CIRCLES I JUST THINK IT
IS NOT A GOOD USE OF TIME AND
JUST BE HONEST. THE STATE IS
LISTENING. AND WE NEED A LOCAL
Y. C. R. DID WAS JOB I NEED TO
BE WELL FUNDED. AND IF YOU KNOW
OVERSEE OUR TAKE THE POSITION
THAT THEY CAN DO MORE WITH LESS
THAN. MY LAST COMMENT WOULD BE
THAT MAYBE YOU SHOULD TALK TO
PROBATION. SYSTEMATICALLY MORE
WITH LESS AS WELL- A THANK YOU
IT IS. IT'S LATE HOUR. AT HERE
TODAY SO I AM- THEN I LET THAT
BE A PART OF RECKLESS AND
COMMENTATORS- REALLY URGE H. A.
S. S. AND THE- I HAVE TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO GET ON
THE SAME PAGE I THINK OUR
COMMON GOAL IS ENSURING THAT
OUR KIDS ARE PROTECTED THAT OUR
KIDS ARE NOT JUST PROTECTED AND
NOT TO SERVE BUT WE'RE FINDING
OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP THEM. BE
THE LEADERS THAT WE KNOW THEY
CAN BE AND MOVE FORWARD IN LIFE
OUT THERE AND SO THERE'S A LOT
AT STAKE- IT'S BEEN WORK THAT'S
BEEN ONGOING FOR A WHILE AND SO
I THINK IT'S CLEAR WE'RE NOT ON
THE SAME PAGE BUT I DO BELIEVE
THAT SOME CONVERSATIONS TO GET
US THERE BETWEEN NOW AND US
HAVING A FINAL BUDGET PROPOSAL.
AS WELL OUT THERE. AND SO I DO
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S TIME TO
LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
DISCUSSIONS- WE HAVE SOME VERY
PASSIONATE MEMBERS WHO HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR A LONG
TIME AND SO I DO. RECOMMEND YOU
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THEIR OFFERS
TO WORK WITH YOU DIRECTLY. I TO
GET IT RIGHT. AND TO MAKE SURE
WE HONOR OUR COMMITMENTS ALL OF
OUR- ALL OF OUR KIDS OUT THERE.
THANK YOU. AND SO I WILL BE
MOVING ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM. AND ON THE PHONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT
THIS ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
THE AGENDA AND SHOULD BE ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU'RE STREAMING THE
HEARING. THE NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AT SIX ACCESS
CODE. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. IF YOU ENCOUNTER
ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2090 NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. WE ALSO
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN PUBLIC TESTIMONY AS
WELL. THIS CAN BE SUBMITTED AT
BUDGET SUB FIVE AT ASM DOT CA
DOT GOV AND IS ALSO LISTED ON
THE AGENDA. DO WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS FROM THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM. SCENE NINE UP. OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT EACH PERSON HAS ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ONE
ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MIKE CARROLL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY THANK YOU FOR THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION ON THE
CONTINUING RELIANCE OF THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH ON EXTRACTING
FUNDS FROM LOW INCOME
DEFENDANTS. YEAH WE OPPOSE THE
EXPANSION OF THE ONLINE CRAP
DIGITIZATION PILOT FOR MANY OF
THE REASONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE OUTLINE DESPITE GOOD
INTENTIONS THE PILOT PERPETUATE
UNEQUAL LEVELS ADJUSTED.
DEPENDING UPON WHERE ONE LIVES.
PARDON ME. BOB THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY THE COURTS OVER
DEFENSE OF WHAT THE I THOUGHT
FUNDS. TICKET ABOUT THE NEED TO
REDUCE SPEED TO CROSS THE
BORDER. AND WALKED BACK SEVERAL
LINES COURTS. ONE TAKEN FROM
THOSE WHO WOULD BELIEVE THE
BELIEVE THE PAIN- WE ALSO URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO. EXERCISE
CAUTION ABOUT APPROVING THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ALLOWING.
COURTS TO MOVE TO REMOTE
RECEIVING. ACTUALLY AS DRAK THE
CORPORATE ONLY CONSTRUCTION
TERM THROWN HEARING AND NOT.
TOUCH HIM ON MONUMENTAL CHANGE
CONCERT THE CAREFUL REVIEW THAT
IS NOT APPROPRIATE FOR ADOPTING
EXPEDITED TRAILER BILL PROCESS.
THAT'S FINE REYES WOULD WRAP UP
THE BIKE BUT- I GET THEM. THANK
YOU ARE PART OF THE NOTE I KNOW
THERE IS A CERTAIN PART IN. WE
WOULD JUST URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO FUND IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
JAMISON DECISION CAN'T MAKE
SURE THAT THE TRANSCRIPT
EMBARRASSMENT FUND IS FULLY
FUNDED TO HANDLE WHAT THE
ANTICIPATED ME. THANK YOU SORRY
FOR GOING OVER THANK YOU I KNOW
THAT THIS THESE TOPICS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THE PEOPLE'S ADVOCACY
IMPATIENCE WE HAVE A LARGE
NUMBER OF FOLKS- IN LINE
WAITING TO SPEAK SO I DO- URGE
YOU TO PLEASE BE SO THINK WITH
YOUR COMMENTS AND TRY TO KEEP
IT TO ONE MINUTE. OPERATOR NEXT
PERSON. NINE ONE THIRTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS DEBORAH LARA AND
PROBATION MANAGER THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
PROFESSIONAL MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION AFFILIATED WITHOUT
ME LOCAL NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
ADMINISTRATION PARTNER THIRTY
FIVE YEARS AND DURING THIS TIME
BETWEEN A LOT OF CHANGES IN
ORDER TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE GOT
TO WHERE WE ARE AND WHERE WE'RE
GOING IT'S IMPORTANT TO TAKE A
LOOK BACK TO SEE HOW WE GOT
HERE FORTY YEARS AGO WE WERE
DEPARTMENT LASER FOCUSED ON
REHABILITATION BUT THE BOARD OF
SUERVISORS THAT THE TIME HAD A
DIFFERENT AGENDA BECAUSE OF THE
LOSS O PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
UNDER PROP THIRTEEN. RESEARCHES
FOR SEVERELY CURTAILED LAW
ORDER WAS BRINGING POLICY SO WE
WERE STRIPPED OF NEARLY ALL OF
OUR RESPONSIBILITIES YEAH
POPULATION MANAGEMENT WHAT ARE
CAPABLE TO DOUBLE THE AND WE
ACTUALLY WENT ON STRIKE TO
FIGHT. THE BOARD SO WHAT THEY
WERE DOING. WHAT THE- THAT WITH
THE DESTRUCTION OF THE PRODUCT
PROGRAM EVERY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM WILL WORK. ON FELL
APART AS THEY REDUCE THE
RESOURCES FROM HOPING TO CATCH
SINCE THAT TIME WE'VE DONE THE
BEST WITH WHAT WE HAVE AND
CONTINUE TO INNOVATE BUT THEY
SHOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN FUNDED
PROPERLY AND WE HAVE STRUGGLE
TO DO THE BEST WE CAN. WITH
LIMITED RESOURCES I'VE ALWAYS
SAID THAT IF THE COUNTY'S
RAPIDLY BECOME AND- GRAHAM.
THEY NEED TO RESTART THAT
PROBATION AND WILL PRODUCE IT.
REGARDLESS OF THE LEVEL OF
RESTRICTIVE AREA OF THE CRIME
OUR HEARTS ARE. WITH DOING THE
VERY BEST THING WE CAN. I'MTHE
DOCTOR HAVE A- BOXER ENGINE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT PERCENT. NINE ONE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS LEO
SHARP BURKE THE LAWYERS
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS AND
WERE INVOLVED IN THE DEATH
PROJECTED COALITION AND THE
BACK ON THE ROAD COALITION I'M
HERE TO SPEAK REGARDING THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S ABILITY TO
PAY EXPANSION PROPOSAL AND I
URGE YOU TO REJECT IT. INSTEAD
OF EXPANDING THE TOOL THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE LIMIT OF
WHAT THAT MEANT OF COURSE WE
NEED TO REDUCE THE COST OF
FINES AND FEES THEIR WAY TOO
HIGH WE ALL AGREE BUT THE
ONLINE TOOL IS NOT THE RIGHT
APPROACH ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
SAID WE MUST ATTEND TO THE
UNDERLYING CAUSE OF THE
PROBLEM. THE. IMPOSITION OF
EXCESSIVE FINES AND FEES.
RAMPART OF THOSE WITH THE WHERE
ALL TO GET ONLINE COMPLETE THE
TOOL. FOR THOSE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE MEETING VIRTUALLY THAT
MIGHT. BE THE- BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR MANY PEOPLE THAT NEED THAT
TOOL. USING THE ONLINE TOOL THE
LOWER COSTS WILL ENSURE THAT
MANY OF THOSE WHO NEED HELP
MOST WILL NOT RECEIVE IT. THE
ONLINE TOOL ALSO HELPS PEOPLE
IN DIFFERENT COUNTY
DIFFERENTLY. WE SHOULD HAVE AN
OPTION OF SOLUTION THAT OFFERS
GEOGRAPHIC UNIFORMITY. WE
SHOULDN'T LOAD PEOPLE UP THE
MAP OF THAT AND THEN OFFER THEM
A WEEK ON THE BACK AND WE NEED
FRONT AND REFORM WE NEED TO
ELIMINATE SEVERAL AFFECTING YOU
PLEASE WRAP UP WHAT. HAPPENED
DISPROPORTIONATELY PENALIZE LOW
INCOME PEOPLE BECOME MUCH MORE
EQUITABLE. WAY TO REDUCE COSTS.
EXPERTS ON. NINE ONE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS THE RESULT OF THE
WITH THE LAWYERS COMMITTEE
ABOUT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
ABILITY TO PAY ITEM. AND YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS THAT JOB
THE LATE BEING CALIFORNIA JUST
A THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR THE BOOK
THAT. IS MORE THAN WHAT NEARLY
EVERY OTHER STATE WITH
AVAILABLE DATA CHARGES FOR A
TRAFFIC TICKET. AND IT WILL
AFFECT OUR DEEPLY RELEASE TO
THE ABILITY TO PAY- EXPANSION
AT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS. IN
VERY GOOD FAITH PROPOSING
BECAUSE- IF YOU LOOK AT IT FOR
EXAMPLE SOLANO COUNTY ADOPTED
AN ABILITY TO PAY PROGRAM AND-
NEAR IN NEARLY EVERY CASE MORE
THAN 90% OF CASES. THEY
RETAINED AT LEAST THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. WORK ON UNABLE TO PAY
THEY KEPT THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
ON THE BUT FOR THOSE PEOPLE
TRUMP OF WHAT THEY OWE. BECAUSE
THE FEDERAL ASSESSMENT. WE SEE
THAT IN CALIFORNIA PEOPLE ARE
BEING. PUNISHED FOR IT ABILITY
TO PAY AND THE PERSON IN A
TRAFFIC FINE LEVEL FAR BEYOND
THAT THEY SHOULD BE PUNISHED
FOR THE ORIGINAL. AND THE
ABILITY TO PAY PENSION. OTHER
THAN FLOOD WON'T. POP UP
UNFORTUNATELY. I ALL THE EFFORT
PUT IN BY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
IMPLEMENTATION NUMBERS SHOW
THAT BROAD DISPARITIES BETWEEN
COUNTY ILL AND SPELL THAT. OUT
FOR YOU. NEXT PERSON. NINE ONE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE THAT
DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA HERE TO
SPEAK ON ITEM TWO FIFTY ISSUE
TO. ME RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS
THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE REJECTED
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
EXPANSION OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL ABILITY TO PAY PILOT
PROGRAM AND INSTEAD WE ALLOCATE
THE FUNDING TO THE ABOLISHMENT
OF THE SIMPLE ASSESSMENT CREEK.
CALIFORNIA TRAFFIC FINES AND
FEES ARE SOME OF THE HIGHEST IN
THE COUNTRY AND INCLUDES A
PARTICULARLY HIGH BURDEN ON
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES.
WELL CERTAINLY WELL INTENTIONED
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL ONLINE
EDUCATION PROGRAM DOES NOT
ACHIEVE THE GOALS IT SET OUT TO
ACCOMPLISH IN PARTICULAR DUE TO
BARRIERS TO ACCESS TO THE
PROGRAM DOES NOT ADEQUATELY
PROVIDE RELIEF FOR ALL WHO NEED
IT. SECOND THE PROGRAM LEAD TO
INADEQUATE REDUCTIONS FOR THOSE
WHO USE THAT AND LASTLY THE
PILOT PROGRAM ALSO ALLOWS
WIDELY DIVERGENT PRACTICES FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY. WITH THIS IN
MIND THE BEST WAY TO PROMOTE
AFFORDABILITY EQUITY AND ACCESS
TO JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA
TRAFFIC COURT IS TO ELIMINATE
THE CIVIL ASSESSMENT FEE
ALTOGETHER TO THE EXTENT THAT A
LIMITING. ELIMINATING CIVIL
ASSESSMENTS WOULD REDUCE COURT
REVENUES WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ALLOCATE THE
BUDGETED FUNDS TO ADDRESS THAT
SHORTFALL RATHER THAN TO FUND
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL PROGRAM
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT WEEK OR
NEXT PHONE CALL. MY ONE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LONG IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS A VERY REAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY JUSTICE SPEAKING
ON- TWO ISSUES THANK YOU NUMBER
FIVE THE FIRST BEING THE FIFTY
MILLION PROPOSAL TO PROBATION-
DEFINITELY IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO SUCH A PROPOSAL. OF
PROBATION AND THE COUNTIES
ALREADY RECEIVING ABEMAMA
RESOURCES BECAUSE OF THAT B.
EIGHT TWO THREE. ALSO REGARDING
THE NEW OFFICE OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION- THE
OFFICE NEEDS MORE STAFF AND PUT
INTO POLICE DUTY TO OVER TO THE
TREATMENT OF ALL YOUTH IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM. THANK
TEN OF ALL THE ARTS PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED ACCOUNTABILITY.
OVER COUNTY LEVEL INVESTMENT IN
THE CONTINUUM APPROACHES IN ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES- THE
CREATION OF ALL WHITE HERE IS
MONUMENTAL IN CALIFORNIA HAS
HAD NOT HAVE NOT HAD A STATE
ENTITY RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVERSEEING AND PROMOTING. BEST
PRACTICES FOR THE CARE AND
CUSTODY OF YOUTH IMPACTED BY
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM. CALIFORNIA
HAS HAD ABSOLUTELY NO
MEANINGFUL CHECK ON ABUSES
NEGLECT AND THE MISTREATMENT OF
OUR YOUTH. LASTLY HAVE BEEN
SAID THAT BUDGETS REFLECT
VALUES IF THAT IS NEED TO KNOW
THAT A MERE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ARE BEING PROPOSED FOR
THIS CRITICAL OFFICE. IT IS
SHAMEFUL AND NOT IN LINE WITH
THE INTENT OF SB EIGHT TWO
THREE AND WHAT IS NEEDED FOR
THE PROPER STATE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE WELL
BEING OF THE THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN LOCKED UP IN COUNTY
FACILITY. YEAH NO. NINE ONE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL UNDER
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE ON THE
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR PROBATION
DEPARTMENT TO SUPPORT AN
EMPLOYMENT BOTH JUVENILE AND
ADULT PERFORMED BY THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR- THE
IMPACT OF THESE REFORMS HAVE
BEEN IMMEDIATE UPON ENACTMENT
FOR EXAMPLE PROVISIONS TO GET
THE GET ONE TIME COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PREPARING. ALL
OF THE CURRENT CASES WITH THE
GRANT OF PROBATION AND WORKING
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE PEOPLE OFF OF
PROBATION PURSUANT TO AB
NINETEEN FIFTY ADDITIONALLY WE
KNOW THAT A NEW CASES ARE
CONSIDERED BY THE COURT IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A
ROBUST PROGRAMS IN PLACE SOONER
IN ORDER TO AVOID AN INCREASE
IN INCARCERATION SENTENCE AS-
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO PARTNER WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION TO SUPPORT
THESE PROGRAMS. AND REFORMS.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
TONIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT. NINE
ONE SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY LET
ME HELP YOU EIGHTY. YES. HI MY
NAME'S THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING US TO BE TODAY- I AM.
ON ANCESTRAL WE ARE TERRITORY
ALSO KNOWN AS HUMBOLDT COUNTY-
AND I JUST WANTED TO SUPPORT
DOMINIQUE- CRISTINA AND
SUGGESTIONS FOR THE BUDGET- I
WORK WITH YOUNG PEOPLE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO SPECIFICALLY. HAVE A
SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT AND- YOU
KNOW THE LOOKS ON THEIR FACES
WHEN WE TELL THEM THAT THIS IS
THE AMOUNT THAT IS BEING GIVEN
FOR THIS OFFENSE- THE TWENTY
LOOKING AFTER ALL OF THEM AND
THEN AND THEN LETTING THEM KNOW
THAT. THE STATE FIND IT MORE
IMPORTANT TO PUT FIVE TIMES AS
MUCH MONEY AND SO FORTH- BOARD
IT'S REALLY TRAUMATIZING- AND
IT'S REALLY DEVALUING AND SO-
YOU KNOW ALL THE SPECIFICS WERE
GIVEN ALREADY AND SO I REALLY
HOPE THAT YOU GUYS- DO YOUR
RESEARCH AND- BELIEVES THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING IN THIS
INDUSTRY AND LIKE KNOW HOW
MUCH. WORK IS AND MONEY IS
GOING TO BE NEEDED TO SUPPORT
ALL THESE YEARS- AND JUST THINK
OF YOU KNOW IF YOU KNOW ANY
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
INCARCERATED AND LIKE WHAT.
THAT'S GONNA MEAN FOR THEM-
WHEN THEY WHEN THEY HEAR HOW
MUCH VALUE IS BEING GIVEN TO
THAT SWITCH WHICH DOESN'T FEEL
LIKE A LOT AT ALL. SO I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PERSON. NINE
ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING FROM HOSTING WITH THE
CENTER ON JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE WE ASKED THE COMMITTEE
TO REJECT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED SHIFTING MILLION TO
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LOWEST YOUTH
CRIME RATE NEARLY SIXTY YEARS.
LAST YEAR COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT STORE RECEIVE NEARLY
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN ANNUAL JUVENILE JUSTICE
GRANTS. SB TWENTY THREE WILL
GET COUNTY AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THE PROPOSED FIFTY
MILLION IS UNNECESSARY INSTEAD
WE SHOULD RE DIRECT RESOURCES
TO COMMUNITY PROGRAMS. SERVING
ARE YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PERSON. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINE ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LAURA RIDOLFI ON
BEHALF OF THE WTA WITH BURNS
INSTITUTE I'D LIKE TO GIVE A
COMMENT ON THE ISSUE FIVE. THE
OPPOSITE USING COMMUNITY
RESTORATION. THE CREATION OF A
WHITE B. R. IS WITHOUT A DOUBT
ONE OF Vì MOST IMPORTANT AND
VISIONARY COMPONENT OF SB
TWENTY THREE. FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN CALIFORNIA THERE WILL
BE A MUCH NEEDED STATE AGENCY
THAT OVERSEES THE CARE AND
CUSTODY OF ALL YOU IN CONTACT
WITH AND HARMED BY THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. HOWEVER THE PROPOSED
FUNDING AND STAFFING FOR THE
BROAD RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE
OFFICE AS DISCUSSED BY THE
PANELISTS WHOLLY INSUFFICIENT.
TO FOCUS ON ONLY ONE OF THE
MANY RESPONSIBILITIES BEYOND
THE PERSON WE CAN CLEARLY SEE
THE INADEQUACY OF THE FUNDING
THE PROPOSED STACKING OF TWO
PEOPLE EVEN WITH SUPPORT. STAFF
WITH ME INVESTIGATE AND RESOLVE
COMPLAINTS FROM THE MORE THAN
SIXTEEN THOUSAND WHO ARE
DETAINED ANNUALLY AND THE MORE
THAN TEN THOUSAND NEWS PER YEAR
WHO ARE REMOVED FROM THEIR HOME
AS A RESULT OF THE QUARTER
DISPOSITION IN NINETY
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE. A
WHOLLY INSUFFICIENT THERE IS
NOTHING IN THE STATUTE THAT
LIMITS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF-
Y. ARE. ON THE PERSON OR
OTHERWISE. YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
WOULD OTHERWISE BE COMMITTED TO
DJJ AND LET'S BE CLEAR WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHO WAS
INVOLVED IN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND WHO THE ADMINISTRATION IS
REQUESTING LIMIT THE BUDGET TO
PROTECT WE ARE TALKING ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY ABOUT USE OF COLOR.
THERE IS NO POSSIBLE WAY FOR
THE OFFICE TO SUCCESSFULLY
EXECUTED BOTH MISSION WITH THE
PROPOSED FUNDING WE NEED A
BUDGET THAT REFLECTS OUR
PRIORITY TO PROMOTE THE
WELLBEING OF YOUNG PEOPLE IN
OUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
FOR SOME. NINE ONE SIXTY NEAR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TEDDY NOT
MY DREAM YOUNG BART FOLLOW WITH
COURAGE IN A RESIDENT OF SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY I AM ALSO A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED YOUTH IN
A PROUD MOTHER OF A CHILD
EASTERN GREENE DEPEND ON
WORKING DAYS AND EVERY DAY. I'M
GETTING COMMENT ON IF YOU FIVE
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION GAP WITHIN THEIR
SPONSOR FOR MONITORING THE
TREATMENT OF ALL YOUTH IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL NOW
REMAIN UNDER COUNTY CARE ACT
NEARLY SIXTY THOUSAND YOU
REFERRED TO THE DEATH WITH THE
TEN ANNUALLY. SIXTEEN THOUSAND
YOU THE PANCREAS EDUCATION AND
NEARLY TEN THOUSAND REMOVED
FROM THEIR HOMES AS A RESULT
THE COURT ORDERED THE DIVISION.
THANK ME THREE MILLION DOLLARS
AND THREE FOUR KINDS OF THAT
SEND AS A FAN. PERSPECTIVE THE
HORSE RACING BOARD HAD THE
BUDGET NEARLY FIVE TIMES A DAY
AND HALF BUDGET THIRTEEN FULL
TIME POSITION FOR A FAMILY
MEMBER AT THE BALLOT YOU.
ACCESS PEOPLE NO WONDER THE
SYSTEM FAILED ME TO AGREE
DISPLACEMENT FIFTY MILLION IT
ON THE TABLE PRESERVATION
BUDGET THREE MILLION FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE AND IT'S. REALLY
IMPORTANT CAN'T HEAD. MAKE IT.%
AND THAT THE ON THE PART. ABOUT
THANK YOU YOU. NEXT FOR SOME.
NINE ONE SIX EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO A- GOOD EVENING RUNNING
AND I WITH THIS AND YOU AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE I'M COMMENTING
ON ISSUE FIVE FIRST AND LET YOU
KNOW MY- CONCERN ABOUT THE
PROPOSED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
IN FUNDING FOR PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS WITH NO STRINGS
ATTACHED THIS IS SIMPLY
THROWING MONEY INTO AN ALREADY
BLOATED SYSTEM A PROBATION
SUPERVISION. NOW I ALSO LIKE TO
FOCUS ON THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION AND
INVESTMENT THAT PALED IN
COMPARISON TO THAT
UNACCOUNTABLE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION THAT
HHS SUBMIT AN UPDATED B. C. P.
WITH. ITERATION FULL SCOPE OF
RESPONSIBILITIES. THE CURRENT
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR- I HEAR
FAILED TO EVEN ITS MOST
RUDIMENTARY NEEDS FOR STAFF AND
RESOURCES. I. T. R. ADVOCATES
MONITOR THE TREATMENT OF TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF USED IN
CALIFORNIA JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. YET THE PROPOSAL ONLY
HAS THREE PEOPLE TO FILL A
LIGHT YARDS ROBUST ON BY ADMIN
DUTIES. WORSE YET THERE'S ONLY
ONE DATA SPECIALIST TWO
RESEARCH AND- ANALYZE JUVENILE
JUSTICE DATA IN OUR FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. AS A POLICY ANALYST
MYSELF I SEE HOW THOROUGHLY
UNREALISTIC THIS EXPECTATION
ED. CURE COMMITTEE HEARD JUST
LAST WEEK HOW TERRIBLY PSEC IS
FAILING AT JAIL AND JUVENILE
FACILITY INSPECTIONS. WE NEED A
PROPERLY FUNDED BY THE ARTS TO
FILL A LONG STANDING GAPS IN
OVERSIGHT AND LEADERSHIP. ARE
STATES USE THANK YOU. NEXT
PERCENT. NINE ONE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MY NAME'S MIGUEL GARC DEAL WITH
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
GIVING PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUED
BY THE OFFICE OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION. BUT I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO VOICE MY
CONCERNS ON THE FIFTY MILLION
NO CAN DETACH BY THE PROBATION.
THEY ARE ALREADY RECEIVING THAT
AND I'M- I'M NOT OFFENDING.
FIFTEEN TO PROVIDE. HELLO THE-
LIKE DR CANADIAN A FORMER USER
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE I RECOGNIZE
THE NEED FOR THE OFFICE THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT EXPECT T. PAY
EXPERIENCE THAT INCLUDED THE
POPE EXPERIENCE AND OTHER GIVE
ABOUT A MAN OUT SHOULD BE UNDER
WHAT I BELIEVE IT I BILL BE
ABLE HELP TREATMENT PROGRAMS IN
THE MODERATE ABOUT LIVING UNITS
WITHIN DJJ I THINK THE CLOSE OF
THE DAY DAY MEANT TO
CALIFORNIA'S CREDIT TRANSPONDER
KNOWLEDGE AT THE TIME ONE
FOCUSED ON PUBLIC HEALTH.
DEVELOPMENT ANOTHER TRONG MY
EMPLOYMENT APPROACHES MEANT
THAT YOU COOK NO LONGER HAVE TO
CONTINUE ON HEALTHCARE AND BY
D. CARRYING BUILDING POWERED UP
BY METAL BOXES UPON A TYPE OF
EXPECTED THAT BACKED UP PASSED
BOTH OF LIVED EXPERIENCE JEFF
BUT THE TERMINATE THE CONFLICT
RESOLUTION AND OTHER CULTURAL
NOT WILL GET APPROACH THANK.
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PERCENT. MY.
WE URGE. THE LEGISLATURE TO PUT
ON PARK. THE PUSH FOR REMOTE
JOINED. SEVERAL EXTERNAL AND
DOMESTIC FROM THE MIDDLE OF
TEMPORARY PRACTICES. THAT HAVE
BEEN. CONVICTED OKAY. PERFECT
RECORD IN COURT PROCEEDINGS. ON
THE LEFT OF. THE CONTRACT
DURING THE PAST AND- ON WHAT
WORKED WELL WHAT DIDN'T WORK
AND THEN COME BACK TO DISCUSS.
ANY POTENTIAL FOR EXPANSION OF
THE NINETEEN NINETY ONE
TROUBLES HAVE BEEN. STORY CAN
HAVE EXPERIENCE. OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH LIMITED ENGLISH.
PROFICIENT NON COMPARABLE THE
REQUESTED PAGE. CORPORATE
BECAUSE- THE TROUBLE IS ON
VIDEO AND NOT SPEND TAXES THAT.
EVEN THE TYPE OF STORY.
CURRENTLY THAT. CALCULATED FOR
THE LEGISLATURE MCCORD I REMIND
YOU THAT THE TEMPORARY ORDER.
AND PRACTICES IN THE COURTS
WILL REMAIN IN EFFECT FOR SIX
MONTHS. HOW THE LIFTING OF THE
FAKE WHY PUBLIC HEALTH ORDER
WHICH MEANS WE GET PLENTY OF
TIME. TO EXPLORE THAT TOGETHER
TO GET IT RIGHT AND GET IT DONE
QUICKLY. YOU HAVE TO PUT THE
PHONE POTS. AND HEALTH BENEFITS
THAT COME WITH IT. NEXT PERSON.
NINE ONE FOUR TWO YOU'RE MY IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH THIRTY
SAN ON BEHALF OF STI CAL. FUNNY
TO READ THE FIRST CONCERNS THAT
BY MY COLLEAGUE THAT- REGARDING
REQUESTING LEGISLATURE TO TABLE
BUT TBL. TWO TWO- OR MELT
INSTEAD ALL WE'VE HAD REALLY
ALL PUTTING X. AND THE ENTIRE-
AS IT RELATES TO COURT REPORTER
NOT BEING ABLE TO DO THEIR JOB
AS IT RELATES TO THE OFFICIAL
VERBATIM RECORD I'M NOT. THEN
CREATE. ALATORRE COUNTY FOR
MEDIC SUPPORT A TO PARK THEIR
RIGHTS- ON APPEAL WE THINK THAT
THE ONLY WAY TO GO IS TO WAIT
OUT A RAFT OF THE PANDEMIC
LEARN FROM OUR EXPERIENCES WAIT
FOR THAT TO FIFTY THREE PILOT
TO BE COMPLETED. AND THEN
CONVENE A WORKING GROUP OF ALL
COURT USERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE NOT INADVERTENTLY
EXACERBATING PROBLEMS AT THE
ROUGHLY EQUAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE
WE ALSO HOPE THE LEGISLATURE
WILL CONSIDER WE ALLOCATING THE
ELEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- WITHDREW AS IT RELATES
TO OPERATIONS. COMING OUT OF
THE ADVECTION MORATORIUM WE
WILL GIVE THE AN ONSLAUGHT OF.
FILING THANK YOU. THANKS FOR.
NINE ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
NUTCRACKER WITH THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA BEING
TWO DIGITS OF BRANCH. BACK
UNDER THE RECORDS ARE FACING
CIVIC CENTER NEGATIVE HERE AND
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING BECAUSE OF
IT. I BACKING BEGIN THE ROLLOUT
HOPEFULLY THE CONTENT MAKE OF
THE COMMISSION ON. EMERGENCY
MCCOURT IS JUST GOING TO BE
GETTING HEALTHIER FOR YEARS TO
COME. THURMOND EMERGENCY ACTION
TO RESOLVE THE BACKLOG IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO HAVE
FUN A DIFFICULT ALLOCATED
WORKING A DOUBLE BACKLOG.
HEARING ARTIFICIAL TOOL AND
REMAIN A KEY TOOL AND WORKING
THE BACKLOG. NOW IS THE TIME TO
INCREASE REMOTE HEARING TO GIVE
IT MORE THAN NOT AMONG THEM
ALTHOUGH WE THINK THE DETAIL
COULD BE FLUSHED OUT IN THE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TNCS SUPPORT THE BILL AND
CONCEPT. IMMEDIATE EMERGENCY
ACTION TO YOU TO BE A VIRGIN
MEDIA ARE YOU ACTIVE ACTION TO
UTILIZE TECHNOLOGY INCREASE
BUDGET RESOURCES FOR THE COURT.
AND DO ALL WE CAN TO ENSURE
TIMELY ACCESS. TO JUSTICE FOR
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT PRESS. MY NAME YOUR
LINE IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS SANDY LEVIN
I NEED DIRECTOR THE LOS COUNTY
LOS. AND HE WAS PRESIDENT THE
STATE CAL OF CALIFORNIA COUNTY
LAW LIBRARY BECAUSE OUR- I
THINK GREAT HOW AND TRAUMA
DURING PAST YEAR THERE ARE TWO
LOWER INDIVIDUALS WHO CAN'T
AFFORD REPRESENTATION ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC OF PUBLIC AGENCIES
YOUR COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES ARE
THE SAFETY NET. FOR SELF
REPRESENTED INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
THE STATE WHEN NO ONE ELSE CAN
HELP CHARLIE THOUGH OUR ABILITY
TO HELP HAS BEEN REMITTED CAN
YOU LAW LIBRARIES ARE FUNDED
ALMOST ENTIRELY BY TROUBLE
FILING FEES WE EXPERIENCED A
DRAMATIC DECLINE IN THE
TEACHINGS OF THE DECADE BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC BEND. DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FINALLY IF YOU
TRACKING FURTHER IF CURRENT
NUMBERS CONTINUE CAN YOU LOWER
RIGHT WILL BE SHE PER AS
COMPARED TO A DECADE AGO. A
CRITICAL PART OF CALL THE JUDGE
GAP IS ADDICT FOR CHUNG WALLEYE.
YOU REACH A DEEP LETTER FROM
OUR STATE ORGANIZATION PUT MANY
LETTERS OF SUPPORT STATEWIDE
FROM AID ORGANIZATIONS THE
COMMISSION ON ACCESS TO
TRUSTED. PATRONS AND VOLUNTEER
TO KNOW FIRST HAND THE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES WE PROVIDE
THANK YOU PLEASE FIND THE
FUNDING FOR THIS CRITICAL
COMMUNITY RESOURCE. THANK YOU.
MCPHERSON NINE ONE FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING JOSH DUGGAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE
WITH IRVINE COUNTY TO
CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTED AT THE CALIFORNIA
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSED BURKE COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENT TO PREPARE
FOR AND SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT
DJJ REALIGNMENT AND EIGHTY
NINETEEN FIFTY. THESE RESOURCES
ARE CRITICAL FOR COUNTY TO
PREPARE TO PRODUCE SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOMES WITH THE VULNERABLE
DJJ POPULATION THAT INCLUDES
SOME OF THE MOST ACUTE CASES
AND STATE. TO PRODUCE THESE
OUTCOMES WE MUST INVEST IN
HIGHER LEVEL AND NEW TREATMENT
PROGRAMS RATHER THAN SIMPLY
PLUGGING THIS POPULATION INTO
THE EXISTING LOCAL SYSTEM UNDER
SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE NOT ALL-COUNTIES WILL RECEIVE THE
APPROPRIATE RESOURCES TO
PRODUCE THESE SYSTEM
ENHANCEMENTS BUT THESE.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WILL HELP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PERSON. NINE ONE FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JENNA MYRA
AND THE DIRECTING ATTORNEY FOR
IMPACT LITIGATION POLICY AFFECT
STATE LEGAL SERVICES IN LOS
ANGELES. I'M CALLING ON ISSUE
NUMBER TWO SPECIFICALLY REMOTE
CORPORATE DETAINED WELL WE
SUPPORT ALLOWING NORMAL
PROCEEDINGS AND CIVIL ACTIONS
THE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
SEVERAL OTHERS TO PROCEED WITH
CAUTION AND FOR ATTENTION TO
THE NEEDS AND RIGHTS OF
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT EXPANDING
ACCESS TO REMOTE APPEARANCES
DOES NOT WIDEN ACCESS GAP. TO
PREVENT WIDENING THE GAP REMOTE
APPEARANCES SHOULD BE OPTIONAL
BUT NOT REQUIRED CLAPBOARDS
MUST WORK ON MOBILE DEVICES
THERE NEEDS TO BE A TELEPHONE
OPTIONS AND PROVISIONS NEED TO
BE MADE FOR EFFECTIVE LANGUAGE
AND DISABILITY ACCESS. WE ALSO
AGREE WITH THE NEED FOR
UNIFORMITY AND CONSISTENCY
ACROSS COUNTIES INCLUDING AYE
UNIFORM PLATFORMS AND UNIFORM
POLICIES AND PRACTICES FOR
THINGS LIKE YEAH INTRODUCING
EVIDENCE AND TESTIMONY XTERRA
WE ALSO URGE YOU TO FIND A WAY
TO CLEARLY AND ROBOTIC
COMMUNICATE WITH COMMUNITIES.
THAT INCLUDING IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES AND TO WORK TOGETHER
WITH COMMUNITY PARTNERS
INCLUDING COURT INTERPRETERS
REPORTER AND LAW LIBRARY YOUR
THAT ALL THEIR NEEDS ARE MET
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR ATTENTION
AND CONSTIPATION. THANKS FOR.
MY ONE TWO FIVE YOUR IS OF
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES MY NAME IS
JONATHAN BYRD I REPRESENT ASK
ME LOCAL SIX EIGHTY FIVE AS
SECOND VICE PRESIDENT AND CHIEF
STEWARD I AM ALSO A TWENTY NINE
YEAR JUVENILE PROBATION OFFICER
AND TODAY IS MY TWENTY NINTH
ANNIVERSARY BEING IN THE
DEPARTMENT- I WAS A LITTLE
CONFUSED WHEN I READ THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE BACKGROUND-
WHERE YOU MENTIONED THAT D. Y.
D. IN LOS ANGELES- WE NOTICED
THAT LOS ANGELES MADE A MOTION
LAST WEEK. TO HELP FLEXIBILITY
IN THE USE OF S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY THREE FUNDS WE BELIEVE
THAT PROBATION IS THE PERFECT
CANDIDATE TO HELP OF THE BJJ OF
CLIENTELE-WE HAVE- MOST OF OUR
MEMBERS AND- EMPLOYEES COME
FROM THE COMMUNITY. THEY'RE
EDUCATED AND THEY'RE DEDICATED
AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT- IF YOU
DON'T HAVE GOOD OVERSIGHT ON
OUR EARMARKED THE FUNDS THAT
ARE COMING TO THE COUNTIES TO
GO TO PROBATION THAT SOME OF
THE COUNTIES WILL TRY TO DIVERT
AND USED THE- FOCO DE WHAT THE
WHICH IS NOT BASED ON BEST
PRACTICES ARE EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE BECAUSE THIS
NONEXISTENT. AND SO IT WOULDN'T
BE COST EFFECTIVE- TO USE THOSE
FORMS FUND IN THAT MATTER SO-
WE WOULD HAVE BEEN REQUESTED TO
PLEASE PAY ATTENTION TO THE USE
AND THE- MARKING OF THE FUND.
THANK YOU. NEXT PERCENT. MY
SEVEN EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO THIS
IS ELIZABETH ESPINOSA CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
PROVIDING COMMENT ON ISSUE
THREE UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE I WE WISH TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
RENEWED- LA- PROPOSAL TO CHARGE
COUNTIES FOR STATE CRIME LAB-
AS ALLUDED TO IN THE COMMITTEE
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THE
CHARGING OF FEES WILL
JEOPARDIZE THE QUALITY. AND
CONSISTENCY OF FRANTIC SERVICES
LOCALLY AND RESULT IN LIMITING
AND CURTAILING- THE PURSUIT OF
JUSTICE AND THE ACCESS OF
JUSTICE ACROSS THE STATE THANK
YOU FOR HEARING OUR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU NEXT PERCENT. LINE
ONE EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD TWENTY
YEARS. BRADY BUCKLEY WARRANTED
OR THE COURT. WOULD BE FOR THAT
THAT WOULD BE. EVERY THREATEN
SOMEONE. BUT IT WOULD YOU WOULD
STILL. HELLO HELLO. YES. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME GLORIA MONTANA
WAS THAT GIVEN RIGHTS WATCH I'M
GIVING COMMENT ON THE ISSUE
FIVE THE OFFICE OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION PUBLIC
VETTING STUDY YOUNG AGE TO LIFE
WITHOUT POSSIBILITY POSSIBILITY
OF COL THOMAS GIVE ME VERY
PERSONAL UNDERSTANDING OF THE
ISSUE LOOKING BACK I REALIZE
HOW GOOD HEALTH FOCUSED
INTERVENTIONS OF THE JUVENILE
HAVE HELPED ME AVOID THE
CHOICES THAT I MADE THAT LANDED
ME IN PRISON. IT'S TRONG ó
YC R. WILL MAKE THE U. STRONGER
AND IT WILL MEAN FEWER VICTIMS
OF CRIME IN THE FUTURE ARE YOU
COULD NOT NEED MORE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO BE SUCCESSFUL
WITH A WHITE TEE ARE MUST BE
STAFFED WITH THOSE WHO HAVE THE
EXPERTISE AND EXPERIENCE TO
PROVIDE THE HELP YOU NEED.
WEITERE STAFF SHOULD HAVE
DIRECT EXPERIENCE WITH YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT AB- AND MENTAL
HEALTH AND TRAUMA INFORMED
HEALING CENTER PRACTICES THANK.
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PERCENT. MY
ONE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
OUT. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
TYLER GUN BAN FROM THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN
SACRAMENTO AND GIVING COMMENT
ON ISSUES FIVE REGARDING A
WHITE C. R. MY COMMENT IS THAT
THE PARTS FIRST THE OFFICE
NEEDS MORE STAFF AND FUNDING TO
FACILITATE OVERSEE THE CHAIRMAN
OF ALL USED IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THE INTENT OF A
WIFE YARDS TO PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED ACCOUNTABILITY OVER
COUNTY LOCAL INVESTMENT IN A
CONTINUUM OF ALL APPROACHES IN
FIFTY IN THE STATE SECONDLY THE
OFFICE MUST INCLUDE THE RIGHT
EXPERTISE AND EXPERIENCE AND
SHOULD NOT HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
BIASED AND THEREFORE SHOULD
HAVE DIRECT EXPERIENCE. AS AN
EXPERIENCED PERSON MYSELF I
KNOW THAT THOSE WITH DIRECT
EXPERIENCE PROVIDE VALUABLE
INSIGHT TOWARDS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF HOLISTIC
PROGRAM SERVICES. LASTLY THE
CREATION OF A Y. C. R. IS
MONUMENTAL AS A RESULT OF
INCONSISTENT THE OVERSIGHT
CALIFORNIA HAS FAILED TO
CONDUCT A NEEDS BASED DATA
ANALYSIS AND THEREFORE RESULTED
IN THE MISTS ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES WHICH IS STILL ARE
GRAPPLING WITH CITY I THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION AND I URGE. YOU
TO PRIORITIZE THE WELL BEING OF
OUR YOU. THANK NEXT PERSON. I'M
ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I SPENDING AS WITH
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION I'M
HERE TO TALK ABOUT TWO
DIFFERENT ISSUES- ALL START
WITH ISSUE TWO- WE ARE POSTED
YET JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S ABILITY
TO PAY. ARE JUST BEYOND EXACTLY
DOESN'T WORK IT'S WHY WE A. R.
C. ALONG WITH A BROAD COALITION
BUT AFTER JUSTICE CALIFORNIA- I
HAVE WORKED TO ELIMINATE THE-
LOCALLY AND CAL. IN THAT
THROUGHOUT. VARIOUS COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO STATEWIDE-
DID IT VERY LEGISLATURE LAST
YEAR- AND I'M- REGARDS TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE. THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE WHAT
FRANKIE GOODMAN- DOMINATE YOUNG
AND MY COLLEAGUE MIGUEL GARCIA
STATED. SO MUCH WEIGHT IN THE
BALANCE HERE AND WE'RE HUGELY
SUPPORTIVE OF ENSURING THAT
ADEQUATE FUNDING IS
APPROPRIATED TO THE OFFICE. AND
FINING AND I FIND THE NOTION
THAT LASTED SUFFICIENTTO VERY-
IS VERY TROUBLING AND FRANKLY
DANGEROUS. NOT ONLY THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
STUDIED A BIT OF THE AREA OF
THE BRAIN AND ITS DEVELOPMENT
IN THE IMPACTS OF TRAUMA- IT
IN. IN THE POSITION- AND NOT
LAW ENFORCEMENT- WHO WHO WHO.
OFTENTIMES BUT- WHICH ARE.
UNDERLYING WELL THANK YOU. NEXT
PERCENT. ONE ONE EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GREETINGS MY NAME IS HAN
GOING ON AND I'M A TWENTY THREE
YEAR PROBATION OFFICER I SERVE
AS THE PRESIDENT. OF AFT LOCAL
FIFTY FIVE L. A. COUNTY DEPUTY
PROBATION OFFICER UNION AND I'M
ALSO ELECTED COUNCIL MEMBER FOR
THE CITY OF MONTEREY PARK AND
SPEAKING TODAY REGARDING SENATE
BILL EIGHT TWENTY THREE. I
SPENT MY ENTIRE CAREER IN
JUVENILE MOST OF IT WORKING
ASIAN GANG UNIT THE ONE
STAKEHOLDERS TALK ABOUT RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN CULTURAL
APPROPRIATE CARE I BELIEVE THAT
pTHE COMMUNITY. AS OTHERS BEFORE
ME HAVE STATED YOU LOOK DOWN.
AND THAT'S THE GOOD NEWS
CLEARLY. CALL APPROPRIATE
REFERENCE. THAT EMPLOYING.
TOGETHER WITH OUR- AND SOCIAL
SERVICE AND MENTAL. AND THE
PRIVATE COMMUNITY BASED
PARTNERS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL OUR
WORK IS. NEVER LEFT TO USE
REMAINING PROVISIONS THAT
FACILITIES AND THOSE HAVE BEEN
REMANDED TO DJJ. THAT WILL NOT
BE UCH A PERVASIVE FACILITIES
PERSONAL TICKET SB IN TWENTY
THREE ARE INDEED THE HIGHEST
RISK OF NEW. THIS IS NOT A
POPULAR WITH WHICH WHICH
EXPERIMENT. WE MUST EMPLOY
EVIDENCE BASED BEST PRACTICES
WITH OUTCOME. MEASUREMENTS IN
ORDER TO REHABILITATE THEM AND
TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES OUR
COMMUNITY AND FAITH BASED
PARTNERS. COMING TO PUBLIC
FACILITIES DALY AND OUR
DEDICATED STAFF. WE ARE PEACE
OFFICERS NOT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. WE MAINTAIN THE PEACE
SO THAT KIDS. AND THOSE WHO
COME INTO THE FIELD SPECIAL
TEAMS TO PROVIDE SERVICE TO OUR
STATE. WE ARE MORE THAN GIVE
OFFICERS WE CARE DEEPLY AND WE
DO AND WE DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER TO TURN HIS LIFE AROUND.
THEY CAN HAVE THE BEST SHOT AT
A PRODUCTIVE LIFE THANK YOU.
THANKS PERCENT. AND ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD HI HI MY NAME IS ORTEZ
AND I LIVE AND I REPRESENT THE
ENTIRE WITH SEVEN COALITION IS
NOT INTENDED TO AND GIVING
COMING ON ISSUE FIVE COPIES OF
YOU CAN COMMUTER SERRATION.
OPTED NEED MORE STAFF
COMPLAINTS BUILD BEAUTIFUL. THE
TRIMMING OF ALL YOU IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM. OFFICE
MUST HAVE WITH RIGHT EXPERTISE
AND EXPERIENCE THAT SAID INCOME
FROM LONG. BACKGROUND I SPENT
ABOUT THE MY MAJORITY OF TIME
WITH THEM PROVISIONS AND THE
AGE OF TWELVE YEARS OLD AND I
COULD TELL YOU PROMOTE A UNIQUE
POINT OF VIEW. OF SOMEBODY THAT
WOULD DIRECTLY IMPACTED NOT
SOMEBODY THAT WE WEREN'T THERE
BUT SOME OF THOSE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY PROBATION THAT.
WOULD HELP ME TO REENTER MY
COMMUNITY WITH CREDIBLE
MESSENGERS. PEOPLE WITHIN MY
COMMUNITY PEOPLE THAT. REACHED
OUT TO ME ONE HOUR PARTS WALK
WILL BE WAS DOING NOTHING BUT
ME IN ROOM I THINK THAT I. WAS
SO WHAT CAN I YOU TURN THREE
HOURS ALONG WITH THEM TO HELP
ME WELL BE IN THE COMP. SO I
STRONGLY BELIEVE AND- STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE
CREDIBLE MESSENGERS WITHIN THE
WITHIN THE- THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. MCPHERSON. NINE ONE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DEREK
MORGAN ON BEHALF OF THE BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
SPEAKING ON ISSUE FIVE AND I
WANT TO ECHO THE CRITIQUES
RAISED BY. MEMBERS AND- THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
AND- THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND. THAT BIG PROPOSED FUNDING
AND SCOPE FOR THE- I. T. R. IS
INADEQUATE COMPARED TO WHICH
CHARGE. ALL OF OUR USE. DESERVE
BETTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THE NEXT PERSON. NINE
ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS DAVID
LIEDERMAN A FAMILY LAW
PRACTITIONER IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND PAST CHAIR OF THE
FAMILY LOGS THAT GIVE THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OLD STATE
PARK CALIFORNIA. I SPEAK ON
ISSUE TO THE TRAILER BILL IN
REMOTE HEARINGS. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE CONTINUATION OF
REMOTE HERE IS THE POST
PANDEMIC WORLD. WHAT THE USE OF
THESE HEARING THE ROAD HEARINGS
DURING THE PANDEMIC HAS SHOWN
IS THAT THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASE IN ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
THE DEPARTMENT CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES HAS SEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN THE APPEARANCES
VERSUS NON APPEARANCES FOR
CASES THAT THAT DEAL WITH LOWER
INCOME- INCOME PEOPLE. FOR
PRIVATE COUNSEL THERE'S A HUGE
SAVINGS AND IN TERMS OF TRAVEL-
TRANSITION TIME- AS DISCUSSED
IN THIS IN THIS EVENING'S
HEARINGS- THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION COSTS I
HAVE TO MEET THE CLIENT SAVINGS
FOR HEARING IN REDUCING
ATTORNEY TRAVEL TIME ON
AVERAGE. IS BETWEEN EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS DEPENDING ON
THE GEOGRAPHY. FOR ON REPRESENT
AND- CLIENTS ARE FOR
UNREPRESENTED PARTIES- REMOTE
HEARINGS ME ACCESS TO THE COURT
SYSTEM VERSUS NOT HAVING A
VOICE. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE IN
AN UNDERCOVER IF YOU IF YOU'RE
IF YOU'RE A OF- LOWER RESOURCES
THE REALITY IS TO GET TO
HEARING YOU NEED TO TAKE OFF A
DAY OF WORK YOU'VE GOT A
PROBLEM POTENTIALLY BY BUS- AND
THAT MAKES IT ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THEM TO HAVE ACCESS TO
COURTS TO GET- TO RESOLVE THEIR
FAMILY LAW ISSUES TO. OCCUR THE
PARMA CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES
THERE'S BETTER ACCESS TO
INTERPRET SERVICE LAST. COUNT
BACK CHANGE I'M SORRY. PLEASE
PLEASE HAVE A BRIEF COMMENTS.
SURE. THAT JUST WRAPPED UP I'M
NOT ALL CONTACTED OF ACCESS TO-
INTERPRETS FROGHALL LANGUAGES
IN OF THAT REMOTE HEARINGS
INTERPRETS TO MEAN ANY
GEOGRAPHY- AND ENNIS'S MATTERS
IN IN ANY COUNTY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THANK YOU. EXPERTS ON.
OUR LAST COMMENT COMES FROM
MINE. ONE NINETY ONE. BEHALF OF
THE APPLY TO BOTH MEN OF COLOR
REGARDING STAFFING AND
RESOURCES FOR THE OFFICE WITH
YOU THANK COMMITTEE RESTORATION.
THE OCCUPANT YOU THINK MEETING
RESTORATION NEED MORE STAFF AND
FUNDING FOR THE BILL- WHAT THE
ARTS POSSIBLE OVERSEEING THE
TREATMENT ALL YOU IN THE TRUCK
WITH THE IN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I MUST BE PUT
ADEQUATELY TO ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA YOU GET THE
DEVELOPMENT AND CARE THEY NEED.
BLACKLEY THE CLOSER DJJ WITH
MATT TO COMPLETELY TRANSFORM
CALIFORNIA'S JUVENILE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO ONE FOCUSED ON
PUBLIC HEALTH AND YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT. SHOULD CONSIDER
THE TAPPAN WE BELIEVE THE
OFFICE MUST HAVE THE RIGHT
STAFF WITH THE RIGHT EXPERIENCE
AND THEY SHOULDN'T COMP OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR PROBATION THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
NEXT PERSON. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q. THANK
YOU WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN TWO DAYS
HEARING AND OFFERED COMMENTER
TESTIMONY RASTA QUESTION WITH
THAT WE WILL ADJOURN.